ALRIGHT GOOD MORNING WE'RE GONNA
BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING SOMEBODY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE -- TODAY WE HAVE.
A VARIETY OF MISCELLANEOUS
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION A
PROGRAMS WAY TO OUR OUR DATA
SYSTEM THE C. COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
AS WELL AS OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS SCHOOL NUTRITION AND
SOME EDUCATION BUDGET PROPOSALS
WERE VERY EXPECT SOME OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES TO TO POP
IN AND GIVE US THEIR PERSPECTIVE
ON EDUCATION -- PROPOSALS IN THE
BUDGET WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT
THIS YEAR.
SO WITH THAT LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE WE WON'T DO THAT BUT ONLY
ONE WILL BEGIN WITH.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE TO PART OF
EDUCATION THE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY LET'S THAT BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER.
ONE DâN HANOVER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
SEGMENTS OF PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION.
OF INSTEAD OF THE INCREASING
THEIR DATA COLLECTION AND
ANALYSIS EFFORTS OVER THE PAST
DECADE.
HOWEVER THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THAT THESE EFFORTS
HAVE LARGELY BEEN ISOLATED FROM
EACH OTHER.
MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO GAIN
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW OTHER
STUDENTS PERFORM.
ONCE THEY GET TO COLLEGE FOR
INTO THE WORK FORCE.
CONVERSELY CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ARE
NOT ABLE TO OBSERVE METRICS FOR
HOW THEIR STUDENTS.
DID DURING THEIR TIMES IN K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS.
AS CALIFORNIA SCHOOL STRIVE TO
INCREASE STUDENT SUCCESS AND
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES IT WILL
BE CRITICAL TO HAVE ACCESS TO
DATA THAT CAN HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPACT OF EDUCATIONAL
INITIATIVES.
ON A STUDENT'S ABILITY TO
PROGRESS THROUGH EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND INTO THE WORK
FORCE. TO THIS END THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME PROP
ART NAM PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. TO PLAN FOR AND
DEVELOP A CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS RELEASED
TRAILER BILL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE DATA SYSTEM.
WITH THE GOAL OF EVENTUALLY
CONNECTING STUDENT INFORMATION
FROM EARLY EDUCATION PROVIDERS
K. TWELVE SCHOOLS HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS EMPLOYERS.
OTHER WORKFORCE ENTITIES AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES.
ADDITIONALLY THECREATION OF A
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO OPTIMIZE
EXISTING PROGRAMS.
ENHANCE ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
AND CONDUCT RESEARCH ON
EDUCATION OUTCOMES.
FURTHER SUCH A SYSTEM WILL ALLOW
THE STATE TO BETTER SUPPORT THE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND ADULTS IN
THE STATE'S PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEMS.
THE AGENDA PROVIDE THE SUMMARY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S BEFORE
PROPOSAL.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
SPECIFIC ASPECTS OF THE LANGUAGE.
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TASK
A WORK GROUP COMPRISED OF STATE
ENTITIES WITH OWNERSHIP OF DATA
THAT WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE
SYSTEM.
WITH DEVELOPING TO REPORTS
CONTAINING RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW BEST TO CREATE A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST REPORT WILL FOCUS ON
BROAD OVERARCHING ISSUES SUCH AS
GOALS SYSTEM GOVERNANCE.
AN ARCHITECT AND ARCHITECTURE
AND DATA PRIVACY.
THE SECOND REPORT WILL OUTLINE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR MORE
SPECIFIC ASPECTS SUCH AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE.
WAYS TO INCREASE DATA QUALITY.
ANALYST A PARTNERENTITIES THAT
SHOULD BE CONNECTED TO THE DATA
SYSTEM.
THE LANGUAGE ALSO CALLS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND REQUEST THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. TO BEGIN DEVELOPING
A MEANS OF MATCHING STUDENT
RECORDS AT THE TIME A STUDENT
APPLIES TO AN INSTITUTE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THIS WILL COMPLETE ONE OF THE
ESSENTIAL STEPS OF A CRADLE TO
CAREER DATA SYSTEM AND ALLOW THE
STATE TO ADVANCE ALONG AN
AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS EXCITED TO
BEGIN WORK ON THIS PROJECT THAT
WILL CONNECT OUR EXISTING
DISPARATE DATA SYSTEMS AND
PROVIDE US WITH A BETTER LOOK.
AT WHAT HELPS OUR STUDENTS TO
SUCCEED WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
POSTING HOUSE IN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OUR OFFICE JUST RELEASED A BRIEF
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE
SERGEANT HAS DISTRIBUTED COPIES
IT'S TITLED THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET CREATING
AN INTEGRATED.
EDUCATION DATA SYSTEM.
WE AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT
HAVING AN INTEGRATED DATA SYSTEM
WOULD BE A BIG ASSET FOR
CALIFORNIA SUCH A SYSTEM IS
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES OVER THE YEARS.
PAGE SIX OF THE BRIEF -- FIGURE.
TO THIS SOME CROSS CUTTING
ACROSS A SEGMENTAL QUESTIONS
THAT COULD BE ANSWERED MORE
READILY IF OUR EDUCATION DATA
SYSTEMS WERE CONNECTED
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE.
REALLY USEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE
AS WELL AS EDUCATORS PARENTS AND
STUDENTS. FOR EXAMPLE THE IMPACT
OF EARLY EDUCATION PROGRAMS ON
SCHOOL READINESS FOR CHILDREN
POST SECONDARY OUTCOMES OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PATHWAYS
PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE.
PAGES FOR FIVE OF THE BRIEF
PROVIDES A SUMMARY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND WE THINK
IT MAKES SENSE AS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TO START WITH THE CORE
EDUCATION SEGMENTS AND THEN
BUILD INCREMENTALLY FROM THERE.
THAT SAID WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
WE SHARE STAFF CONCERNS RAISED
IN YOUR AGENDA ABOUT THE LACK OF
REALLY MUCH OF A ROLE AT ALL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS PROJECT.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THE LEGISLATURE'S ONLY ROLE
WOULD BE UP TO APPROPRIATE THE
MONEY.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION MAKING
THE DECISIONS FROM THERE.
IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL PROVIDES AN EX DOES NOT
PROVIDE AN EXPLICIT REQUIREMENT.
FOR THE STATE TO GO THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHED A PLANNING PROCESS
FOR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS IT PROJECTS AND GIVEN
THE STATE'S A CHECKERED.
PAST WITH IT PROJECTS WE THINK
IT'S RISKY NOT TO USE THE
ESTABLISHED PROCESS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL PROVIDES
QUITE A BIT OF MONEY FOR
WORKGROUPS TO MEET AND DISCUSS
WHEN IT INTEGRATED DATA SYSTEM
MIGHT LOOK LIKE AND WHO SHOULD
GOVERN IT.
YET THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
COMMISSIONED WORK GROUPS LIKE
THESE IN THE PAST.
THE SO CALLED SB TWELVE NINETY
EIGHT WORK GROUPS WHICH INCLUDED
REPRESENTATION FROM THE SEGMENTS
HERE AT THIS TABLE DEVELOPS A
DETAILED ROAD MAP FOR DEVELOPING
AN INTEGRATED DATA SYSTEM.
ANOTHER WORK GROUP MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW THAT
SYSTEM SHOULD BE GOVERNED.
IN RESPONSE TO THE S. B. TWELVE
NINETY EIGHT WORK GROUPS THE
LEGISLATURE EVEN PASSED
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE CREATING A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. TO MANAGE THE SYSTEM
TO DEVELOP AND MANAGE THE SYSTEM.
AND THAT WOULD INVOLVE THE THE
SEGMENTS K. TWELVE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS AS WELL AS
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS.
THAT LEGISLATION WAS ULTIMATELY
VETOED BY THEN GOVERNOR BROWN
BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE BUT RATHER
THAN STARTING ALL IT OVER AGAIN
WITH ANOTHER WORK GROUP AND
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR ANOTHER
WORK GROUP WE THINK A BETTER
APPROACH WOULD BE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO LEVERAGE THESE
PAST EFFORTS.
TO REALLY LEARN WHAT THAT TO
REALLY.
BUILD ON WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
LEARNED AS A STATE.
SO PAGE EIGHT OF THE BRIEF.
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER LAYS OUT
SOME RECOMMENDED STEPS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS TO MAKE SURE
THE LEGISLATURE PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND GUIDANCE OF THE
SYSTEM OVERSIGHT OF THE SYSTEM.
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PROJECT HAS A MINIMAL RISK
OF FAILURE.
AND WE WAN TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE THAT THE THAT THE PROJECT IN
THE APPROACH REALLY BUILDS ON
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND THE PAST EFFORTS -- THAT THE
STATE HAS ALREADY UNDERTAKEN.
SO SPECIFICALLY WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ENACT LEGISLATION
CREATING A JPA ALONG THE LINES
OF WHAT THE LEGISLATURE ALREADY.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WITH
SENATE BILL.
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATION SPECIFY THAT THE
GPAS TO INCLUDE THE SEGMENTS --
AS MEMBER AGENCIES SO THE ONES
CONTRIBUTED THE DATA AS WELL AS
NON SEGMENTAL REPRESENTATION
SEARCHES THE ADMINISTRATION AND
BIPARTISAN REPRESENTATION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THEN END THIS JPA
COMPOSITION IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT AN SP TWELVE NINETY EIGHT
WORKGROUP.
ALREADY RECOMMENDED.
SO WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATION.
AND TELL THE JPA TO BUILD THE
STATUS SYSTEM INCREMENTALLY
GRADUALLY STARTING WITH THE CORE
EDUCATION SEGMENTS.
AND THEN BUILDING FROM THERE
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL AND WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATION
SPECIFY THE GPA IS TO DEVELOP A
CENTRALIZED DATA SYSTEM THAT
FOLLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES.
PLANNING PROCESS FOR STATE IT
PROJECTS.
FINALLY THE LEGISLATURE.
COULD APPROVE THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PUT FORTH FOR THIS PROJECT
EARMARKED FOR THIS PROJECT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEM
WOULD BE CHARGED WITH NOTIFYING
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THROUGH THE BUDGET
ACCESS SECTION LETTER PROCESS.
WHICH WHICH WHAT IT DOES IS HAS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTIFY
THE JAIL B. C. PRIOR TO ALLOCATE
IN ANY ROUND OF FUNDING AND THAT
FUNDING IN TURN WOULD BE
CONDITION.
ON THE GPA HITTING CERTAIN
MILESTONES SUCH AS DEVELOPING A
MULTI YOUR WORK PLANNED
DEVELOPING A BUDGET.
DEVELOPING PROTOCOLS IN THEIR
INDUSTRY STANDARD FOR DATA
PRIVACY AND DATA SECURITY.
SO AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE
PANELISTS CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
HAS A NUMBER OF EXAMPLES OF DATA
SHARING.
GOING ON IN THE STATE AND THE
LEGISLATURE IT REALLY IS IN A
GOOD POSITION NOW TO PULL ALL
THE STATE TOGETHER WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DEVELOP A
DATA SYSTEM.
THAT CAN REALLY BE HELPFUL -- IN
INFORMING POLICY AND PRACTICE
GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT WE CAN HEAR FROM
OUR DEPARTMENTS.
BERMAN OF EDUCATION AND THE
HIRING DEPARTMENT'S.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS IN BECAUSE HONEST AND
DIRECTOR OF ANALYSIS MEASUREMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORTING
DIVISION AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AND ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND THANK
YOU FOR INVITING US TO BE PART
OF THE PANEL TODAY TO SPEAK ON
THE GOVERNOR'S CRADLE TO CAREER
PROPOSAL.
IT'S AN EXCITING TIME TO BE AN
EDUCATION DATA.
WORKING IN THIS FIELD --
ESPECIALLY AS OUR K. TWELVE
STUDENT LEVEL SYSTEM CAL PADS
CELEBRATES ITS TEN YEAR
ANNIVERSARY.
WE ARE AN IDEAL POSITION TO
BEGIN THIS WORK TO DEVELOP A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM WITH
OUR HEART HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM PARTNERS.
THE SUPERINTENDENT WANTED ME TO
MENTION THAT FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE SUPPORT SYSTEM INTEGRATION TO
BETTER SUPPORT STUDENTS.
AS WE APPROACH THIS ISSUE WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT WHO NEEDS
WHAT INFORMATION AND FOR WHAT
PURPOSE AND AT THAT THE CENTER
SHOULD BE HELPING TO FACILITATE
A BETTER STUDENT EXPERIENCE.
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN IS VERY
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL MAY WANT TO HELP
CONNECTS SYSTEMS WHERE IT MAKES
SENSE.
IN THAT IN THAT REGARD AND IN
ITS AND FOLLOWING THE ELLIE OWES --
REMARKS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH MOVING FORWARD.
WE CONSIDER THE OPTIONS IN A
FACILITATED SETTING WHICH IS
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
OFFERS THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSAL
I THINK REFLECTS WHAT THE
SEGMENTS ARE DOING RIGHT NOW
WE'VE BEEN MEETING SENSE --
SINCE CHRISTMAS TIME ON A
MONTHLY BASIS TO HELP FACILITATE
A DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW TO SHARE
DATA.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
PRODUCE A REPORT ON HOW MANY
STUDENTS GO TO COLLEGE.
THAT'S BECAUSE IT IS AT DATA
THAT WE DO NOT RECEIVE FIVE FROM
THE SEGMENTS IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE TO PURCHASE FROM THE
NATIONAL STUDENT CLEARINGHOUSE.
AT A COST OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS A YEAR.
THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR WILL BE
ABLE TO PRODUCE THAT REPORT IN
PART BECAUSE OF THE JOINT
AGREEMENT WITH THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO HELP COVER THE
COST.
MOVING FORWARD WITH SAID DATA
SHARING AGREEMENTS THAT WERE
DEVELOPING RIGHT NOW WITH THE
STATEMENTS OF THE GENTLEMAN AT
MY TABLE AT THE TABLE HERE.
I THINK IT WILL BE ABLE TO AVOID
THOSE COSTS NO VOIGTS
DESCRIPTION -- TO IT AS DATA
SOURCES OUTSIDE OF THE STATE AND
RATHER DEPEND ON OUR PARTNERS
INSIDE OF THE STATE.
THE FIELD IS READY NOW FOR THIS
TYPE OF SYSTEM AFTER NEARLY TEN
YEARS OF COLLECTING DATA AT THE
STUDENT LEVEL FOR THE STATE FOR
K. TWELVE EDUCATION WE HAVE
BETTER DATA QUALITY THEM ON WHAT
WE STARTED WITH IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE IN FACT WERE ABLE TO
USE OUR STUDENT.
LEVEL DATA SYSTEM TO REGISTER
STUDENTS TO TAKE OUR STUDENT
TESTS ART RATHER ARE OURS GRADE
LEVEL TEST SMARTER BALANCED AND
TODAY WE PEAKED AT SIX HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS CAN
CURRENTLY TAKING THAT TEST AGAIN
LEVERAGING THE CAL PAD SYSTEM.
I WANT TO MENTION THAT DATA IS
ONLY THE QUALITY OF THAT DATE IS
ONLY AS GOOD AS HOW CLOSE YOU
ARE TO THE DATA SO WITH THE
STUDENT LEVEL DATA COLLECTION
THAT WE DO.
WE'RE GETTING A DIRECTLY FROM
DISTRICTS IF WE WERE TO THEN
SEND IT OVER TO YET ANOTHER DATA
SOURCE YOU MAY LOSE.
THE QUALITY OF THE DATA --
BECAUSE IT FOR THE WAY YOU GET
FROM THE DATA -- THE MORE --
OPPORTUNITIES THERE ARE FOR A
FOR A LACK OF TRANSLATION.
I ALSO WANTED TO MENTION --
THERE'S THAT THAT THE
SERIOUSNESS I THINK FROM ALL THE
SEGMENTS ABOUT -- SECURITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE FOLLOWING --
AND WE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S BEST --
UNDER FEDERAL AND STATE PRIVACY
LAWS TO ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE AFFORDED UNDER
THESE LAWS.
WE ALSO MUST BE CONSIDERATE
PRESERVING STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
DIGNITY IN OUR DATA COLLECTION
AND THE SHARING OF THIS DATA.
AS STUDENTS MOVE FROM ONE LEVEL
TO THE NEXT AND GIVEN THE
INFORMATION WE CURRENTLY NOW
JOINT P. POPULATES CERTAIN
INFORMATION SUCH AS WHERE THEY
ARE FOSTER YOU STUDENT OVER
THERE HOMELESS STUDENT.
ADDITIONALLY THE SHINE OF
CERTAIN INFORMATION SUCH AS
DISCIPLINE RECORDS MAYBE
RELEVANT AT DURING THE
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION BUT ARE NOT LIKELY NO
LONGER RELEVANT AS A STUDENT
INTERNS ARE INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION.
I WANTED TO SHIFT TO THE BRIEF
DISCUSSION IN THE STAFF REPORT
ABOUT EARLY EDUCATION DATA AND
THIS IS AN AREA THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS.
A MAJOR ROLE IN IN THE SENSE
THAT -- WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
COLLECTING AND REPORTING AND
DATA FOR THE EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE PROGRAMS THAT WE OPERATE.
AND THESE PROGRAMS OF COURSE ARE
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
EDUCATIONAL DATA THAT WE COLLECT
AND ARE ANDERSON -- ESSENTIAL
FOR UNDERSTANDING RESOURCE
ALLOCATIONS AS WELL AS
INTERESTING IMPACT OF THESE
EARLY EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
BUT UNLIKE THAT K. TWELVE SYSTEM
AND ARE AS TO LEVEL DATA SYSTEM
AT THE K. TWELVE LEVEL EARLY
LEARNING CARE PROGRAM
INFORMATION DATA.
COLLECTED FOR THESE PROGRAMS ARE
COLLECTED FROM A MIX OF ELEAZAR
AND NON ELEAZAR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS MULTIPLE
SETTING SUCH AS CENTERS FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES AND LICENSE
EXEMPT FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR PROVIDERS.
THERE IS NO INDIVIDUALIZED
STUDENT DATA -- IDENTIFIER THE
THE THE EARLY HEAD SYSTEM LACKS
A STUDENT A STUDENT ID -- WHILE
THEY'RE ABLE TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ON DEMOGRAPHICS
FAMILY SIZE AGE OF A CHILD THERE
IS NO -- CONSISTENCY FROM
PROGRAM TO TO OUR IN PROVIDER TO
PROVIDER.
SO -- WE ALSO ARE VERY HOPEFUL
THAT THE WORKGROUP INCLUDING OUR
EARLY EDUCATION -- DIVISION AS A
MEMBER OF THAT WORK GROUP THAT
WE CAN FOCUS ON HOW TO DEVELOP A
UNIQUE ID AT THE EARLY EDUCATION
LEVEL.
THAT WE CAN USE THIS DATA FOR
PROGRAM MONITORING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND TO ENSURE --
EQUITY AND ALLOCATING RESOURCES
AND TRACKING TRENDS IN
ADDRESSING KEY POLICY ISSUES
SUCH AS DECREASED ACCESS TO CARE
AND A QUALITY CARE AND LEARNING
MORE ABOUT THE CHILDREN SERVED
IN OUR PROGRAMS.
SO THAT I'M HAPPY THAT RESPOND
TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE -- CHRISTMAS MANY OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANK YOU FOR TODAY'S
HEARING -- THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS THAT WE OFTEN REFERENCE
CALLS ON OUR SYSTEM TO FOSTER
GREATER USE OF DATA THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT WE THINK IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AND
THEREFORE WE SUPPORT THE%
INCLUSION.
OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET CAN SYSTEM OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
WE COLLECT LOTS OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF DATA CURRENTLY THE
PROPOSAL TALKS ABOUT STUDENT
LEVEL DATA SOLE FOCUS MY
COMMENTS THERE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT -- YOU KNOW -- I THINK AN
IMPORTANT STARTING POINT FOR
THIS CONVERSATION IS WHAT IS OUR
GOAL AND COLLECTING DATA AND
CONNECTING DATA WE CAN DO IT FOR
A VARIETY OF PURPOSES.
WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT -- THREE TO
MAKE BETTER POLICY. TO ENABLE
PRACTITIONERS TO DESIGN
INTERVENTIONS THAT BEST MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS.
BOB AND TO GIVE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES BETTER INFORMATION TO
USE WHEN MAKING EDUCATIONAL
DECISIONS -- YOU KNOW AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
CONSISTENT -- EL AL'S
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK WE'LL
NEED TO PRIORITIZE ACROSS THOSE
BUT I DON'T THINK.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T LOSE SIGHT OF THOSE
ESPECIALLY THE THIRD AROUND
GIVING -- PRACTITIONERS --
INFORMATION THAT THEY CAN USE TO
BETTER DECIDE THE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY WE CONDUCT -- AND
COLLECT DATA FROM THE SEVENTY
TWO SEVENTY THREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
WE COLLECTED ON STUDENT
ENROLLMENT COURSES TAKEN
SERVICES STUDENTS ACCESS STUDENT
AWARDS WE ALSO COLLECTED ON
FACULTY AND STAFF WE DO SO
ANNUALLY AND BY TERM.
WE SHARE THAT DATA TODAY WITH A
VARIETY OF ENTITIES IN THE
RECEIVED DATA FROM A VARIETY OF
ENTITIES -- THESE INCLUDE THE
OTHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS WITH YOU SEE CSU IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION --
WE SHARE IT WITH STATE AGENCIES
AND WE COLLECT -- MATCHED IT
WOULD STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IN THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION.
THAT WE AGGREGATE OUR DATA AND
SUBMIT IT TO OTHERS INCLUDING
THE INTEGRATED POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION DATA SYSTEM.
ADMINISTERED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE ALSO PARTNER WITH
ORGANIZATIONS FOCUSED ON
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS THESE
INCLUDE THE EDUCATION RESULTS
PARTNERSHIP OF OUR OWN RP GROUP
AND ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA.
TYPICALLY THROUGH AMMO USE WITH
EACH OF THOSE ENTITIES.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT KIND OF
A PROBLEM CENTER PROBLEM
STATEMENTS THAT WE THINK DRIVES
THIS CONVERSATION -- THE FIRST
STAR CHALLENGES AROUND
MANAGEMENT OF DATA -- DATA
IDENTIFICATION CLASSIFICATION
AND RECONCILIATION ALL OF WHICH
WE THINK THAT AND IMPEDES OUR
ABILITY CHALLENGES IMPEDE OUR
ABILITY -- TO GENERATE INSIGHTS
FROM OUR DATA -- THE SECOND IS
AROUND SECURITY -- INCLUDING --
THE NEED FOR AUTHORIZATIONS FOR
DATA ACCESS AND HOW WE MANAGE --
THE PROPER USE AND DISCLOSURE OF
DATA.
AND THEN THE TREMENDOUS COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH BOB CONNECTING
DATED TODAY WE'VE HAD GOOD
SUCCESS IN NEGOTIATING CROSS
SEGMENT MENTAL AGREEMENTS
ANOTHER AMMO YEARS -- THE THESE
GENERALLY FOLLOW MONTHS OF LEGAL
NEGOTIATIONS AND SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TECHNICAL WORK.
AND SO WHAT WE CAN DO THIS WORK
TODAY I THINK THE BENEFITS OF A
NEW STATEWIDE DATA SYSTEM --
INCLUDE -- THE FACT THAT ACCESS
TO DATE IT WOULD NOT BE
DEPENDENT ON THE PRIORITIES OF
THE INDIVIDUAL SEGMENTS OUR
ABILITY TO SHARE DATA --
GENERALLY FOLLOWS A PROCESS BY
WHICH WE PRIORITIZE REQUESTS
BASED ON OUR GOALS WHICH MAY BE
DIFFERENT FROM THE GOALS THAT
OTHERS HAVE.
I ASSUME OTHER ENTITIES ARE A
VALUE ADDING OUR REQUEST FOR
DATA BASED ON THEIR OWN
PRIORITIES.
WE THINK FEWER TRANSACTIONS OF
STUDENT LEVEL DATA -- WOULD EASE
CONCERNS ABOUT DATA SECURITY
RIGHT NOW EACH TIME PEOPLE AND
TURNED IT NMO YOU THEIR MATCHING
INDIVIDUAL STIRRED LEVEL DATA
USING STUDENT IDENTIFIERS WHICH
MAKES IT.
WHITE CLEAR THAT -- THERE COULD
BE SECURITY CONCERNS.
ABOUT OBVIOUSLY THE EFFICIENCIES
OF HAVING A CENTRAL -- PROCESSOR
ENTITY BY WHICH WERE CONNECTING
DATA.
SO WE THANK YOU THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS -- FOR
THE PRIORITY ON THIS THIS YEAR
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
IF YOU -- ED SULLIVAN -- SYSTEM
VICE SAID CHANCELLOR PRINCE TO
TIONAL RESEARCH ANALYSIS UP FOR
THIS ISSUE -- AS MANY OF YOU
WERE WEARING TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
C. ISSUE LAUNCHED FACE TO OVER
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
THE SAME VICIOUS PLANTS CENTERED
ON THE ELIMINATION OF EQUITY
GAPS.
ESTABLISHED AGGRESSIVE DEGREE
COMPLETION TARGETS FOR EACH
CAMPUS IN THE CSU SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE.
OUR GOALS WERE BASED IN RICH
DATA.
AND THE STRATEGIES UNDERTAKEN TO
ACHIEVE THEM WERE INFORMED.
ARE INFORMED BY AN ONGOING DATA
ANALYSIS.
ALONG WITH HER SIBLINGS SYSTEMS.
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF SUCH A SYSTEM
WE RETUNE ROUTINELY PURSUE-MEMORANDA UNDERSTANDING.
WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE WHAT
WORK IS BEST APPROACHED IN
PHASES.
WITH INITIAL FOCUS ON EFFORTS
THAT REQUIRE MODEST INVESTMENTS
IN NEW INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN
BE FLEXIBLE FOR FUTURE EXPANSION.
AM SERVE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
AS THEY NAVIGATE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS.
EXPANDING PROJECTS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE GUIDANCE
INITIATIVE IN TRANSCRIPT
CALIFORNIA WOULD PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE BENEFIT FOR STUDENTS.
FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS WHAT
BUILDING STRONG FOUNDATION FOR
SUBSEQUENT EXPANSION OF
LONGITUDINAL DATA.
EACH ACADEMIC TERM THE C. ISSUE
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR
COLLECTS DATA FROM OUR TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES. TO MEET EXISTING
FEDERAL STATE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
THE DATE INCLUDE DEMOGRAPHIC
FINANCIAL ECONOMIC CAN CAMPUS
RESOURCE DETAIL.
NORM TO TO A COMMON SET OF C.
ISSUE STANDARDS.
LIKE OUR COLLEAGUES THE C. ISSUE
PROVIDES AGGREGATE ADMISSIONS
AND READING THIS -- IN DEGREE
COMPLETION DATA BY HIGH SCHOOL
IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
WE ALSO PROVIDE PUBLIC FACING
ACCESS TO LABOR MARKET OUTCOMES.
WHILE THE WORK INVOLVED IN
SHARING INSTITUTIONAL DATE IS
IMPORTANT IT IS NOT WITHOUT
ONGOING CHALLENGE.
MATCHING STUDENT RECORDS AS MY
AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED --
NORMING -- IN STANDARDIZING
VARIABLES IN ENSURING CONSISTENT
DATA QUALITY REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
TIME A CONTINUOUS INVESTMENTS OF
CAMPUS AND SYSTEM LEVELS.
INNER SEGMENTAL DATA SIMILARLY
WILL REQUIRE ONGOING INVESTMENTS
AND TIME AND RESOURCES
[inaudible] FOR CURATION.
ADDITIONALLY ABSENTEE UNIVERSAL
IDENTIFICATION VALUE THAT EVERY
STUDENT.
OR CALIFORNIAN HOLDS WE ARE
DEPENDENT ON MULTIPLE CRITERIA
THE TEMP TO MATCH REPRESENT
RECORDS BETWEEN SEGMENT DATES
SYSTEMS.
FINALLY ISSUES SURROUNDING DATA
SECURITY IN DATA PROVINCE
PRIVACY ARE CONSTANT AREA FOCUS.
AND INVESTMENT REQUIRING
CONTINUOUS ADAPTATION.
OF ARTS OF BUYER STAFF. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS SEE ISSUES SUPPORT
OF A OF A STAGED APPROACH TO
BUILDING A LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM FIRST BUILDING ON
EXISTING FILES AND STRUCTURES.
WHICH WERE UTILIZED UNDERSEA
PACK -- AS WELL AS THOSE
EXISTING -- IN OTHER PROJECTS
SUCH AS C. GI -- THAT DIRECTLY
BENEFIT STUDENTS FAMILIES AND
SCHOOLS.
AND THEN EXPANDING OVER TIME TO
PROVISION DATA TO INFORM POLICY
RESEARCH.
THE STAGE APPROACH ALL PRO
CHOICE ALSO.
ALLOWS APPROPRIATE TIME AND
ATTENTION BE GIVEN TO ISSUES OF
PRIVACY DATA SECURITY AND DATA
GOVERNANCE.
AS WE SEE FROM SUCCESSES IN
OTHER STATES LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEMS HOLD GREAT POWER AND
PROMISE TO IN HELPING ADDRESS%
CHRONIC EDUCATIONAL ECONOMIC
SOCIAL AND SOCIETAL CHALLENGES.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE ARE NOT
STARTING FROM SCRATCH.
WE HAVE STRONG EXISTING DATA
SHARING RELATIONSHIPS ON WHICH
TO BUILD.
AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR BRING THIS
TOPIC -- FORWARD -- AND AM HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT.%
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
I'M CHARLES MASTER FROM
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
INSTITUTIONAL RESEARCH AND
ACADEMIC PLANNING AT THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT.
THE UNIVERSITY IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF A STATE WIDE
LONGITUDINAL DATABASE WE
UNDERSTAND THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING THIS KIND OF INFORMATION.
ONE IMPORTANT ASPECT TO CONSIDER
IS HOW TO ENSURE STUDENT PRIVACY.
THIS APPLIES TO BOTH THE DATA
SYSTEM ITSELF ALONG WITH HOW THE
INFORMATION IS SHARED.
PULLING FROM FOR A WE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE FOR THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER ON HOW TO MAKE
STUDENT PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
MARKS WITH THE WE ALSO THINK
THAT IF THE STATEWIDE
LONGITUDINAL DATA PROJECT WILL
BE SHARED WITH RESEARCHERS.
A GOOD METHOD IS TO CREATE A
PUBLIC USE VERSION OF DE
IDENTIFIED RESEARCH DATA WITH
OPEN ACCESS.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT MORE THAT IF
YOU'RE IF INTERESTED.
BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE WE HAVE
A FEW RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT
THE HELPED US SUCCEED.
FIRST OF THE KNOW THE PRIMARY
QUESTIONS YOU WANT TO ANSWER.
THEN START WITH A SMALLER
SMALLER PROJECT.
A PILOT SO YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
ALL THE STEPS OF THE PROJECT.
FROM DATA COLLECTION TO
INTEGRATION THE SECURITY TO
REPORTING.
AND THEN ALSO SUCCEEDING WITH
THE PILOT GIVES YOU A QUICK WHEN.
I KNOW AS WELL AS OTHERS HAVE
SAID STRUCTURE IT FROM THE
BEGINNING SO YOU CAN EXPAND
CONTACT.
THE UNIVERSITY IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF CALIFORNIA
CREATING THE STATE LAUNCHED ON
DATABASE.
THING WITH THE OTHER SEGMENTS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND ET DE TO DISCUSS
AN EARLY PILOT.
AND OTHER ASPECTS LIKE EMMA USE.
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
VALUABLE TO CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE
STATE HOWEVER WE CAN.
AB ANTHONY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
COLLECTIVELY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL HAS
SOME QUESTIONS THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO COMMENT -- I THINK IT'S
MISTER SULLIVAN -- I THINK YOU
GAVE THE MOST HONEST ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW THIS IS A BIG
CHALLENGE IS IN THE VERY
EXPENSIVE.
IT'S VERY COMPLEX AND SITTING
HERE I'M STILL NOT CONVINCED WHY
WE NEED TO DO THIS -- I HOPE
WERE COLLECTING EXISTING DATA
NOT CREATING NEW DATA OR THAT
AGAIN YOU TALK ABOUT.
YOU'RE VERY STE PLATFORMS AND
HOW WE ACCESS THAT THAT I DON'T
KNOW.
HOW THAT WOULD BE DONE BUT I'M
SURE IT WOULD TAKE A LONG TIME?
AND I'M SURE IT WOULD TAKE A LOT
OF MONEY AND I REALLY.
WONDER WHY WE'RE DOING THIS I'M
NOT CONVINCED WHERE I SIT.
WHAT THIS IS GOING TO INFORM?
HEY.
I'M JUST NOT AT THIS POINT --
AND I LOOK AT OTHER DATA SYSTEMS
WE'VE COLLECTED TAKE THE ASPECT
HAS RIGHT VERY.
IN OUR NEVER MATURED TO THE
PRODUCT THAT WE WE CONTEMPLATED --
AS LAID OUT IN THE ORIGINAL CODE
SECTION IT'S TODAY IT'S A TEST
NOT AN ASSESSMENT SYSTEM WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE AN ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE
LEGISLATURE GAVE SOME MONEY.
THEY CREATED SOMETHING CREATED
CONSORTIUM [inaudible]
AND IT NOW IS IS IS SUB PAR
QUITE FRANKLY IT'S NOT TEACHER
FRIENDLY RIGHT IT'S NOT THUS
IT'S NOT STUDENT FAMILY.
IT DOESN'T INFORMACIóN NOT
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S IT'S IT'S A
TESTING SYSTEM NOT IN THE SYSTEM
SO I USE AN EXAMPLE AND NOW
WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT
ARE.
WE HAD BUILT IN RESISTANCE TO
CHANGING ANYTHING FROM THE
CONSORTIUM THE ASPECT AND
SOURCING EVEN IN THE DEPARTMENT.
OF EDUCATION WELL THIS IS MY YOU
KNOW MY BABY AND I DON'T WANT
ANYONE.
CHANGING AND I JUST WORRY THAT
YOU KNOW WE BACK UP WE'RE FOR
CREATING ANOTHER.
SUCH ANIMAL WITH THIS DATA
SYSTEM BECAUSE IT'S GONNA BE A
VARIETY OF PARTNERS AND ARE THEY
GOING TO AGREE.
ON HOW WE MIGHT HAVE TO CHANGE
IT.
YOU KNOW DOWN THE TIME MINOR HOW.
HOW DATA SHOULD BE SPELLED OUT
AND YOU KNOW BECAUSE I'M SURE
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER ONCE IS STARTED WE
CREATE AND HAVE TO MEET?
EVEN AFTER THAT WHEN YOU WANT TO
MAKE CERTAIN CHANGES BECAUSE
YOUR YOUR ORGANIZATIONS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO TO COMMUNICATE --
SO I'M JUST SKEPTICAL BECAUSE
MORE THAT WERE GONNA DUMP A LOT
OF MONEY INTO SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY COMPLEX.
SO I APPRECIATE ACTUALLY THE
BOTH THE HIGHER EDUCATION --
BOTH YOU GENERAL FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION YOU YOU DIDN'T REALLY
SAID WHICH IS CERTAINLY HEADED
AT THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX ANIMAL.
AND PEOPLE IN SACRAMENTO LOVE TO
CREATE THINGS.
AND YOU KNOW THROUGH A LOT OF
MONEY MAYBE SOMEONE TIME MONEY
AT SOMETHING LIKE THE S. BACK
RIGHT.
AND THEN LATER ON WELL HEY THERE
IT IS IN A RESERVE SYSTEMS THERE
IS BUT IT NEVER MATURE TO THE
PRODUCT THAT WE'RE EVEN TALKING
ABOUT TODAY.
SO THAT'S MY FEAR THAT THIS IS
JUST TEN MILLION MAYBE ONCE BUT
A LOT OF MONEY AND A LOT OF
YEARS. TO CREATE SUCH A SYSTEM
WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MERA MEDINA.
OF I ALSO SHARE A MY COLLEAGUES
SKEPTICISM AN INTERESTING ENOUGH
WE'RE BOTH TEACHERS YOU KNOW
WE'RE BOTH.
TEACHERS WHO HAVE -- NO SPENT
PRETTY MUCH ARE HOLD WORKING
LIVES -- IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND I AM VERY ALSO KINDA CONFUSE
[inaudible]
ABOUT.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO -- YOU
KNOW HOW.
WHAT INFORMATION WE ARE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO GET IN AND CHAIRED THE
THE SKEPTICISM -- MISTER
O'DONNELL ON THE VALUE OF IT --
AND ALSO SHARE HIS SKEPTICISM ON
THE TRACK RECORD OF CALIFORNIA
IN AS SOME OF YOU ALLUDED -- TO
IN THE AREA OF IT AND I WOULD GO
BACK TO OUR LAST HEARING.
A LAST WEEK WHEN WE LOOKED AT ON
OUR AGENDA.
YOU SEE.
TAKING THE ENTERPRISE WHICH WAS
A BIG ENTERPRISE OF OF OF
CONSOLIDATING PAY AND I KNOW
THESE ARE DIFFERENT THINGS AND
BUT THAT WAS IN I WILL REMIND
THIS GROUP IS I DID.
LAST WEEK THAT THAT WAS SEEN AS
A COST SAVING.
AND THE COST.
MR DONALD THE COST OF THAT WHICH
WAS PRESENTED TO US A FEW YEARS
BACK.
AS A COST SAVING YOU KNOW IS.
TREMENDOUSLY OVER BUDGET.
NOT SAVING ANY MONEY SO I I
AGREE THAT OUR TRACK RECORD ON
BIG PROJECTS HASN'T BEEN TOO
GOOD.
MAYBE THOUGH I COULD GET A
LITTLE BIT BETTER UNDERSTANDING
FROM EVERYONE HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT KIND OF DATA
IS IT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
YOU KNOW I'M A LITTLE SKEPTICAL
TO OF PUTTING A NUMBER ON ON A
CHILD [inaudible]
AT AT EIGHT ZERO TO THREE AND
FOLLOWING THEM ALONG.
ALL THE WAY TO COLLEGE THAT'S
JUST ME.
YOU KNOW AND I'M NOT SURE THAT I
SEE THE VALUE OF DOING THAT --
AS SOMEONE EXPERIENCE AND IN
EDUCATION SO I I WOULD NEED A
LOT OF CLARIFICATION I HOPE THAT
I COULD GET A LITTLE BIT OF THAT.
THIS MORNING.
THEN MAYBE I CAN START.
SO SO PERHAPS AS AS AS AN
APPROACH HERE AND IT'S SORT OF
SORT OF HELLO I THINK A AFTER OF
PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
INTERSECTION OF GROUPS.
I MAYBE OF LANDED IN A PLACE.
WHERE THERE'S REALLY TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS TO THINK ABOUT
THE LONGITUDINAL DATA SAID?
THERE'S AN OPERATIONAL PIECE.
WHICH IS TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS.
YOU CAN THINK OF IT IN TERMS OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE NEEDING
DATA FOR PLACEMENT THAT HAS TO
COME UP OUT OF THE CD RECORDS.
THAT THERE'S MAYBE A BETTER WAY
TO FACILITATE ADMISSIONS TO BOTH
UNIVERSITIES.
OR ALL -- THREE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AS WELL FOR STUDENTS
THAT ARE LOOKING TO GO ON TO
COLLEGE.
SO THERE'S AN OPERATIONAL PIECE
AND I THINK THAT PEACE IS EASIER
TO TO MAKE A CASE.
FOR I THINK THE RESEARCH AND
POLICY PIECES OF FAR MORE
COMPLEX PIECE AS AS A SERVICE.
BUT MY COLLEAGUE FROM YOU SEE
AND AND OTHERS.
IN TERMS OF OF WHAT IT TAKES TO
GET FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
AND THAT I THINK STILL REMAINS A
LITTLE MORE OPEN ENDED IN TERMS
OF WEAR MAKE UP.
AND I WOULD SAY IN TERMS OF OF
K. TWELVE AND ESPECIALLY AT WE
WE KNOW HOW MANY STUDENTS
GRADUATE FROM WHICH CLASSES WE
KNOW THE DEMOGRAPHIC -- MAKE UP
THE PROGRAMS THEY'RE INVOLVED
WITH WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
TO THEM AFTER WE LEAVE.
AFTER THEY LEAVE OUR SCHOOLS AND
IF WE WERE TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE STUDENTS AFTER
THE OF OUR SCHOOLS WHETHER OR
NOT THEY ENROLLED IN A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THEY PERSISTED.
AND THEY GRADUATED OR IF THEY
DIDN'T IF THEY DIDN'T MAKE IT
PAST THAT FIRST SEMESTER WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING TAUGHT
OR THAT ARE BEING -- SPOT --
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS FIVE AND A
MILLION DOLLARS TO A PARTICULAR
PROGRAM BUT NOT AS EFFECTIVE IN
LIEU OF COLLECTING THAT DATA --
EXCHANGING THAT DATA WITH ARE MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE TABLE THERE'S
A VOID OUT THERE.
AND IT MOST EVERY OTHER STATE.
NO THIS INFORMATION BECAUSE THEY
HAVE EXISTING SYSTEMS IN WHICH
THEY'RE CONNECTED ON A ON A TWO
WEEK CONNECTIONS.
PIECE RIGHT NOW WITH -- WITH
THEIR INSTITUTES OF HIGHER
EDUCATION BECAUSE WE HAVE A
BLACK THAT -- WE HAVE WE WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO TALK ABOUT COLLEGE
GOING RATES WITH ANY.
YOU KNOW ANY CERTAINTY -- WE
HAVE WE HAVE A ROBUST DATA
SYSTEM FOR K..
TWELVE CALLED CAL PATS AND
THAT'S BEEN A TEN YEAR
INVESTMENT ARE LONGER NOW BY BY
THIS BY THIS BODY -- THAT HAS --
ALLOWED US TO COME UP WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE SUSPENDED AND THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
TELL US MAYBE SINCE SUSPEND
STUDENTS FOR A CERTAIN TYPE OF
CYST OF OF DISCIPLINARY POLICY.
SO THERE'S BEEN A YOU KNOW A
RICHNESS THAT HAS COME OUT OF
THE INCREASE QUALITY OF THE DATA
COLLECTION YOU SEE AND AND AND
USING THE SUSPENSION ANALOGY WE
SEE WE'VE SEEN A DECREASE OVER
THE LAST -- SEVEN TO EIGHT YEARS
WITH COLLECTED THAT DATA SO AS
THESE SYSTEMS HAVE BECOME MORE --
MORE MORE STAB WISHED ME NO MORE
HOW TO TO SHOULD HAVE BETTER
DATA SHARING AGREEMENTS WE ARE
MEETING ON A MONTHLY BASIS WITH
AGAIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE
AND I THINK THAT WE ARE.
YOU KNOW ON TRACK TO TO MEET --
THE DEADLINES THAT ARE HERE THAT
ARE LAID OUT -- IN THIS --
PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR TO
HAVE SOMETHING ESTABLISHED BY BY
DECEMBER -- I'M I'M CONFIDENT MY
TO BETTER POSITION WE HAVE BEEN --
OVER THE LAST DECADE.
IF I COULD ASK A QUESTION.
AND I AM A PRETTY CONFUSED.
I I I HEARD SOMETHING ABOUT
DISCIPLINE -- AND NOT HAVING
DISCIPLINE SHARED SO HOW
SPECIFIC YOU KNOW DO WE REALLY
NEED SPECIFIC INFORMATION.
RIGHT WITH THE DATA REALLY GO.
SPECIFICALLY TO A STUDENT.
THAT'S A QUESTION.
YES I WOULD GO SPECIFICALLY TO
STUDENT BUT IN MY REMARKS TODAY.
SURE THERE DISCIPLINE RECORD
MIGHT BE.
ON NOW THERE WOULD BE A RECORD
NO I I WAS I WAS USING THE
ANALOGY FOR THE DISCIPLINE
RECORDS TO US TO SHOW YOU HOW
THE DATA QUALITY HAS --
INCREASED OVER TIME AND YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE THE CONFIDENCE
IN DATA SYSTEMS RIGHT SO I WOULD
SAY THE CONFIDENCE AND DATA
SYSTEMS HAS INCREASED OVER TIME
AT LEAST AT THE K. TWELVE LEVEL.
BUT IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
APPROPRIATE TO SHARE WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION DISCIPLINES AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT I USED AS WHAT NOT TO
SHARE I DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT.
THE STUDENT WAS SUSPENDED IN
FIRST GRADE AT THAT.
THAT KEEPS FOLLOWING THEM
THROUGHOUT THEIR THEIR THEIR
THEIR VARIOUS YEARS FIVE BUT
THAT'S A QUESTION THAT I HAVE.
WOOD IS STUDENTS.
WITH WITH THIS DATA HAVE THAT
NOW.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT.
HAS A VALUE IN THAT AT ALL I
MEAN YOU KNOW THAT'S INFORMATION
THAT'S GOOD FOR SCHOOL.
BUT I DON'T THINK THE STATE
NEEDS THAT INFORMATION.
THE DISCIPLINE INFORMATION RIGHT
OKAY.
BUT BUT YOU HAVE THE CAPABILITY
AND WE WE'VE BEEN COLLECTING
THAT FOR THE LAST. EIGHT YEARS
OUT.
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE STUDENT
IS WHAT I'M ASKING CORRECT AND
BY THAT INFORMATION ALSO ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT TRENDS AT THE STATE
LEVEL HOW MANY AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALES.
WHO ARE ALSO IN THE SPECIAL ED
PROGRAM BE SUSPENDED AT A HIGHER
RATE THAN THEIR PEERS SO THAT IS
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE ABLE --
TO TO LEVERAGE IN THE SYSTEM AS
A RESULT OF THAT THAT STUDENT
LEVEL DATA COLLECTION ABSENT
THAT SOON DOUBLE DATA COLLECTION
I COULD NOT GIVE YOU THOSE KINDS
OF STATISTICS.
OKAY DID YOU WANNA RESPOND TO
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO MOVE ON
HERE YEAH.
AT THE END.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A CONCRETE
EXAMPLE LEGISLATURE PASSED
LEGISLATION NUMBER YEARS AGO.
TO REFORM THE STREAMLINED
TRANSFER PATHWAYS FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SO SHE TO REFER TRANSFER.
SO AFTER AND THAT THE PURPOSE
WAS TO WAS TO GET IT SO THAT
STUDENTS GOING FOR MAKE ME
COLLEGE TO CSU TO GET A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE ARE TAKING.
SIEU UNITS AS POSSIBLE TO GET
THAT DEGREE THAT THEY'RE NOT
TAKING ACCESS UNITS WHICH OFTEN
HAPPENS WHEN THEY TRANSFERRED TO
CSU.
COURSES THEY TOOK A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DON'T.
TRANSFER OVER TO ARTICULATE AND
IT AND IT CAN BE REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR STUDENTS.
SO THE LEGISLATURE HAD THIS
LEGISLATION OVERHAULED TO CREATE
REALLY REFORM THE SYSTEM.
BUT TO THIS DAY.
YOU DON'T KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T KNOW HOW MANY STE TOTAL
UNITS STUDENTS ARE TAKING GOING
FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO CL
STATE UNIVERSITY.
WOULD ASK.
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY YOU'RE AT
T. STUDENTS YOUR SURGERY FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS VERSUS YOUR
REGULAR TRANSFER STUDENTS HOW
MANY TOTAL UNITS OF THE
ACCUMULATED COMMITTEE COLLEGE
AND CSU.
THEY CAN'T TELL YOU WITHOUT
DOING SOME SPECIAL DAIS SHARING
AGREEMENT WHICH IS QUITE
CUMBERSOME AND THEY CAN'T TELL
YOU BECAUSE THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
DATA SYSTEM AND IT'S DIFFERENT
SILOS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE DATA
SYSTEM SO JUST ONE EXAMPLE IF WE
WERE TO IT IF THE LEGISLATURE
WHERE TO INTEGRATE DATA SYSTEMS
YOU'D BE ABLE TO GET A LOT
BETTER INFORMATION ABOUT.
PATHWAYS FROM STUDENTS FROM ONE
SEGMENT TO ANOTHER.
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PATHWAYS FROM HIGH SCHOOL SICK
MANY COLLEGES WHICH YOU'VE SPENT
A LOT OF MONEY ON WHAT'S THE
IMPACT OF THAT THAT COULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL FOR STUDENTS AND
PARENTS AS WELL TO DE IDENTIFY
LEWIS'S PATHWAY PROGRAM.
DOES THIS SEEM LIKE A A GOOD.
A GOOD APPROACH AND IT'S A GOOD
WAY TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND
BE READY AND SUCCESSFUL IN
COLLEGE SO JUST A COUPLE
EXAMPLES HOPEFULLY IT MAKES A
LITTLE MORE CONCRETE.
THANK YOU I I THINK THAT THERE
OBVIOUSLY IS THAT IS A NEED FOR
THIS AND SOME OF A NEW ERA OF
COURSE START PRIOR GOVERNOR
WASN'T.
ALWAYS A BIG FAN OF THESE DATA
EFFORTS -- CERTAINLY IF YOU LOOK
AT STUDENT SHE MEN AND TRACKING
WE HAD A ROBUST THAT DISCUSSED
AS FAR AS THE MERITS HERE. ONE
THING I'D JUST LIKE TO JUMP ON
WITH THE OTHER SAID IS THAT
WITHOUT A TERRIBLE TRACK RECORD
WITH THESE I. T. PROGRAMS AND
SELL.
THIS IS A ONE TIME. TEN MILLION
CELL IT'S BETTER ONE TIME YOU
HAVE TEN MILLIONS NOT WILL SPEND
TO HAVE. THIRTY MILLION ON GOING
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE FISCAL.
THE THE STATE -- PAYROLL PROGRAM
OR YOU SEE PATH LIKE YOU
DESCRIBE WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE
ORACLE THING FROM TWENTY YEARS
AGO JUST -- A NIGHTMARE OF THE
STATE TACKLING THESE PROJECTS SO
I DO HAVE.
A LOT OF SKEPTICISM WITH THAT
BUT UNDERSTAND THIS IS A ONE
TIME.
A PROPOSAL HERE WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE -- OPEN AND
COME BACK IN THE NEXT WEEK OR SO
AND MOVE ON TO THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER.
CREDENTIALING.
AND THE CTC BUDGET.
OKAY -- BEFORE WE DO WE DO THAT
LET'S GO BACK AND MISTER
GALLAGHER WANTED -- TO TO BE
HERE FOR THIS RIBBON AT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
WELL FIRST OF ALL IS TO TAKE
ROLE.
MCCARTY HERE BRO [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
MEDINA.
OUR STATE CHAIR O'DONNELL.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
TOP OF THE AGENDA.
IN THIS IS THEY CAP LOLLY ITEM
FOR THE FREE MONTH SCHOOL FOR
THE DEAF.
AND I'M LOOKING FOR MISTER
GALLAGHER -- TO TO MAKE THE
MOTION TO SIGN ME THE MOTION.
SO MOVES.
I WANT YOU TO SHOW OFF YOUR
SKILLS -- WHAT?
RECALL THIS ISN'T AN A. B. I
HAVE A YEAH.
I AM MOVE THAT LEADS TO PASS
THIS BILL.
OKAY EXCELLENT. SEVEN YES.
WE HAVE A MOTION MAYBE THE
THUMBS UP THAT WAS KAY.
TIMES UP OVER THERE FOR THE
SECOND WITH THAT PLEASE CALL --
THE ROLE FOR THIS -- ITEM THREE
FREE MONTHS SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF
[inaudible]
HI BRO.
GALLAGHER HI LIMóN.
MEDINA.
PURSUE G. [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
OKAY THANK YOU ITEM PASSES.
I WITH THAT LET'S PROCEED NOW
WITH -- CTC.
AND THEIR BUDGET ITEM
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO IF WITH YOUR
PERMISSION INVITE -- CAM LEAHY
FROM FINANCE TO START FIGHT WITH
AN OVERVIEW OF OUR BUDGET.
GOOD MORNING CAM LEAHY WITH THE
I'M THE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES TWENTY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN TEACHER
CREDENTIALS FUND FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TEST
DEVELOPMENT AND ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNT FUNDS.
AND FOUR HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REIMBURSEMENTS FOR A
TOTAL OPERATING BUDGET OF TWENTY
NINE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE COMMISSION IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THIS
FUNDING SUPPORT ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX AUTHORIZED POSITIONS
AT THE COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION STATE OPERATIONS
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES. TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME TEST DEVELOPMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNT FUNDS
AVAILABLE OVER TWO YEARS AND ONE
ONGOING POSITION FOR THE
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP.
TEACHER PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS
FOR THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
CREDENTIAL CANADA.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REIMBURSEMENTS. FOR
THE COMMISSION TO UTILIZE GRANT
FUNDING PROVIDED BY SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY AS PART OF THE
THIRD AND FINAL YEAR GRANT
AWARDED.
BY THE WALL THIS FOUNDATION. TO
COMPLETE THE WORK OF THE
CALIFORNIA ADMINISTRATOR
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT INCLUDING
A FIELD WORKSHOP AND THREE
SMALLER STATEWIDE MEETINGS.
FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES -- OR PROPOSES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO A UPDATE THE
EXISTING STATUTE GOVERNING
TEACHER MISSUS I'M MONITORING.
THESE CHANGES WILL REFLECT THE
ELIMINATION OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PERFORMANCE INDEX
THE ELIMINATION OF THE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED TEACHER REQUIREMENT OF
THE FEDERAL NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND
ACT.
AND TO ALIGN THE DATA SYSTEM
WITH THE ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OF THE FEDERAL
EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS REGARDING.
THESE ISSUES I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PERCENT YES THANK YOU.
SO I'M PLEASED TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF UPDATE ON COMMISSION
ACTIVITIES AS A CONTEXT FOR THE
PROPOSED BUDGET -- FIRST WE'VE
HAD THE GREAT GOOD FORTUNE FOR
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS TO WORK
WITH LINDA DARLING HAMMOND AS
THE CHAIR OF OUR COMMISSION --
WE'RE THRILLED TO SEE HER MOVE
TO THE STATE BOARD PRESIDENT
POSITION AND ALSO QUITE THRILLED --
TO INTRODUCED TO THE PUBLIC DR
TINA SLOAN WHO WAS ELECTED FIRE
COMMISSION TO SERVICE THE
INCOMING CHAIR.
SHE IS THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF
TEACHER EDUCATION AT UC SANTA
BARBARA AND IS GOING TO BE QUITE
A GOOD LEADER FOR US AS WE AS WE
MOVE INTO THE NEXT -- FOR YEARS --
SO OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS
WE'VE UNDERTAKEN A NUMBER OF
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND AND
REFORMS WITHIN THE COMMISSION.
YOU MAY RECALL THAT IN TWENTY
ELEVEN THERE WAS A HIGHLY
CRITICAL AUDIT OF OUR DISCIPLINE
ARE EDUCATOR DISCIPLINE PROCESS --
AND WE HAD WE HAD A SIGNIFICANT
BACKLOG IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN OF OF CASES THAT
WERE PENDING REVIEW BY OUR
COMMISSION WE HAVE WE CLEARED
THAT BACKLOG IN TWENTY TWELVE
AND HAVE BEEN OVERHAULING OUR
PROCEDURES EVER SINCE THEN --
THE WE WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR CASES THAT
ARE REFERRED TO THEM FOR FURTHER
EDUCATION.
THE EIJI HAD EXPERIENCED A
BACKLOG IN CASES DURING THE OF
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS I'M ALSO
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OF WORKLOAD.
BACK WALKERS BEEN ELIMINATED WE
NOW HAVE A WORKLOAD UNDER WAY --
WITH THEM WE'RE ALL CASES THAT
GO TO THEM ARE ARE COMPLETED
WITHIN ONE YEAR SO THAT BIG
PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN A TOPIC OF
MUCH CONVERSATION ANNUALLY AND
WE'RE WE'RE PLEASED TO REPORT
THAT.
WE'VE ALSO OF COURSE BEEN
ENGAGED IN OVERHAULING OUR
STANDARDS FOR EVERYONE. FOR
TEACHERS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS FOR ADMINISTRATORS MOST
RECENTLY WE'VE ADOPTED NEW
STANDARDS FOR SCHOOL COUNSELORS
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS AND SCHOOL
SOCIAL WORKERS SO THE STANDARDS
REFORM WORK HAS BEEN BRINGING
EVERYTHING INTO ALIGNMENT WITH --
CURRENT THINKING AND FRAMEWORKS
AND STANDARDS FOR STUDENTS AND
SCHOOLS THAT'S BEEN A BIG PART
OF OUR WORK WE'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENTS FOR OUR TEACHERS AND
FOR ADMINISTRATORS -- THAT GO
INTO THAT'S PART OF THEIR
PREPARATION PROGRAM LEADING TO A
CREDENTIAL THAT WORK WAS FUNDED
BY THE LEGISLATURE SEVERAL YEARS
AGO WERE PLEASE THAT BOTH THE
TEACHING PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
AND A AN ADMINISTRATOR
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT ARE NOW
IN FULL OPERATION.
WE LOOK FORWARD -- TO TAKING
THIS WORK INTO THE AREA OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND BRING IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS ON
BOARD AS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR -- WE'VE ALSO OVER
HOLDER ACCREDITATION SYSTEM
WHICH IS HOW WE MONITOR QUALITY
IN TEACHER PREPARATION AND IN
WELL IN ALL EDUCATOR PREPARATION
AND THAT HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT.
SHIFTING FROM A DOCUMENTATION
AND COMPLIANCE ORIENTATION IN
THAT WORK TO A FOR PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES OF BASIS FOR THAT WORK.
AND THAT HAS ALSO BEEN
SIGNIFICANT THAT NEW SYSTEM IS
COMING ON LINE THIS YEAR AND
IT'S BEEN THERE SOME SOME GREAT --
OUTCOMES OF OF THAT SET OF
CHANGES WE'VE ALSO HAD THE GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO ADMINISTER ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FUNDING FOR TO ADDRESS
TEACHER SHORTAGES -- OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS WE EXPECT ALL OF
THESE GRANT PROGRAMS TO TO
PRODUCE ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
TEACHERS THAT'S OUR ESTIMATE --
WHICH IS GOOD NEWS FIVE THOUSAND
OF THOSE TEACHERS IN THOSE SLOTS --
ARE FUNDED SPECIFICALLY IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION SO THAT HAS
BEEN A MAJOR PART OF OUR WORK
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AS
WELL.
WE'VE -- SO THAT SO THAT'S GOOD
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S NEXT FOR US --
WE ARE FOCUSING ON
IMPLEMENTATION AND CAPACITY
BUILDING WHEN YOU ENGAGE IN AS
MUCH CHANGES WE'VE ENGAGED AND
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND ALLOW ALL THOSE
CHANGES TO REALLY GET TO THE
GROUND LEVEL.
OF THE SYSTEMS THAT WE THAT WE
WORK WITH AND SO WE'RE REALLY
ARE TURNING OUR ATTENTION TO HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
THESE CHANGES ARE BEING AS WELL
IMPLEMENTED AS WE NEED THEM TO
BE.
THAT'S A BIG FOCUS FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS WE ALSO ARE TAKING
A DEEPER LOOK THE COMMISSION
WILL BE OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS AT TEACHER TESTING OVERALL
AND LOOKING AT THE WAYS IN WHICH
WE TEST TEACHERS. FOR SUBJECT
MATTER FOR READING INSTRUCTIONAL
CONFIDENCE AT CETERA TO
DETERMINE HOW WE MIGHT BRING
THOSE SYSTEMS.
INTO MAYBE THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
GOAL -- WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE
PROGRESS IN CREDENTIALING A
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION WE
ARE EXPECTED TO DO MAJOR WORK OF
THIS YEAR.
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AS
THE LEGISLATURE UNDERTAKES ITS
MANY PROPOSALS AND LOOKS
EQUALITY IN THAT WORK FORCE THE
COMMISSION IS PREPARED TO
PARTNER WITH WITHOUT WORK.
AND AND WORK ON OUR SIDE OF IT
WHICH IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY THAT WE LICENSE IN
THIS FIELD TO WORK IN SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE.
IS PREPARED TO DO THAT WORK TO
OUR EXPECTATIONS SO -- WE ALSO
OF COURSE HAVE THE FUNDING THAT
A KID MENTION TO UPDATE OUR
ASSIGNMENT MONITORING WORK AND
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE
AUTOMATION PART OF THAT.
AND ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE BILL --
AND THAT THAT BRING ME THE
ECHOED IN STATUTE UP -- TO YOU
KNOW PART WITH THE CHANGES THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SO THAT'S A
BROAD OVERVIEW I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
ALL NOW OR LATER.
THANK YOU LA -- GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AMY LEE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I'LL BE SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT TODAY.
THEY BELIEVE OF THE SERGEANTS
HANDOUT WHICH 'LL BE SPEAKING
FROM DURING MY PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING. ONE OF THE ISSUES
BEFORE YOU IS WHETHER TO ADOPT A
NEW ASSESSMENT INTENDED TO
MEASURE WHETHER PERSPECTIVE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS ARE
PREPARED TO ENTER THE CLASSROOM.
THIS ASSESSMENT IS CALLED THE
TEACHING BEFORE STE TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT ORG THE
TVA.
STARTING ON PAGE ONE BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND.
THE TVA IS PERFORMED A PORTFOLIO
BASED EXERCISE THAT ASKS
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS TO
DEMONSTRATE THE SKILLS AND
KNOWLEDGE EXPECTED OF BEGINNING
TEACHERS.
THESE TASKS INCLUDE PREPARING
LESSONS -- ASSESSING STUDENT
LEARNING AND REFLECTING ON PAST
INSTRUCTION.
THIS SUSSMAN IS INTEGRATED INTO
THE TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS
SUCH THAT PERSPECTIVE TEACHERS
COMPLETE THE T. P. A. ALONGSIDE
THEIR COURSEWORK.
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS SUBMIT
THEIR PORTFOLIO OF WRITTEN AND
VIDEO RECORDED WORK TO AN
INDEPENDENT ASSESSOR FOR SCORING.
THE STATE HAS REQUIRED GENERAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS TO COMPLETE
EIGHTY P. A TOP TEAM THEY'RE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED THIS
REQUIREMENT TO IMPROVE TEACHING
PREPARATION.
BY STAB WISHING CONSISTENCY IN
TEACHING ASSESSMENT ACROSS
PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
NOW IN CONTRAST TO GENERAL
EDUCATION SET YOU TAKE STAYS
SILENT ON WHETHER SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS ARE REQUIRED
TO PASS THE TVA.
RATHER START YOU GIVES CTC BROAD
DISCRETION OVER OF ASSESSMENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS.
SEIZE CDC CURRENTLY DOES NOT
REQUIRE SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS TO PASS EIGHTY PA.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PAGE.
HERE WE COVER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES ONE POINT TWO MILLION
IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR CDC TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT ATP FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THIS FUNDING WOULD COME FROM THE
TEST DEVELOPMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNT A SPECIAL
FUNDS THAT COLLECTS REVENUES
FROM FEES PAID BY PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS WHEN THEY ARE TAKING
STATE REQUIRED ASSESSMENTS.
CDC ESTIMATES THE TOTAL COST TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TBA TO BE TWO
MILLION AND INTENDS TO REQUEST
THE REMAINING EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
CDC ANTICIPATES A FOUR YEAR
TIMELINE FOR T. PA.
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
THIS YEAR THE CDC WOULD CONTRACT
WITH A TEST DEVELOPER TO BEGIN
DEVELOPMENT THE FOLLOWING TWO
YEARS WOULD BE DEDICATED -- TO
PILOTING THE T. P. AND FEEL
TESTS AND BEGINNING TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE NEW SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PASS THE T. PAY TO OBTAIN THEIR
TEACHING CREDENTIALS.
CDC INTENSE THE COST OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION T. PAY TO BE
COMPARABLE TO THAT OF THE
GENERAL EDUCATION GPA WHICH RUNS
CURRENTLY.
AT THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
TEST TAKER.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND ON GOING FROM THE
TEST DEVELOPMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNT. FOR A
WILL WANT A NEW.
FULL TIME PERMANENT POSITION TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TO PA.
WITH THE ON TO THE NEXT PAGE.%
IN OUR ASSESSMENT WE BELIEVE
THAT SPECIAL EDUCATION T. PA A
CERTAIN STRENGTHS AND
LIMITATIONS STARTING WITH THE
PROPOSAL STRENGTH.
FIRST A SPECIAL EDUCATION TO PAY
COULD BETTER PREPARE NEW
TEACHERS TO ENTER THE CLASSROOM
BY ASSESSING WHETHER THEY HAVE
THE EXPECTED KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS TO PROVIDE INSTRUCTION TO
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
THIS MAY INCLUDE MANAGING CASES
AND PREPARING INTO BY
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
ALTHOUGH THE EXISTING RESEARCH
IS LIMITED IF WE FOUND THREE
STUDIES GENERALLY SUPPORTING
THAT EIGHT THAT HOW IT TEACHER
PERFORMS ON THE TVPA CAN BE
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPROVEMENTS IN
STUDENT OUTCOMES.
SECOND EIGHT GPA COULD IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
CDC INTENDS TO ANALYZE THE
OUTCOMES OF FROM THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION GPA WHEN DECIDING
WHETHER TO APPROVE PROGRAMS THIS
DATA ANALYSIS WOULD HELP CDC.
AS UNDERSTAND WHAT THE RELATIVE
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES OF EACH
PROGRAM WOULD BE.
LASTLY WE CONSIDER IF THE
PROJECT COST AND FUN SOURCE TO
BE REASONABLE CITY SEES COST
ESTIMATES FOR THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION GPA REFLECTS SOME
SAVINGS FROM RE PURPOSING SOME
COMPONENTS OF THE GENERAL
EDUCATION GPA.
IN OTHER WORDS CITIES YOU WILL
NOT BE STARTING FROM SCRATCH.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSED
FUNDING SOURCE IS SPECIFICALLY
INTENDED FOR TESTS OF ELEMENT
AND ADMINISTRATION OF TAX.
THE SPECIAL FUND HAS BEEN
GROWING IN RECENT YEARS AND IS
LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSALS.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PAGE.
WE DISCUSSED TO POTENTIAL
DOWNSIDES TO THE PROPOSAL FIRST
GENERAL EDUCATION TEACHERS WE
SPOKE TO COMPLETED THE EXISTING
T. PAY CONSIDER THE T. PAY TO BE
RATHER TIME INTENSIVE.
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF TIME IT TOOK TO
COMPLETE THE ASSESSMENT WHICH
SEEMS RELATIVELY HIGH COMPARED
TO HOW HELPFUL THEY CAN BE FOUND
THE PREPARATION TOOL.
ESPECIALLY WHEN COMPARED TO
OTHER COMPONENTS OF TEACHER
PREPARATION SUCH AS COURSE WORK
AND STUDENT TEACHING.
LASTLY WE ARE UNCERTAIN ABOUT
THE IMPACT EIGHT SPECIAL
EDUCATION T. PAY MIGHT HAVE ON
TEACHER SUPPLY.
AS YOU WELL NOW THE STATE HAS
FACED CHRONIC SHORTAGE OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS TO
MEET THE DEMAND FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
TEACHERS MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
RELY ON OUT OF STATE RECRUITMENT
OR HIRE STAFF WHO DO NOT MEET
ALL CREDENTIAL REQUIREMENTS.
A NEW T. P. REQUIREMENT WOULD AT
WORK AND COST TO THE PROCESS OF
BECOMING A SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER.
ALTHOUGH THE ADDITION OF THE T.
P. A. MIGHT SEEM MODEST IN THE
CONTEXT OF ALL THE OTHER
REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE FOR NEW
TEACHERS.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT IT MIGHT
ALSO AFFECT THE NUMBER OF
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS INTERESTED
IN OBTAINING A SPECIAL EDUCATION
CREDENTIAL.
MOVING ON TO OUR LAST PAGE.
WE RECOMMEND TO THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
TO FUND THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION T. PA AND OUT
THE EIGHT OFFICE BUT ON BALANCE
WE THINK THE PROPOSAL COULD HELP
IMPROVE TEACHER PREPARATION.
AND BRING SPECIAL EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR TEACHERS AND
LINE WITH THOSE FOR GENERAL
EDUCATION.
HOWEVER WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE CTC TO
ASSESS HOW THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
GPA MIGHT AFFECT TEACHER SUPPLY
BY JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WHICH IS WHEN THAT REQUIREMENT
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED.
CDC COULD COLLECT INFORMATION
DURING THE PILOT PHASES OF
IMPLEMENTATION REGARDING.
ONE HOW THE T. P. IS AFFECTING
INTEREST IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS TO
HOW HOW MUCH TIME IT TAKES TO
COMPLETE THE DPA AND HOW THIS
AFFECTS OVERALL WORKLOAD.
AND THREE WHAT PERSPECTIVE
TEACHERS CONSIDERED THE ADDED
VALUE OF THE T. PAY AND BETTER
PREPARING THEM FOR THE CLASSROOM.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD THEN USE
THIS INFORMATION TO EVALUATE
WHETHER THE SPECIAL EDUCATION T.
PAY WHAT EFFECT INTEREST
WORKLOAD AND COMPLETION RATES
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
LASTLY IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE T. P.
AND STUDENT OUTCOMES WERE
GENERALLY IT CONSIDER FUNDING AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION.
THIS WILL HELP INFORM WHETHER
REQUIRING THE G. D. P. A. FOR
BOTH SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS
AND SPECIAL AND GENERAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS.
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF
IMPROVING TEACHER PREPARATION
AND STUDENT OUTCOMES.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTION ALL OF SAM BUT FIRST MR
O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND ALL
YOU DO -- I'M VERY MUCH A MUCH
OF PREPARED IS TO BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE ONE TIME AND ONGOING
EXPENDITURES THERE IS ONE THING.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE -- THE
COMMITTEE -- ADOPT OR LEAST
CONTEMPLATE IS -- THAT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REFLECT
READY JONES SAWYER MISTER
SAWYER'S JOHN SORES AB.
TWELVE NINETEEN WHICH BASICALLY
REQUIRES THAT.
THE ALL SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA --
ALL CLASSROOMS AND CALIFORNIA
HAVE THE APPROPRIATELY
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS I KNOW IN
SOME INSTANCES I GUESS SOME
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE CLAIMING
THAT.
THEIR TEACHERS DON'T EVEN NEED
TO HAVE CREDENTIALS.
A HIGH I DON'T THINK THAT'S A
GOOD THING -- IN FACT THEY MAY
NOT EVEN HAVE A DEGREE -- SO --
I I WHAT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS -- THE THE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- BE CHANGED TO
REFLECT AGAIN -- AB TWELVE
NINETEEN WITH THAT I TURN IT
BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
[inaudible] TWO QUESTIONS --
AND I'LL ALASKAN VOTE ONE ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION IF YOU COULD
TELL ME MORE ABOUT.
CALIFORNIA IS -- ACCEPTING OUT
OF STATE -- SPECIAL ED TEACHERS
IN THE HOUSE HOW EASY IS IT FOR
THEM TO GET A CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
ED CREDENTIAL.
IF THEIR CREDENTIAL IN ANOTHER
STATE.
SECOND QUESTION -- THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT VERY RECENTLY PUT
OUT -- I THINK A PRIORITY FOR
HIM.
WHERE HE SAID THAT -- 6% OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN BUT ONLY 1% OF THE
TEACHERS ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN.
HE ALSO SAID THAT WE'RE I
BELIEVE 45% OF THE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE LATINO ONLY 5% OF
THE TEACHERS.
ARE LATINO.
SO.
SECOND QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING COMMISSION
DOING TO HELP.
CHANGE THAT TWO QUESTIONS.
SO WITH RESPECT YOUR FIRST
QUESTION SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS PREPARED IN OTHER
STATES WE HAVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S TAKEN ACTION IN
THE PAST TO BRING SOME
NORMALIZATION TO HOW WE LOOK AT
OUT OF STATE PREPARE TEACHERS.
BASED ON HOW MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE THAT TEACHER HAS
SERVING IN ANOTHER STATE.
SO I BELIEVE IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION YOU CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG JOSH SPEAKS IS -- ARE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AND MAY
HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
THIS -- ANY TEACHER COMES TO
CALIFORNIA WITH TWO OR MORE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
IS GRANTED A PRELIMINARY
CREDENTIALING GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY -- TO GO THROUGH
INDUCTION AND CLEAR THAT
CREDENTIAL IF THEY NEED -- TO
ACTUALLY I DON'T THINK THE
REQUIRED FOR INDUCTION -- THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE ACCIDENTAL
OUT OF STATE.
IF YOUR CREDENTIALS OUT OF STATE
YOU CAN COME TO CALIFORNIA
PRESENT YOUR CREDENTIAL AND
RECEIVE A CREDENTIAL IN
CALIFORNIA TO BEGIN SERVICE IF
THERE SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT YOU
MAY BE MISSING FOR INSTANCE
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES ALL TEACHERS
TO BE PREPARED TO TEACH ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
IN OTHER STATES THAT'S AN ADDED
CERTIFICATION.
IN SOME CASES A NOT AT ALL SO WE
PROVIDE TIME FOR TEACHERS WHILE
TEACHING TO MEET THAT
REQUIREMENT SO THEY'RE
CONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA MAY
BE ADDITIONAL.
WORK NEAR MAYBE THERE MAY BE BUT
IT'S BEEN FAIRLY LIMITED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN PRIOR.
A LEGISLATION THAT YOU'VE BEEN
ACTED OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS SO -- WE WE WELCOME
TEACHERS FROM OTHER STATES
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY AND 25%
OF THE TEACHERS WE CREDENTIAL
EVERY YEAR ARE PREPARED IN OTHER
STATES SO THAT'S NOT AN
INSIGNIFICANT -- POPULATION
COMING INTO CALIFORNIA SO.
SO AND JOSH SPEAKS FOR MICE.
I JUST WANTED -- TO NOTE THAT --
WE ARE.
CONSTANTLY LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
MAKE THAT PROCESS YOU KNOW AS
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE.
SEE IF THERE ARE UNNECESSARY
OBSTACLES WE CAN REMOVE -- AND
BASED ON SOME DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE HAD WITH ASSEMBLY AT
COMMITTEE STAFF -- IN THE
INTERIM -- BEFORE THE SESSION
STARTED -- THERE IS ACTUALLY A
BILL AB -- NINE EIGHT EIGHT THAT
IS -- CO SPONSORED BY -- CO
AUTHORED BY -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL.
THAT -- DOES ELIMINATES SORT OF
A AN ADDITIONAL BARRIER THAT WE
FOUND IT'S IT'S KIND OF
TECHNICAL BUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT
IT DOES IS.
IF A PERSON COMES IN FROM OUT OF
STATE WITH THE GENERIC
SPECIALIST CREDENTIAL WHICH
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T ISSUE GENERIC
CREDENTIALS.
WE ISSUE THEM IN SPECIALTY AREAS --
BUT OTHER STATES ISSUE GENERIC
CREDENTIALS -- THAT TEACHER GETS.
THE APPROPRIATE CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIAL THEY YOU KNOW THEY
TELL US WHAT THEY'RE INTERESTED
IN.
AND THEN WHILE THEY'RE TEACHING
ON THAT PRELIMINARY CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIAL THEY CAN USE --
SERVICE AND CALIFORNIA CLASSROOM
UNDER THIS BILL -- TO MEET THE
THE SORT OF SPECIALIZATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY DIDN'T
TURN OUT OF STATE BECAUSE THEY
YOU KNOW WERE ISSUED A GENERIC
CREDENTIAL SO AGAIN THAT'S KIND
OF A TECHNICAL ISSUE BUT IT'S
JUST -- SORT OF EMBLEMATIC OF
THE FACT THAT WE ARE.
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO MAKE
THAT PROCESS.
AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE.
SO WITH RESPECT TO THE OTHER
QUESTION THAT YOU RAISED ABOUT
THE DIVERSITY OF THE TEACHING
WORKFORCE -- WE HAVE SEEN OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS -- AND
INCREASING NUMBER OF TEACHERS OF
COLOR AND ROLLED IN TEACHER
PREPARATION -- A PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS OF COLOR LESS THAN 50%
OF THE TEACHERS AND ROLLED.
IN PREPARATION AND EARNING
CREDENTIALS -- SELF IDENTIFY AS
WHITE OR ANGLO BACKGROUND NOW I
THINK AROUND 30% AND I'LL GET
YOU THE SPECIFIC DATA BUT IT'S
IT IT'S A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER --
OF TEACHERS AND ROLLED IN
SEEKING CREDENTIALS ARE OF
LATINO DESCENT AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATIONS CONTINUE TO BE OUT
WE NEED TO BEEF THAT UP AND AND
DO MORE RECRUITMENT AN OUT REACH.
TO CONTINUE TO DIVERSIFY OUR THE
TEACHING WORKFORCE BUT IT'S AN
ONGOING COMMITMENT NOT JUST OF
THE COMMISSION'S BUT ALSO OF
EVERY TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAM IN THE STATE.
THEY ARE SEEKING ACTIVELY TO
RECRUIT A MORE DIVERSE TEACHING
FORCE THE LEGISLATURE ALSO HAS
ENACTED AS SOME OF THE GRANT
PROGRAMS THE CLASSIFIED GRANT
PROGRAM FOR INSTANCE IS GOT A
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DIVERSE
POPULATION.
OF CANDIDATES MOVING INTO
TEACHING AS A RESULT OF THAT
INVESTMENT IN THEIR PREPARATION.
SO WHILE WE HAVEN'T YET ACHIEVED
ANYTHING LIKE OUR REPRESENTATIVE
DIVERSITY IN THE TEACHING FORCE
THAT WOULD REFLECT THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR STUDENT POPULATION IT'S
TRENDING IN THAT DIRECTION.
AND AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I
KNOW ABOUT THAT RIGHT NOW -- I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT.
THIS STATE SUPERINTENDENT ALSO
MENTION THE LACK OF OF MEN OF
COLOR.
IN THE IN THE CLASSROOM AND AND
AND I WONDER IF THERE MAY BE
ALSO.
CONDITIONS IN THE SCHOOLS THAT.
EITHER INFLUENCE -- TEACHERS OF
COLOR TO STAY IN THE PROFESSION --
AND TO DROP OUT AND I THINK THAT
MIGHT BE.
INTERESTING AND VALUABLE TO LOOK
INTO.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR GALLAGHER.
SO -- NEAR THE YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY I THINK THAT I THINK
THIS APPROACH IS A GOOD ONE TO
KIND.
RBC FIRST KIND OF COLLECT SOME
DATA SEE HOW THIS IS THIS IS
WORKING -- AND AND CERTAINLY
WANT TO TRY AND ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE YOU KNOW -- BETTER PREPARED --
TEACHERS AND TRAIN TEACHERS --
THE THE CONCERN THAT I THAT I
MAY HAVE IS THAT YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE -- SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS [inaudible]
AND IT'S A IT'S A VITAL PART OF
OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO AN AD --
WHAT I DON'T WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN
IS IS MAYBE A BARRIER?
TO AND SO THAT'S WHY I THINK
MAYBE COLLECTING THIS DATA TO
FIND OUT HIS T. PAY REALLY.
IS THAT GOING TO REALLY HELP
THEM AS IS GOING TO KEEP OR IS
IT GONNA MAY BE A BARRIER TO
PEOPLE -- CONTINUING IN THE IN
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION FIELD.
BECAUSE WE WE CAN AND DO YOU
HAVE SHORTAGES OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS -- AND AND SO
THAT'S ONE CONCERN THAT I HAVE
THE OTHER PART IS IS THE IS THE
FEE LIKE I KNOW WE WE INCREASE
THE FEE.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE TEACHER
MISCONDUCT BACKLOG -- NOW THAT
WE'VE CLEARED THAT BACKLOG HAS
THERE BEEN ANY -- DISCUSSION
ABOUT REDUCING THAT FEE.
BECAUSE HE OF FEES YOU KNOW THE
FEE STRUCTURE COULD ALSO
POTENTIALLY BE A BARRIER. TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS AND
AND AGAIN I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT DOING THIS MAY IF YOU
COULD COMMENT ON BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS. TO BE HAPPY TO THANK YOU
SO WHERE WE FIND WITH TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THEM FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS PLUS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN TERMS OF WHAT CANDIDATES
EXPERIENCE.
THE PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
ORGANIZES THEIR STUDENT TEACHING.
THEY GIVE THEM SOME VERY
SPECIFIED TASKS THAT THEY NEED
TO COMPLETE WITHIN THEIR STUDENT
TEACHING.
THAT BECOMES GIVE ME -- MISTER
DONALD.
WE JUST TAKE A MOTION BUT ON
THIS RIVER.
YES WE WANT.
TO MOVE.
THIS - CTC BUDGET ITEM I DO
HAVE A FEW MORE QUESTIONS AFTER
WE VOTE TO APPROVE THE BUDGET
BUT ALWAYS HERE.
THE MOST IN A SECOND -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY.
HI.
GROW [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
LIMON.
MEDINA FOR SEARCHING FOR DONALD.
SO I CONTINUE YES OKAY SO IT
ORGANIZES THEIR THEIR STUDENT
TEACHING SO TEACHERS GOING INTO
A TEACHER PREPARATIONPROGRAM.
IN GENERAL EXCEPT THE CONDITIONS
OF THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS THIS HAS BECOME A
CONDITION OF THE PROGRAM THE
TEACHERS -- THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY THINK ABOUT THIS AS
IT'S NOT LIKE THE BAR EXAM IT'S
NOT IT HASN'T BECOME THAT IT IS
A WAY OF ORGANIZING TEACHER
PREPARATION IT'S ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS THEY MUST MEET.
IN ORDER TO EARN A CREDENTIAL.
WE HAVE NOT FOUND THAT IT IS A
BARRIER FOR TEACHERS IN THE
GENERAL EDUCATION POPULATION
WHAT WE FOUND INSTEAD IS THAT IT
MOVES FROM THE ABSTRACT LEARNING
TO CONCRETE DOING IN THE
CLASSROOM BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF THE TASKS WE GIVE THEM IT'S
TIED TO VERY SPECIFIC PRIORITIES
THAT WE HAVE FOR TEACHING --
WITH RESPECT TO HOW THEY
INTERACT WITH LEARNERS SO FOR
INSTANCE SOME OF THE CHANGES
WE'VE MADE IN OUR TEACHING
GENERALIZED TEACHING PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT.
HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM A KIND OF
OVERALL TEACH THE CONTENT. TWO
YOU MUST TEACH CONTENT TO
STUDENTS BUT YOU HAVE TO KNOW
ABOUT STUDENTS AND YOU HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO ADAPT WHAT YOU'RE
TEACHING TO THE NEEDS THEY BRING.
SO WE REQUIRE THEM IN A TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT TO ADAPT
THEIR LESSONS PUT TO ENGLISH
LEARNERS TO STUDENTS WHO MIGHT
BE IN SPECIAL EDUCATION TO
STUDENTS TO BRING ANY OTHER
FRAGILE OR NEED OR OR ASSET TO
THE CLASSROOM.
SO MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO DO PLANNING THAT IT
TENDS TO BOTH CONTENT AND THE
STUDENTS THEIR TEACHING SO WHAT
THE T. P. A. DOES.
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
ASSESS STUDENT LEARNING AND KNOW
WHEN THEIR INSTRUCTION.
MET THE MARKING WHEN IT MISSED
THE MARK AND WHO WITNESSED THE
MARK FOR SO THAT THEY CAN BE
TEACHING LEARNING IS IT IMPROVED
AS A RESULT OF THAT.
SOME OF THE RESEARCH THAT ELIO
RAISED INDICATES THAT IT HAS
THAT IMPACT WE DON'T HAVE THE
KINDS OF LARGE SCALE STUDIES YET
THERE WOULD THAT WE WOULD ANSWER
THIS COMPLETELY AND CONCRETELY
AND FOREVER MORE.
BUT WE HAVE INDICATIONS THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING AND
THE MOVEMENT FROM ABSTRACT
LEARNING ABOUT TO DOING IS THE
KEY THEORY OF ACTION HERE FOR
TEACHERS.
SO MOVING THIS INTO SPECIAL
EDUCATION WILL ORGANIZE THEIR
CLINICAL PRACTICE AS WELL WE
NEED TO ADAPT IT TO THAT SPACE
THE LEARNERS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION BRING A WHOLE
DIFFERENT KIND.
SET OF NEEDS -- AND ASSETS TO
THAT ENVIRONMENT ON SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING NEEDS IN
VARIOUS DIFFERENT SETTINGS IN
WHICH THEY ARE THEY'RE TAUGHT SO
ADAPTING.
THE FRAME OF A PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT TO THE TYPES OF
SETTINGS OF THE TYPES OF
STUDENTS THAT THEY'RE TEACHING
IS WHAT'S NECESSARY.
I THINK THAT THE LARGER LIFT FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE TVA IS FOR
PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T ALL
ORGANIZED THEIR PROGRAMS IN THIS
WAY SO MANY OF THE PREPARATION
PROGRAMS HAVE HAD TO RE DESIGN
SOME CURRICULUM.
REDESIGN HOW THEY SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND STUDENT TEACHING.
BUT WE IT DOESN'T INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF HOURS OF SPUR OF
STUDENT TEACHING.
IT'S SIMPLY PUTS IN PLACE AND
THINGS THEY MUST DO AND
DEMONSTRATE BEFORE THEY CAN
COMPLETE THAT.
SO MY HYPOTHESIS IS THAT THIS
WILL NOT HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON PEOPLE COMING INTO SPECIAL
WHAT [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
MY EXPECTATIONS BASED ON FIFTEEN
YEARS OF WORK IN PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT IS THAT IT WILL
IMPROVE THEIR SKILL SET WHEN
THEY GET INTO THE CLASSROOM --
BUT I THINK WE ALWAYS HAVE TO BE
ATTENTIVE TO THE THINGS THAT
ENABLE OR CONSTRAIN PEOPLE
MOVING INTO SPECIAL EDUCATION
ESPECIALLY.
PRODUCTPERSISTENT SHORTAGE --
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS AND I'M
NOT SURE THAT PREPARATION IS.
EVEN IF AMONG THE TOP FIVE
REASONS WHY SPECIAL EDUCATORS
COME INTO OR STAY IN OR DESIRE
TO LEAVE.
THEIR ISSUES AROUND WORKING
CONDITIONS ARE ISSUES AROUND
CASELOADS OTHER KINDS OF YOU
KNOW CONTEXT IN WHICH SPECIAL
EDUCATION UNFOLDS.
THAT WE HAVE TO BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO KIND OF A CROSS
AGENCIES AS A STATE -- SO THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE THE KIND OF
ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH TEACHERS
CAN GET THAT JOB DONE THE
LEARNERS ARE GETTING WHAT THEY
NEED.
THAT'S THAT'S MY VIEW ON THAT --
IN IN TERMS OF THE FEE.
ARE YOU ASKED A QUESTION ABOUT
THE FEE AND HAVE EARNED REDUCING
THE BACKLOG COULD WE WOULD
REVISIT THE FEET -- THIS IS THIS
RELATES TO OVERALL WE MOVED FROM
A FIFTY FIVE DOLLAR TO A SEVENTY
DOLLAR TO NOW A HUNDRED DOLLARS
EVERY FIVE YEARS THAT'S TWENTY
DOLLARS A YEAR.
THE TEACHERS ARE PAYING FOR
THEIR LICENSING.
AND MY ARGUMENT JUST ON THE GET
GO IS THAT THAT'S THAT'S NOT IF
THAT'S NOT A LARGE BURDEN FORD
FOR TEACHERS FOR A CREDENTIAL
FEET.
AND THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
DISCIPLINE EVEN THOUGH WE'VE
GOTTEN RID OF THE BACKLOG OUR
WORK LOAD IN TEACHER DISCIPLINE
AN EDUCATOR DISCIPLINE HAS
INCREASED SUBSTANTIALLY -- WE
AND AT OCT I CAN I CAN GIVE YOU
MORE DETAIL ON THAT IF YOU'D
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT I MEAN BY
SUBSTANTIAL BUT THE WORKLOAD
ITSELF HAS INCREASED.
THE STAFFING NEEDS HAVE
INCREASED THE IS A AND THAT
ITSELF I MEAN WE ARE ABSORBING A
GOOD PORTION OF THE FEE AND SO
IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
IN TERMS OF MANAGE THE WORK GETS
REFER TO THEM SO I'M NOT SURE
THAT THAT FEE ITSELF.
OF IS IT NEEDS TO CHANGE IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS SHORTAGES OR TO
TO SHIFT THE WAY WE FUND OF THIS
WORK -- BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S SO
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY KIND OF HOW
I THINK ABOUT THE QUESTION.
OKAY THANK YOU I WANT TO MOVE TO
SOME OF THE ISSUES IN THE AGENDA
THAT.
THAT WITH -- INVESTED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS TO DEAL WITH THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE IN THE PIPELINE
AND TALK ABOUT -- OVERALL
EFFECTIVENESS AND WHICH ONES IF
ANY WE RECOMMEND TO TO RE UP.
IF IF MONIES ARE AVAILABLE AND
YOU KNOW THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THE PAST FEW
YEARS PROBABLY BUT THERE STILL
MAY BE SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THESE --
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS.
THAT YOU HOW ALL HAVE HAVE --
IMPLEMENTED SO SOME A FAMILIAR
WITH -- I WORKED ON WITH YOU ON
THE BUDGET LEGISLATION BUT MAYBE
JUST RUN THROUGH AND AND GIVE US
THAT THE RUN DOWN YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU THINK GOING FORWARD WE
SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT SURE.
WE HAVE A HANDOUT ON ON THIS I
BELIEVE THAT HAS BEEN CIRCULATED.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WE ARE
CURRENTLY RUNNING ONE TWO THREE
OF FIVE REALLY FIVE DIFFERENT
FOR FIVE DIFFERENT GRANT
PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW IN THE
CLASSIFIED -- SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PROGRAM IS
PROBABLY THE OLDEST WE ARE
FUNDED FOR THAT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND WE'VE BEEN
FUNDED FOR TWO YEARS NOW. FOR A
TOTAL OF FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- IN TERMS OF DEMAND WE
HAD PROPOSALS RECEIVED EVER BOTH
CYCLES.
WE WE RECEIVED EIGHTY NINE
PROPOSALS WE WERE ABLE TO FIND
FIFTY THREE OF THEM -- EIGHTY
THREE HUNDRED JUST OVER EIGHTY
THREE HUNDRED SLOTS WERE
REQUESTED FOR CLASSIFIED BY
EMPLOYEES TO MOVE INTO THIS
PROGRAM WE WERE ABLE TO FIND --
TO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN SIXTY
SO I WOULD SAY THERE IS THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT THEY USE -- HAS
BEEN IN HIGH DEMAND AND HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND YOU KNOW IF
THEY'RE OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THAT
DIRECTION THAT'S A DEMAND IS IS
THERE OF COURSE -- SHOULD BE AT
ALL BE CONCERNED THAT THAT.
FARRIGHT.
TABLE THAT PERCENTAGE OF
CREDENTIALED -- PERMITS EARNED
IS STILL LOWER IS THAT JUST THE
KIND OF WORK IN PROGRESS -- THIS
WORK IN PROGRESS LET ME EXPLAIN
THAT SO -- FIRST FUNDING THAT
CAME TO US IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND WENT THROUGH A
GRANT PROPOSAL IF THEY RECEIVED
THEIR GRANTS BY THE SPRING OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THEY AND ROLLED.
PEOPLE IN THEIR PROGRAMS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WHICH
WAS JUST LAST YEAR FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN AT AN A A
DEGREE OR HIGHER WHICH MEANS
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED AT LEAST
TWO YEARS OF OF WORK TO GET YOUR
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE AND A AND A
CREDENTIAL THE THIRD YEAR FOR
CREDENTIALS.
THAT'S THREE YEARS OF FULL TIME
WORK FOR MANY PEOPLE AND
CLASSIFIED SEVERAL WORKING FULL
TIME.
SO THE EARLY YIELD ON THIS WOULD
BE PEOPLE WHO CAME INTO THIS
PROGRAM AS CLASSIFIED STAFF
FORTY HAD A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE.
AND COULD MOVE QUICKLY TO GET
THEIR CREDENTIALS SO THIS IS THE
EARLY LOW HANGING FRUIT IF YOU
WILL WITHIN THE PROGRAM -- AND
IF WE EXPECT THAT IT WILL.
FULLY OF MEET THE IN YOU WILL
GET TO THE TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
CANDIDATES BUT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE THREE TO FIVE YEARS I WOULD
GUESS DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH TIME
THESE CANDIDATES CAN TAKE AWAY
FROM THEIR WORK TO DO FULL TIME
STUDY TURN TO BE AN EVENTUAL.
AND HOW MANY OF THEM HOW FAR
ALONG THEY ALREADY ARE
[inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
AND HOW ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHER
GRANT PROGRAMS SO THE INTEGRATED
TEACHER -- GRANT PROGRAM TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WAS PROVIDED I
ALSO I THINK THAT WAS THE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN YEARS WELL.
OF FORTY ONE PROGRAMS WERE
PROVIDED AND SUPPORTED FOR
DEVELOPMENT AND THEY RECENTLY
HAD TWO YEARS AT OF THE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES TO DEVELOP.
THESE INTEGRATED PROGRAMS WHERE
LIKE CANDIDATE WOULD BE TO
COMPLETE THEIR UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE AND THEIR CREDENTIAL IN
FOUR YEARS FOR A GENERAL AT
CREDENTIAL OR FORD A HALF YEARS.
FOR SPECIAL LIKE CREDENTIAL SO
THEY TOOK TWO YEARS OF TIME WITH
THESE GRANTS TO DEVELOP THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED THEM AND
THEY'VE BEEN ROLLED CANDIDATES
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THOSE
PROGRAMS THIS YEAR -- TWENTY
SEVEN OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
OUR IF WE AND WE DON'T YET KNOW
A WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
COLLECTING INFORMATION ABOUT
ENROLLMENT AND YOU KNOW WHAT WAS
THE FIRST YEAR OF IN ROME AND
WHAT'S YOUR PROJECTION IN TERMS
OF SPACE AND TIME IN RECRUITMENT
EFFORT TO GET THERE.
BUT IF WE ASSUME THAT ALL FORTY
ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS IT ROLL
THIRTY PEOPLE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED TEACHERS COME THROUGH
THESE PROGRAMS IF THEY START AS
FRESHMEN.
IN THESE PROGRAMS -- THANTHAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE THEM FIVE
YEARS FROM FOUR YEARS TO TO
COMPLETING GET THROUGH.
BUT WHAT THIS PROGRAM REFLECTS I
THINK IS A IS A IS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU HAVE.
SHIFTED THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
TEACHER PREPARATION INTO THE
UNDERGRADUATE SPACE WHICH BRINGS
EFFICIENCY WHICH CAPTURES TO
PEOPLE WHO KNOW COMING IN THEY
WANT TO BE TEACHERS.
GIVES THEM A LONGER DEEPER
PREPARATION TO DO SO OVER FOUR
TO FOUR AND A HALF YEARS SO YOU
HAVE INCREASED THE STATE'S.
CAPACITY TO BRING PEOPLE IN AT
THE FRESHMAN LEVEL AND TRAIN
THEM QUICKLY TO GET INTO
TEACHING SO -- WE WILL BE
REPORTING AND COLLECTING DATA ON
WHAT KIND OF ENROLLMENT THEY'RE
HAVING -- OVER TIME -- LOCAL
SOLUTIONS FUNDING THAT CAME TO
US THIS YEAR WE AWARDED FORTY
ONE PROPOSALS WE RECEIVE FIFTY
SIX PROPOSALS FOR LOCAL
SOLUTIONS THIS WAS ALL FOCUSED
ON SPECIAL EDUCATION.
GIVING SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE WHATEVER
RECRUITMENT STRATEGIES SEEM TO
MAKE THE MOST FOR THEM.
IT WAS A HIRING BONUS FOR A
FORGIVABLE LOAN OPPORTUNITY OR
YOU KNOW WHATEVER SEEM TO BE THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING TO GET
SPECIAL FULLY CREDENTIALED
SPECIAL ED TEACHERS IN -- THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE DOING THIS PROGRAM
SHOULD SUPPORT.
THE OF THE HIRING OF TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
THE GOAL OF AND WE WE FOUND THAT
THE FUNDING REQUEST SUCCEEDED
WHAT WAS AVAILABLE BY SEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS -- SO
THERE MAY BE SOME OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT AS WELL --
WE WILL BE.
LOOKING TO SEE HOW THESE
PROGRAMS ARE DOING AND WHAT'S
BEEN EFFECTIVE THERE IS AN
EXPECTATION OF SERVICE
REQUIREMENT FOR TEACHERS TO GET
THESE GRANTS TO STAY FOR I THINK
IT WAS A FOR YEARS.
THANKS FOR YEARS -- SO.
IT'S THIS PROGRAM HAS GREAT
POTENTIAL GREAT DEMAND WILL LET
YOU KNOW WHAT ITS EFFICACY IS AS
WE LEARN IT.
OKAY AND THEN FINALLY THE
TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANT PROGRAMS --
WE SPLIT THAT UP IN SOME WAYS WE
DID SOME CAPACITY BUILDING
INITIALLY LAST YEAR WE SHOULD
GRANTS WE HAVE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO AWARD IN CAPACITY
BUILDING TO BUILD PARTNERSHIPS.
BETWEEN ELEAZAR AND PREPARATION
PROGRAMS AND THEN WE MOVED INTO
AN OF FUNDS FOR EXISTING
RESIDENCES THAT WANTED TO EXPAND.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT MANY
RESIDENCES IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
RECEIVED SEVEN PROPOSALS THERE
AND WE AWARDED FIVE OF THEM. ONE
OF THEM IS FOCUSED IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION ON THE THE FUNDS FOR
RESIDENCIES FIFTY MILLION WERE
SATISFIED FOR SPECIAL LED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR SEVEN BI
LINGUAL -- SO THE THE LARGEST
GRANT PROGRAM THAT THAT WE RAN --
GRANT OUR FEE THAT WE RAN THIS
YEAR WAS FOR THE FULL ARE YOU
READY TO TO BUILD AND DEVELOP.
A RESIDENCY PROGRAM WE RECEIVED
FORTY TWO PROPOSALS FOR THAT WE
AWARDED THIRTY THREE TWENTY
EIGHT OF THEM WERE IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
THESE ARE -- WE EXPECT TO FUND
THESE OVER THE COURSE OF FOUR
YEARS FIRST YOU BUILD A
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AGAIN THIS IS
AN INFRASTRUCTURE.
OF OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY OF LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO WORK WITH A HIGHER
IT.
PARTNER TO BUILD SOMETHING THAT
IS IN DURING BEYOND THESE
FUNDING -- OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT
IT BECOMES AN ON GOING CAPACITY
THAT THE ONLY A HAS.
AGAIN THIS HAS A GREAT DEAL OF
PROMISE BETWEEN THE THE SPECIAL
ED IN STEM FUNDING WE EXPECT
THAT THIS COULD FUND UP.
TO THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED RESIDENTS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS COMING INTO THE
INTO TEACHING SO.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE WITH THESE
PROGRAMS AND HAPPY DANCE IN ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
ABOUT TEST.
FIRST.
YEAH AND AND SO YOU ALREADY DID
THE PARTIAL AWARDS FOR THE
RESIDENCY BUT NOT ALL.
WELL REWARDED THIRTY THREE
GRANTS AND WE EXPECT TO FIND
THEM IN THE SECOND YEAR AND
POSSIBLY A THIRD PARTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SERVING THREE
ELLIE S. ELLIE IT'S TRICKS WE
GOTTA FIND YOU SEND ME THAT LIST
AGAIN.
ABSOLUTELY YEAH WE OKAY.
THANK YOU SURE.
SO WE APPROVE THIS ITEM AND
THAT'S IT PROCEED NOW TO THE
PART OF EDUCATION AND THEIR
STATE OFFICE WILL TRY TO RUN
THROUGH.
THIS QUICKLY BECAUSE WE HAVE --
A BUNCH OF FOLKS COMING TO
TESTIFY
.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ENHANCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE
PROVIDE A BRIEF.
OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STATE OPERATION BUDGET
AND QUICKLY GO THROUGH THE
VARIOUS AUGMENTATIONS ARE
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE OPERATIONS TO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION --
SPECIFICALLY TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION IS PROVIDED.
TO THE DEPARTMENT SPECIFICALLY
HEADQUARTERS OF THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION SEVENTY ONE
MILLION IS NOT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS AND TWENTY NINE
MILLION AND OTHER FUNDS.
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THE STATE'S SPECIAL
SCHOOLS.
OF THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION FIFTY EIGHT MILLION IS
NOT PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. SIXTY ONE MILLION
IS PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
AN ELEVEN MILLION IN OTHER FUNDS.
MOVING ON TO THE VARIOUS
AUGMENTATIONS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES ONE
MILLION SIX HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
AND PAUL POSITIONS -- FOR AN
AUGMENTATION TO THE EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE DIVISION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ADDRESSED INCREASED WORKLOAD IN
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES -- JUST ON
THE QUICK -- QUICKLY NOTE A
COUPLE OF THE MAIN AUGMENTATIONS
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND AND SEVEN POSITIONS TO
MEET NEW COMPLIANCE STANDARDS
FOR THE FEDERAL CHILDCARE
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT.
OF THREE HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO POSITIONS. TO ADMINISTER
THE ADMINISTRATION'S POST
FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
MOVING ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
DIVISION THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND FOR
POSITIONS AS AN AUGMENTATION IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION DIVISION.
OF THAT 500-900-00400 FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND AND GENERAL FUND THREE
POSITIONS TO CREATE A NEW UNIT
WITHIN THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
DIVISION SOLELY FOCUSED ON
ADDITIONAL LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY ACCOUNTABILITY --
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOL NON
PUBLIC SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY.
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS FEDERAL FUNDS
IN ONE POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
INCREASE THE MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS SURROUNDING THE USE
OF RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION IS
ON STUDENTS -- QUICKLY MOVING ON
TO SOME OF THE OTHER VARIOUS
AUGMENTATIONS INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET -- TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS A GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT ACTIVITIES OF
THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION.
A TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION SAM GRANT
PROGRAM.
IN K. TWELVE COMPONENT OF THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
A TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND OR
TWO POSITIONS FOR ONGOING
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION.
AND MAINTENANCE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
HUNDRED FORTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
POSITION TO SUPPORT COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING.
LOCAL INTER AGENCY AGREEMENTS
PLANS FOR CARE FOSTER YOUTH
PURSUANT.
TO AB. 208-300-5000 DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONE POSITION REVIEW
WAIVER SUBMITTED BY DISTRICTS
WHEN THEIR EXPERIENCE A
REDUCTION STUDENT ATTENDANCE OR
LOSS OF INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS.
DUE TO NATURAL DISASTERS ARE
EMERGENCIES AND FINALLY FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES
FOR REVIEWING AND APPROVING
SCHOOL SAFETY PLANTS PURSUANT AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN OTHER
SCHOOL CONCLUDE CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS BE HAPPY TO ASK ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND MY COLLEAGUES
MAY NEED TO COME UP IF YOU HAVE
SPECIFICS ON ANY PARTICULAR
ADJUSTMENT OKAY.
PLEASE.
FOR SIX GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LISA STRIDING ON THE
DIRECTOR THE FISCAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES DIVISION
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TELL ME TONY
THURMOND -- ADD JUST VERBATIM
GAVE MY PRESENTATION SO I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU LA A GOOD MORNING
SERRA CORTEZ LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE PAGE EIGHTEEN
OF YOUR AGENDA INCLUDES A TABLE
THAT SHOWS THE WORKLOAD
PROPOSALS ASSOCIATE POSITIONS
FUNDING AND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
OR FOCUS MY COMMENTS TODAY I'M
PROPOSALS WHERE.
WE HAVE CONCERNS UNDER THE STATE
FUNDS HEADER OF OUR TABLE THE
SECOND PROPOSAL LISTED -- WE
WITHHELD RECOMMENDATION OUR
OFFICE WAS NOT PROVIDED WITH
SUFFICIENT DOCUMENTATION TO
EVALUATE THIS PROPOSAL.
ON THE FIRST PROPOSAL LISTED
UNDER THE STATE'S FUNDS IS RICK
WITH REGARD TO TWELVE POSITIONS
FOR THE EARLY LEARNING CARE
DIVISION.
OF THE TWELVE POSITIONS NINER
FOR EXISTING WORKLOAD AND THREE
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH NEW WORKING
LOW THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN THE
BUDGET -- WITH REGARDS TO THE
NINE POSITIONS FOR EXISTING
WORKLOAD THREE OF THE PERMANENT
POSITIONS ARE TO INCREASE FOR
THE FREQUENCY OF CD EASE TITLE
FIVE COME -- COMPLIANCE REVIEWS
A STATE REGULATIONS REQUIRE THAT
CD EACH CONDUCT ON SITE REVIEWS
ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS AND CD
INDICATES THAT THEY'RE
CONDUCTING REVIEWS ONCE EVERY
FIVE YEARS.
SINCE THIS COMPLIANCE ROUTE IS A
STATE REQUIREMENT WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SOME DISCRETION
HERE -- TO DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF A REVIEW
FOR TITLE FIVE COMPLIANCE -- IN
CONSIDERING WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF REVIEW THEY MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER THE TITLE -- THAT THAT
THERE ARE SOME PROVIDERS ARE
EXPECTED ANNUALLY FOR TITLE
TWENTY TWO COMPLIANCE THAT'S OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS AND
SOME TITLE FIVE PROVIDERS ALSO A
ROUTE.
RECEIVE PERIODIC REVIEWS THROUGH
THE QUALITY RATING IMPROVEMENT
SYSTEM STAND -- QUALITY READY
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM ARE KNOWN AS
Q. R. S..
OTHERS FOR PERMANENT POSITIONS
ALSO INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO INCREASE THE FREQUENCY
OF FISCAL COMPLIANCE REVIEWS OF
FOR EACH CONTRACTOR AT LEAST
ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS -- CD HE
CLAIMS POSITIONS ARE NECESSARY
TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL CALLED
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS -- OUR WITH
OUR REVIEW OF FEDERAL RULES DO
NOT REQUIRE MONITORING OF EVERY
CONTRACTOR ONCE EVERY THREE
YEARS INSTEAD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES THE STATE TO
CALCULATE AND IMPROPER PAYMENT
RATE -- ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS
FROM A SAMPLE OF PROVIDERS --
SINCE THE STATE IS MEETING THIS
REQUIREMENT AND IS IN COMPLIANCE
WITH OF THE ROLE OF THAT THE
REQUIRED FEDERALTHRESHOLD FOR
IMPROPER PAYMENTS ARE WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING IS FOUR
POSITIONS -- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES A ONE
POSITION FOR TO PROVIDE A RIGHT
UP TO COORDINATE REGULATORY
EFFORTS WITHIN THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE DIVISION.
CD CLAIMS THAT A TITLE FIVE
REGULATIONS FOR EARLY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS HAVEN'T BEEN UPDATED
SINCE -- TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
MANY REGULATIONS NOW CONTRADICTS
STATE LAWS IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THAT THE CURRENT
PRACTICES THAT NO OTHER
DIVISIONS HAVE WITHIN CD HAVE
STAFF SPECIFICALLY DEVOTED FOR
THIS REGULATORY WORK -- WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
POSITION AND MAINTAINING THE
CURRENT PRACTICE OF HAVING
EXISTING PROGRAM STAFF CONDUCT
THE REGULATORY WORKLOAD -- AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS UP WITH
THAT THE STEP FUNDING THIS NEW
POSITION FOR THIS PURPOSE
PURPOSE WITH THAT POOR PRECEDENT
IMPLICITLY SIGNALING THAT
DEPARTMENTS ARE ALLOWED TO LET
REGULATIONS BECOME OUTDATED AND
EVEN FISCALLY REWARDED IN SUCH A
CASE -- THEY DO HAVE ONE
POSITION FOR THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THAT
POSITION -- THERE WAS A PORTENT
PROGRAMMED JUDGES.
DEVELOPED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITHOUT
PROPOSAL -- WITH REGARDS TO THE
THREE POSITIONS FOR CURRENT
WORKLOAD -- WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ADDITIONAL
STAFF FOR SOME OF THE MAJOR
PROGRAMS THAT THE GOVERNOR --
INCLUDED IN HIS PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND WAITING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAIT TO MAKE THE
STAFFING DECISIONS AS THESE
PROGRAMS ARE STILL BEING
DEVELOPED.
AND PUT AND ALIGN STAFF.
TO ON THE NECESSARY PROGRAMMATIC
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXAMPLE FOR
PROGRAM -- WOULD BE COME MORE
COMPLEX IT MAY NEED ADDITIONAL
STAFF -- SO WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE OVER THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS TO HELP DETERMINE
THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF STAFF.
TO APPROVE WE ALSO KNOW THAT
EXPLANATIONS AND SOME OF THE
POSITIONS HAVE BEEN CHANGING A
MAKING OF VALUE IN THESE
PROPOSALS -- IT DIFFICULT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO WAIT
UNTIL THE ADMIT THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKE SOME FINAL
DECISIONS.
ABOUT WHAT IT WANTS TO REQUEST
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS MR GALLAGHER --
SO COUPLE THINGS THAT I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT AND ACTUALLY YOU
PLAN TO USE YOUR CHAIRMAN THE
THE MONEY THAT'S THERE TO HELP
WITH -- WAIVERS THE DISTRICTS
MIGHT SUBMIT WHEN THEY WERE
EXPERIENCE A REDUCTION --
PURSUANT TO NATURAL DISASTERS OR
OTHER EMERGENCIES SEE OBVIOUSLY
WITH WHAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH --
IN BUTTE COUNTY -- THAT YOU KNOW
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT IN A GLAD
TO SEE THAT IN THE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET --
THE OTHER THE OTHER ITEM THAT I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS --
THE TWO POSITIONS FOR SEATED EGG.
AS TO OUR SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY HOPING TO
CARRY OUT THE CT PROGRAMS BUT
ALSO SPECIFICALLY IN THERE IS IS
THE REQUIREMENT -- THAT THEY USE
PERKINS ACT THAT CD USES PERKINS
ACT FUNDS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
SIX FULL TIME REGIONAL
AGRICULTURAL -- SUPERVISOR
POSITIONS -- THAT'S BEEN
SOMETHING WE BROUGHT UP.
FOR US.
I THINK ABOUT THREE YEARS NOW --
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THOSE AS
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW YOU'VE SEEN
THE FUTURE FARMERS OF AMERICA
PROGRAM -- YOU KNOW HOW WELL
THAT PROGRAM DOES AND IN TERMS
OF PREPARING -- KIDS ROUTE WITH
LEADERSHIP SKILLS -- AND
PREPARING -- FOR NEO THE COLLEGE
ANOTHER IN IN THE NEXT LEVEL OF
EDUCATION WHATEVER THEY GO ON
INTO -- AND SO THIS ONLY IF WE
REALLY PUSHED ON YOU KNOW WHAT
WE HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN OUT A CD
IS.
IS KIND OF SOME TRANSPARENCY ON
HOW THOSE PERKINS FUNDS ARE
BEING SPENT SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THIS
LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET -- THAT
REQUIRES THEM TO USE THE THE
PERKINS ACT FUNDS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WILL BE THOSE.
THE SIX REGIONAL POSITIONS TO
AND WE HAVE FULL COVERAGE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND TO HELP
SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS -- SO I
WOULD.
HOPE THAT WE CAN DO THAT IS AS
FAR AS THIS COMMITTEE ENSURE
THAT WE KEEP THAT SAME LANGUAGE
OF THE GOVERNOR AS HAS PROVIDED
IN HIS PROPOSED BUDGET
[inaudible]
OKAY. FOR THE QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE WE'RE LOOKING FOR A MOTION
HERE AND OUR STAFF IS GONNA
OUTLINED.
THE HYBRID -- LOTION WERE
LOOKING HERE FOR THAT CD
POSITIONS AND TO APPROVE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS AND AMEND
THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE FOR THE
C. T. POSITIONS THE STRIKE THE
REFERENCE TO THE K. TWELVE
COMPONENT OF THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM [inaudible]
OKAY.
SECOND MOTION A SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MCCARTY HI PRO.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
LIMON.
DINA PURSUE G. FIVE O'DONNELL.
OKAY THANK YOU ISSUE NUMBER FOR
OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE
ACES PROGRAM.
PLEASE -- SOMEONE UP PANEL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I MISS THE MODE YOU WANT TO ADD
ON THE PRIOR ITEMS.
HELLO.
THE ONLY ISSUE ONE AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY FREMONT SCHOOL FOR THE
DEAF -- ISSUED TO CITY OVERALL
BUDGET LIMóN.
OKAY.
GREAT. ONE OF OUR FAVORITE
TOPICS OF THE YEAR OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
EVERYONE LOVES AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM SO.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO STEP IT UP
WITH OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
PLEASE AND LIGHTNESS?
ALRIGHT GOOD MORNING TEAR AND
HAD COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS NATE
IN HOUSTON AND I WORK FOR THE
SINGLE FATHER FAMILIES HELLO
KITTY IN SACRAMENTO -- OUR ASUS
PROGRAM STARTED OVER TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS -- BETWEEN
THREE DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INTACT MIDDLESEX CITY UNIFIED
TWIN RIVERS UNIFIED INTO TOM'S
UNIFIED AND I HAVE WORKED MY WAY
UP FROM A VOLUNTEER TO APART --
TO TO NOW THE DIRECTOR PT FOR
AGENCY AND I WANT TO START WITH
A QUOTE THE SAYS IT IS MORE THAN
ARE HARD WORK IT'S HARD WORK --
MY START IN ACES AS I OF
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PARTICIPATE --
MY PARENTS DIDN'T HAVE --
ADEQUATE SO WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ME WITH ADEQUATE SUPPORT --
FOR WITH HOMEWORK SUPPORT AND SO --
I WENT TO THE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM TO GET THAT -- AFTER
SCHOOL HOMEWORK SUPPORT AND
RECENT ACTIVITIES AND IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE MY FATHER PASSED
AWAY ON AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
STEPPED UP AGAIN IN SUPPORT ME
THROUGH THE PASSING MY FATHER --
GIVE ME OPPORTUNITY TO VOLUNTEER
TO STATE SOME OF THE HARSH
REALITIES AT ALL FACING I GREW
UP IN THAT OF YOU CALIFORNIA
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WOULD SEE ON
MY WAY HOME.
EACH DAY -- WHAT'S THE
HOMELESSNESS -- WE WOULD SEE A
DRUGS GANGS -- ALL KINDS OF
VIOLENCE AND EVEN PROSTITUTION
AND SO THESE ARE THINGS I FACE
ON A DAILY BASIS BUT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM NOT BEING ABLE TO
BE THERE PROVIDING YOU WITH A
SAFE SPACE.
AND PROVIDE A NEW OPPORTUNITY
FOR ME TO SEE -- THINGS THERE
ARE POSITIVE AND THINGS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT ANSWER REALLY SHIFTED
MY PERSPECTIVE -- ACOSTA AROUND
WITH IT SO THAT'S MY WHY I STUCK
A STUCK AROUND WITH AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS BECAUSE SOMEONE STEPPED
UP TO HELP ME.
THROUGH THESE DIFFICULT TIMES OF
MY LIFE AND SO NOW SPENT OVER.
FIFTEEN YEARS GIVING BACK -- TO
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND NOW BEING ABLE TO
TRAVEL THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
ENCOURAGE OTHER EDUCATORS WHO I
DO THE SAME WORK AS I AND A
SPECIFICALLY I JUST WANT TO TALK
ABOUT HOW -- OUR PROGRAM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE -- WE HAVE PROGRAMS
THAT OFFER A STEAM SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND MATH --
WE DO CORRECT CHARACTER
EDUCATION -- SUCH A SECOND STEP
IN -- CHARACTER COUNTS A WE ALSO
DO A CODING AND MATH PROGRAMS TO
EXPOSE RECOGNIZED STUDENTS TO
THESE NEW OPPORTUNITIES THAT.
AS AN AFTER SCHOOL PROVIDERS --
SUPPORT ME THROUGH THAT PROCESS
AND MY FATHER WAS -- BAILEY TO
READ OR WRITE AND SO THESE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE SO IMPORTANT
AND THAT'S WHY I'VE GIVEN UP THE
FIFTEEN UP SEVENTEEN YEARS EXACT
OF MY LIFE -- TO OUR WORK WITH
OUR PROGRAMS AND MY HOPE IS THAT --
YOU WOULD HELP US TO CONTINUE TO
KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN A
SPECIFICALLY I YES I WAS TALKING
TO A GROUP OF STUDENTS THEY SAID
IF I EXT MY SO WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF YOU WERE TO SHUT DOWN ITS
DOORS.
AND FOR SOME OF THEM THEY SAID --
IPROBABLY -- YOU KNOW BE AT THE
PARK HANGING OUT -- ON MY JOIN A
GANG -- SOME OF THEM I BE TRYING
TO SKATE WITH MY BOYFRIEND
GIRLFRIEND I LOVE MY PARENTS AT
WORK.
AND SO THESE PROGRAMS THAT WE
OFFER ON A DAILY BASIS MAKE A
HUGE IMPACT WITH OUR STUDENTS IN
A POSITIVE WAY AND I'M JUST ONE
RESULT OF THE IMPACT OF IT
PROGRAMS ARE NOW DOING AND SO
THIS RESULT THE SHIRT.
THAT SAYS I'M IMPACT IS RESULT
OF AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS SAVING
MY LIFE AND NOW I'M ABLE TO
SHARE MY VOICE -- WITH OTHER
STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND I'VE BEEN YEAR
PROGRAMS YOUR FIRST DANCE OF SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY MY NAME IS JAN DIETRICH
COME FROM THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WHICH IS A
STATEWIDE COALITION THAT
REPRESENTS THE INTERESTS OF HALF
A MILLION CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THAT RELY ON PUBLICLY FUNDED
AFTER.
SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
EVERY DAY.
I APPRECIATE ALL THE ACADEMIC
SUPPORTS AND THAT NAY IT HAS
POINTED OUT HERE IMPROVING
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE REDUCING
DROPOUT RATES HELP.
IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
TRANSITION TO PROFICIENCY BILL
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SKILLS PROMOTE
CAREER EXPLORATION ALL WHILE
PROVIDING CRITICAL CHILD CARE
FOR CHILDREN. FOR SOME STUDENTS
AS YOUNG AS FIVE YEARS OLD
WHETHER PARENTS WORK.
CURRENT CURRENTLY STATEWIDE ASUS
SERVICE FOURTH THAT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN FOUR
THOUSAND SCHOOLS.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR
FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS AND
PRIORITY ENROLLMENT IS GIVEN TO
EXPERIENCING TO YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
OR IN FOSTER CARE.
I WISH WE COULD TALK ABOUT THE
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION STUDENTS
THAT WOULD PARTICIPATE IN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM IF ONE WERE
AVAILABLE.
ESPECIALLY THE NINE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY LOW INCOME ELEMENTARY AND
MIDDLE SCHOOLS.
THAT DON'T OFFER AN AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM AT ALL.
ADDING SLOTS IS A REAL NEED BUT
WE CAN'T ASK FOR MORE SLOTS
UNTIL THE FOUNDATION OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE FIXED.
EACH TIME THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM THE STATE ASUS
PROGRAM SINK DEEPER INTO DEFICIT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE 50%
AND FINING PHRASES HAS INCREASED
9%.
YEARS OF UNDER FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS.
HAVE CAUSED.
THEM TO REDUCE THEIR OFFERINGS
THAT HAVE MADE PROGRAM SO
SUCCESSFUL.
LAKE TUTORING STEM LABS ART
CLASS THE LOSING HIGH QUALITY
STAFF BECAUSE THEY CAN GET
BETTER PAY WITH LESS
RESPONSIBILITY IN FAST FOOD.
TODAY PROGRAMS ARE STRETCHED TO
THE BREAKING POINT AND DON'T
KNOW IF THEY CAN SURVIVE ANOTHER
MINUTE I'M WAGE INCREASE IN
JANUARY AS AN EXAMPLE IN BUTTE
COUNTY.
THEY SERVE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
RULE AND IN ISOLATED STUDENTS
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
AND WITHOUT AN INCREASE IN ASUS
FUNDING THEY WILL HAVE NO OTHER
CHOICE.
BUT TO CLOSE THEIR TWENTY FOUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS IS AN
ISOLATED CASE BUT IT'S HAPPENING
ACROSS THE STATE.
NEARLY ONE IN FOUR PROGRAMS
ACROSS CALIFORNIAEXPECT EXPECT
TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY AND THIS WOULD
LEAVE APPROXIMATELY NINETY ONE
FAT NINETY ONE THOUSAND CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN HIGH NEED
COMMUNITIES WITH OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR PROVIDES CRITICAL
FUNDING THIS YEAR OUR STUDENTS
WILL LOSE HUNDREDS OF ADDITIONAL
LEARNING HOURS THAT HELP KEEP.
HELP CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT AN
OPPORTUNITY GAP.
AND OUR FAMILIES WILL LOSE A KEY
PIECE OF TO THE CHILD CARE
CONTINUE ON THAT HELPS PARENTS
KEEP THEIR JOBS WE ASK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO PLEASE PROVIDE.
THE ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION TO KEEP BASIS
PROGRAMS OPEN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- I HAVE SOME SOME
QUESTIONS TO CAN YOU GO OVER
AGAIN THE IMPACT ON THE THE
MINIMUM WAGE.
AND THE PROGRAM AND I KNOW LAST
YEAR WE FINALLY GAVE UP BOB. TO
YOU AFTER MANY YEARS OF NOT
HAVING A COLOR ANY TYPE OF
ADJUSTMENT.
HE WAS THE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR ENOUGH OF A DECADE
SO LAST WEEK AT A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR.
INCREASE BUT HOW DOES THAT PLAY
OUT AS FAR AS THE REAL COST AND
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE IN LABOR
COSTS AND SO FORTH ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
I'M IT SO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THAT WAS THE FIRST INCREASE IN
ASUS AND IN OVER A DECADE.
AT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WAS THE
9% INCREASE -- THE WAY THAT WE
HAVE ANALYZED FINDING.
EACH TIME THAT MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES A DOLLAR ACES PROGRAMS
NEED ABOUT FIFTY CENTS MORE PER
pWHAT THE MINIMUM WAGE -- AND SO
CURRENTLY PROGRAMS ARE FIND
EIGHT EIGHT DOLLARS AND NINETEEN
CENTS PER STUDENT PER DAY.
IT CAME UP FROM SEVEN DOLLARS
AND FIFTY CENTS PER STUDENT PER
DAY SO.
AS MUCH AS WE WERE ABLE TO GAIN
FROM THAT FINDING INCREASE BACK
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT IS NOW
LOST EACH TIME THE MINIMUM WAGE
CAN HAD CONTINUES TO GO OUT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND AND THEN -- SO THERE THE
REQUEST -- THIS YEAR IS -- IS
THE AMOUNT YOUR CALL AMOUNTS THE
THE REQUEST THIS YEAR IS A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION.
THAT'S TO THAT TAKES AN ACCOUNT
THE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES FROM
TWENTY IN THE LARGEST ONES FROM
TWENTY FOURTEEN TELL TODAY -- WE
ARE ALSO WORKING -- WITH A SEVEN
MEMBER CREO TO ALSO PROVIDE A
COLA -- IN FUTURE YEARS GROWTH
SO WE DO NOT KEEP COMING BACK
WITH THE SAME PROBLEM AS MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES AND ASK COST OF
LIVING.
CONTINUES TO INCREASE THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS WE WE DON'T KEEP
CREATING THE SAME PROBLEM.
YEAH I I THINK IT'S IT'S FAIR
WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR I JUST AS
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE STATE BUDGET
ARE.
CERTAINLY -- PROPERLY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WE RECOGNIZED THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE CAN PAY OUR
OUR WORKERS IN THIS FIELD --
WAGES AREN'T POVERTY WAGES AND
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO BUT
DOING SO HAS AN IMPACT AND JUST
SIMPLE MATHEMATICS SO THAT IF
THOSE WAGES GO UP.
FEAR STUDENTS SO WILL BE SERVED
SO.
IF THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN THIS YEAR
WHAT WOULD THE IMPACT BE ON THE
LINE THE LOSS OF PROGRAMS THE
STUDENTS AGAIN.
SO WE ARE ESTIMATING -- BASED ON
OUR STATEWIDE SURVEY NEARLY ONE
IN FOUR PROGRAMS EXPECT TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS ACROSS THE STATE.
WITHOUT FINDING BY.
TWENTY TWENTY AND SAID THAT
WOULD IMPACT ABOUT NINETY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS WOULD LOSE
THEIR THEIR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM.
AND WE KNOW THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE
THESE HE'S PROGRAMS ARE IN HERE
IN OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY A LITTLE
BIT THERE.
IN A VIABLE FOR WORKING.
PARENTS BUT ALSO AS YOU SAID --
KEEP KIDS OUT OF TROUBLE YOU
KNOW THE POLICE CHIEFS ALWAYS
SAY BETWEEN THREE AND SIX IS
PRIME TIME FOR JUVENILE CRIME
AND FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND KIDS
ABOUT SAYING IT ALL GO AND
COMMIT -- THAT STUFF BUT YOU
KNOW KIDS BE KIDS SOMETIMES AND
SO HAVING THESE PROGRAMS.
BETWEEN THREE AND SIX ARE ARE
ARE CRITICAL ANOTHER THING THAT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESS THE LONG TERM NOT JUST
GENERAL FUND IS THAT.
WE PUT ON THE BALLOT TWO YEARS
AGO PROP SIXTY FOUR TO LEGALIZE
MARIJUANA AND WE SAID THREE
THINGS WE SHOULD TAX IT
[inaudible]
REGULATED.
AND USE THE REVENUES FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS TO LITERALLY WAS ON THE
TV COMMERCIAL.
IT WAS ON THE MAILERS TO
PEOPLE'S HOMES AND IT WAS ON THE
BALLOT ARGUMENTS AND SO.
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO HONOR
THAT WILL AND THAT MONEY IS NOT --
POURING IN -- JUST YET AND THE
FIRST PART OF IT HAS TO GO TO TO
PAY FOR SOME OTHER --
COMMITMENTS AS FAR AS THE BALLOT
MEASURE BUT I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO HOLD ITS ON THAT ISSUE
THEY'RE THEY'RE A LOT OF IDEAS
HOW TO SPEND THAT MONEY.
BUT YOU KNOW THIS IS A THIS IS
AN EFFORT THAT WE KNOW MAKES
SENSE AND THIS IS ACTUALLY.
WAS A COMMITMENT TO THE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA.
SO MISTER GALLAGHER.
YEAH I WAS GONNA SAY I MEAN --
THESE PROGRAMS WE'VE SEEN HOW
VITAL THEY ARE -- IN A LOT OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AS I'VE SEEN IT
FIRST HAND UP IN -- IN THE IN
THE BUTTE COUNTY -- WITH THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF THE NORTH
VALLEY HAVE THEIR AND AND AND
AND IN FACT YOU IN THE AFTERMATH
OF THE FIRE.
WHERE WE HAD -- THEY HAD A THEY
HAD SEVERAL -- PROGRAMS UP THERE
ON THE RIDGE.
THIS YEAR THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE
I CAME THAT SECOND HOME -- FOR A
LOT OF THOSE KIDS WHO WERE.
THE OBVIOUS HE HAD LOST THEIR
HOME HAD BEEN TO A VERY
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE AND WAS THE
PLACE WHERE THEY CAN GET.
SOME NORMALCY -- SO WE REALLY
SAW.
I MEAN WE ALREADY SEE THE VALUE
BUT I I MEAN LIKE WAS LIKE
ESPECIALLY HIGHLIGHTED -- AS I
WAS WORKING WITH THEM.
WITH THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB IN
AND THEY'VE GOT A GREAT STAFF
OVER THERE -- YOU KNOW AS I'M AS
I'M SHARED IT AS YOURS IS HERE
IN SACRAMENTO -- AND SO --
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE KNOW THAT
WE NEED TO THE WE'RE NOW I'D I
HAD HEARD I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
IS RIGHT OR NOT BUT THAT THERE
WAS MAYBE SOME MONEY THAT HAD
GOTTEN RETURNED BACK TO THE
STATE BECAUSE IT IS BECAUSE IT
WASN'T BEING.
UTILIZE LOCALLY OR MAYBE THERE
WERE SOME ISSUES WITH THAT HAVE
WE WHERE IS THAT FUNDING NOW AND
LIKE FOR PROGRAMS THAT MAYBE DO
NEED SOME ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IS
THAT SOMETHING WE COULD
REPURPOSE -- YOU KNOW -- IN IN
IN DIFFERENT AREAS MAYBE MAYBE
YOU COULD SPEAK.
TO YES -- WE HAVE.
IN A SCENE I LEGISLATION OUT
THERE THAT.
TRIES -- TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST
WAY WITH THE THESE UNSPENT FUNDS
SO WHAT YOU KNOW I WOULD DEFER
TO EXPERTS AT CD BUT WHAT I'VE
HEARD FROM THEM IS THAT.
WITH ANY GRANT PROGRAM THERE'S A
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S
LEFT ON THE TABLE EACH YEAR FOR
EXAMPLE DUE TO EVENTS LIKE MADE
YEAR ATTENDANCE CHANGES AND SO.
ONE PROGRAM HASN'T COME BACK AND
TAKING ALL THE MONEY AS THEY HAD
HOPED -- HOWEVER EMAIL I
WOULDN'T SAY THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE OF AN UNDER SUBSCRIBE
PROGRAM.
AND IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN COHORT FOR ASUS
PROGRAMS APPLICANTS REQUESTED
FOUR TIMES AS MUCH -- THAT WAS
AVAILABLE TO BE FIND IT SO.
THERE IS THERE IS -- I THINK
HERE EVERY YEAR A LITTLE BIT
LEFT THAT JUST.
DUE TO TECHNICAL CHANGES
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AT THAT.
WE ARE VERY INTERESTED IN HOW
THOSE FUNDS GETS BAND AND WE
APPRECIATE.
AT THE SENATE MEMBER FROM LOOK
FOR LOOKING INTO THAT -- AND HOW
TO BEST USE THAT FINDING -- BUT
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY IN TERMS
OF OVERALL -- SUBSCRIPTION TO
THIS ACCOUNT.
WELL THAT'S ONE I MEAN KIND OF
SIMILAR.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN DO THAT
HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE DO HAVE MAYBE
SOME UNSUBSCRIBE FUNDS.
IN THIS CURRENT YEAR.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE HAD PROGRAMS
THAT I'VE SEEN BEEN IMPACTED BY
DISASTER THAT KIND OF SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE DID IN THE PREVIOUS ITEM.
IF THERE WAS THE ABILITY TO
MAYBE SET ASIDE SOME FUNDING TO
HELP SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
IF MAYBE HAD -- NEO BUT AN EVEN
GREATER NEED JUST BECAUSE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENED -- AND SOME OF
THE YOU KNOW THE TRAUMA THAT.
KIDS IN A BAND COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD DO -- IN THIS IN
THIS COMMITTEE OR I MEAN.
AT SHIRT IT'S WE KEEP A RUNNING
LIST UP HERE OF ALL OF OUR GOOD
IDEAS AND AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
ON THE LIST WHAT I I'D LIKE TO
JUST -- FOCUS ON THE OVERALL
ASUS PROGRAM WHICH RALPH.
THESE LEADER NOT SURE ABOUT IT
BUT BUT HELP ISSUES IN.
URBAN AREAS IF I HOT HIGH COST
OF LIVING AND THEY'VE DONE
THEY'VE DONE A SECONDARY BALLOT
MEASURE FOR MINIMUM WAGE SOME
SAN JOSE.
SAN DIEGO LOS ANGELES ABOUT
THEIR OWN SAYS HE HAD BEEN HIRED
IN THE STATE.
AND SO YOU'RE SEEING YOU KNOW
MORE PRESSURE ON THOSE PROGRAMS
SOME.
I THINK ALL AROUND BUT THIS IS
DEFINITELY A HIGH PRIORITY.
WE TRY THE LAST FEW YEARS IN THE
BUDGET TO TO TO INCREASE FOR
AFTER SCHOOL -- PROGRAMS AND
CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS ISSUE
OFTEN. FOR NOW WE'RE GOING TO
PROCEEDS WITH -- ISSUE HERE
[inaudible]
HAVE -- SOME LEGISLATORS ARE
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE AS WELL SO
THIS IS ON SCHOOL NUTRITION
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FIRST FROM
DEPARTMENT OF THAT.
GIVES AN OVERVIEW OF OUR SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AND SOME.
BUDGET -- REQUEST RELATE TO
SCHOOL MEALS AND NUTRITION.
SO FIRST GOING TO BRING UP LISA
MEL HOUSE OF DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
AND THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM -- SOME
OF OUR COLLEAGUES.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM LEAST
AMOUNT HOW SO MANY TRIPS
NOTIFICATION ADMINISTRATOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
AND I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME THIS
MORNING TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF SCHOOL NUTRITION AND
THE WORK THAT WE OVERSEE.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ADMINISTERS AND
PROVIDES A SYSTEM OF SUPPORT TO
OVER THREE THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
PROGRAM SPONSORS.
THAT OPERATE ONE OF THE US
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE'S
CHILD NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
THES FEDERAL NUTRITION PROGRAMS
ARE INTENDED TO SAFEGUARD THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
CHILDREN AND TO PROVIDE
NUTRITIOUS YEAR ROUND ACCESS TO
MEALS.
THE DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERS SEVEN
OF THE FEDERAL CHILD NUTRITION
PROGRAMS THE MAIN FOCUS TODAY IS
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES BOTH BREAKFAST AND
LUNCH.
THE NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM IN SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PROGRAM PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENT
TO PROGRAM OPERATORS THAT
PROVIDE A NUTRITIONALLY BALANCED
BREAKFAST OR LUNCH TWO CHILDREN
EACH SCHOOL DAY.
OF THE SIX POINT TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN ENROLLED IN
SCHOOLS 60% ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
IN SCHOOL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN PROGRAM
OPERATORS SERVED OVER FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE POINT
NINE MILLION LUNCHES.
AND OVER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
BREAKFASTS TO NEEDY CHILDREN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
PROGRAM OPERATORS ARE REIMBURSED
FOR MEALS BASED ON THE STUDENTS
FREE REDUCED PRICE ARE PAID
ELIGIBILITY STATUS.
CHILDREN FROM FAMILIES WITH
INCOME AT OR BELOW A HUNDRED AND
30% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE.
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FREE MEALS.
THOSE WITH INCOMES BETWEEN A
HUNDRED AND 31% AND A HUNDRED
AND 85% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL ARE ELIGIBLE FOR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS.
THE REST ARE CONSIDERED PAID
STUDENTS.
BARSTOOLSPORTS SCHOOLS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
FEDERAL SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES THAT
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS OF SCHOOLS TO
OFFER ALL NEEDY STUDENTS AT
LEAST ONE NUTRITIONALLY ADEQUATE
FREE.
OR REDUCED PRICE MEALS DURING
THE SCHOOL DAY.
WE REFER TO THIS A BAR LAW AS A
STATE MAIL MANDATE.
CALIFORNIA ADD CODE SECTION FOUR
NINE FIVE FIVE ZERO REFERS TO
THE STATE MIL MANDATE.
THE STATE MIL MANDATE WILL
EXTEND TO CHARTER SCHOOL
STARTING THIS JULY FIRST AND
THIS WAS AFTER THE PASSING OF AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE LAST YEAR.
THEREFORE ALL MEALS REGARDLESS
OF BEING ON THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
OR NOT IN CALIFORNIA MUST MEET
THE FEDERALLY MANDATED MALE
PATTERN REQUIREMENTS.
THE MALE PATTERN STANDARDS
REFLECT THE MOST CURRENT DIETARY
SCIENCE THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE DIETARY GUIDELINES FOR
AMERICANS AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE.
THE MALES MUST FOLLOW THE FOOD
BASE MANY PINING OF FOR APPROACH
THAT FOCUSES ON FOOD COMPONENTS.
FIVE FOOD COMPONENTS NEED TO BE
OFFERED FOR REIMBURSABLE LUNCH.
FRUIT VEGETABLES GRAINS MEET
MEET ALTERNATE AND MILK. THREE
FOOD COMPONENTS MUST BE OFFERED
FOR REIMBURSABLE BREAKFAST FRUIT
GRAINS AND MILK.
PLANT BASED OPTIONS CAN BE MADE
AVAILABLE WITH THE USE OF MEAT
ALTERNATIVES THAT INCLUDE NUTS
AND SEED BUTTERS.
BEANS PEAS AND LEGUMES AND SOY
PROTEINS SUCH AS SO YOGURT TOFU
AND VEGGIE BURGERS.
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE
ESTABLISHED EACH YEAR BY THE
USDA.
AND FOR THOSE THAT PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM THE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR SCHOOL
YOU'RE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR
LUNCH.
IS THREE DOLLARS AND THIRTY
SEVEN CENTS FOR A FREE MEAL. TWO
DOLLARS AND NINETY SEVEN CENTS
FOR REDUCED PRICE BEAL AND
THIRTY CENTS FOR A PAID MAIL.
IN ADDITION OPERATORS RECEIVE AN
EXTRA POINT TWO THREE SIX EIGHT
CENTS IN STATE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
EACH FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
MEALS SERVED.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE CITY A REIMBURSED
NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM IS
GO BURKE BREAKFAST PROGRAM
PROGRAM OPERATORS A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION IN STATE REIMBURSEMENT.
ANY MAIL SERVER THAT DO NOT MEET
THE MALE PATTERN REQUIREMENTS
CANNOT BE CLAIM FOR
REIMBURSEMENT -- EARLIER THIS
MONTH THE USDA RELEASED NATIONAL
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT TITLE
SCHOOL NUTRITION AND MIL COST
STUDY.
THE STUDY REPORTED THAT ON
AVERAGE ACROSS ALL SCHOOL FOOD
AUTHORITIES REVENUES FROM
REIMBURSABLE LUNCHES COVERED
ONLY AN AVERAGE OF 93% OF
REPORTED COSTS.
OF PRODUCING THOSE MEALS AND
REVENUES FROM REIMBURSABLE
BREAKFAST COVERED AN AVERAGE OF
82% OF REPORTED COSTS.
THESE RESULTS SUPPORT WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM OUR
PROGRAM OPERATORS THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
CHILD NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
AND WITH THAT I CONCLUDE MY
PRESENTATION AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU HOLD OFF -- FOR
FOR NOW I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
PROPOSALS HERE.
WHAT'S THE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I RUBIO ALSO ONE
OF THAT SHARE WITH US HER
THOUGHTS ON INVESTMENTS IN THIS
AREA.
PLEASE JOIN US.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS FOR GRANTS
TO SCHOOLS -- FOOD AUTHORITIES
THEY WANT TO START UP IN EXPAND
BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL NOW I
DO HAVE SOME PREPARED STATEMENTS
BUT I WAS I WAS READING THROUGH
MY STATEMENTS I WANTED TO TELL
YOU A PERSONAL STORY.
BECAUSE I WAS A TEACHER AND
FONTANA UNIFIED AND I SPENT
SIXTEEN YEARS IN THE CLASSROOM
AND A FEW YEARS AGO I HAD TO
STUDENTS.
IN MY CLASSROOM THAT WERE
SISTERS AND THEY THEY OBVIOUSLY
ONE OF THEM HAD BEEN RETAIN
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT OF THE
SAME AGE.
AND AS BOTTOM -- I'M SORRY
FONTANA UNIFIED HAD BURKE
BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL SO IT
WAS MONDAY MORNING I'M WALKING
IN AND I'M A STRICT TEACHER AND
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ALL ON TIME.
AND THE TWO LITTLE GIRLS WERE
LATE AND I NOTICED THAT -- THEY
WERE YOU KNOW NOT NECESSARILY
SHOWERED AND THE HIDING WASN'T
GREAT BUT I SAID YOU KNOW GO GO
GO GET YOUR BREAKFAST AND YOU
KNOW MEET ME IN THE CLASSROOM
BECAUSE I KNEW.
THAT WE HAD BREAKFAST AFTER THE
BELL AND SO THEY COME IN I TO
THE CLASSROOM AND ONE OF THE
LITTLE GIRLS SAYS THAT YOU KNOW
MIGHT MISS RUBIO MY TUMMY HURTS.
AND I SAID OH OKAY WHAT YOU KNOW
FINISH YOUR BREAKFAST OR F YOU
NEED TO GO TO THE BATHROOM LET'S
GO TO THE BATHROOM AND I SAID
JOB YOU KNOW I RECESS AT TEN
THIRTY IN THE MORNING.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN GO TO THE NURSE
AND SO I'M.
THINKING YOU KNOW I LET'S GET TO
WORK LET'S GET -- TO ARE ARE
READING THIS IN FOR THE DAY SHE
COMES BACK TO ME AND SAYS I MISS
RUBIO MY TUMMY HURTS AND I SAID --
OKAY WELL MAYBE BECAUSE YOU WAY
TOO FAST YOU KNOW I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE IT OUT AND AS I KEEP
TALKING TO HER I SAID -- WELL
MAYBE WHAT YOU ATE LAST NIGHT IS
GIVING YOU A TUMMY ACHE AND I
SAID WOULD TREAT LAST NIGHT SHE
SAYS SERIAL.
AND I WENT.
OH AND I SAID WHAT DID YOU EAT
FOR LUNCH AND SHE SAID.
SERIAL.
METHOD WHICH READ FOR BREAKFAST.
SERIAL AND I WENT OH AS IT HOW
MANY TIMES DID YOU EAT YESTERDAY.
AND SHE SAID ONCE.
AND SO OF COURSE I'M.
FEELING NOT SO GOOD ABOUT MYSELF
BECAUSE HERE I AM TRYING TO GET
ORDERS START READING AND WRITING
AND SO I REALIZE THAT THAT WAS
THE ONLY MEAL SHE HAD HAD THAT
DAY ON A SUNDAY.
AND SO THE FACT THAT I CENTER TO
GET BREAKFAST.
WAS ACTUALLY A GOOD THING BUT I
DIDN'T REALIZE BECAUSE WE ALL
LIVE IN OUR LITTLE BUBBLES THAT --
NOT EVERYBODY HAS BREAKFAST
LUNCH AND DINNER ON SUNDAYS OR
ITS SATURDAYS AND SO SO THE
BREAKFAST AFTER THE MEAL --
PROVIDED HER AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY EAT AND YOU KNOW SHE
WAS FINE AFTERWARDS BUT IT MADE
ME REALIZE THAT NOT.
EVERYBODY HAS -- THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE TO TO EAT AND IF I WOULD
HAVE NOT BEEN CONSCIOUS ABOUT IT
AND KNOWN THAT THE THE SCHOOL
PROVIDED -- BREAKFASTS I
WOULDN'T OF SAID HAGEL GET YOUR
BREAKFAST AND COME BACK -- IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AND AS A
FORMER TEACHER I CAN TELL YOU
THAT WE HAVE A A TON OF KIDS.
THAT THE ONLY MEAL THAT THEY
HAVE ARE ARE IN SCHOOL AND THE
BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL -- ALSO
PROVIDES THE TEACHERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE KIDS ARE FED AND SOMEONE
WE'RE REQUIRING BILLS TEACH
THOSE KIDS. TO TO PERFORM AT
LEAST WE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EAT -- AGAIN IT
WASN'T I MY PREPARED STATEMENTS
BUT I WANTED TO MAKE IT --
PERSONAL BECAUSE I DID SPENT
SIXTEEN YEARS IN THE CLASSROOM
AND I SAW A LOT OF THE THE
BENEFITS OF PROVIDING MEALS TO
THESE KIDS AND SO I REQUEST OF
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
CONSIDERATION ON THESE BUDGET
PROPOSALS BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
NOT JUST -- NOT NOT JUST FOR THE
KIDS BUT I THINK IF WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT LIFTING KIDS OUT
OF POVERTY EDUCATION IS THE
NUMBER -- ONE FACTOR TO LEAVE
LIFT THESE KIDS OUT OF POVERTY
AND IF THEY'RE NOT FED -- WE CAN
REQUIRED.
READING MATH AND ARITHMETIC ARE
WE WHAT IS IT READING -- READING
AND ARITHMETIC RIGHT AND THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE.
ALL OF THE THE IMPORTANT LESSONS
BUT IF THE KIDS ARE NOT ABLE TO
FUNCTION BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
EATEN THEN THEN WE'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING FOR THE SKIT SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND I
HOPE THAT -- YOU WILL ALL
CONSIDER THE BREAKFAST AFTER A
GUN THANKS FOR YOUR SHARING YOUR
STORY THAT.
WAY MORE EFFECTIVE THAN YEAR
THANK YOU STOCKING POINTS.
RIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW WE DID THIS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO.
I THOUGHT IT WAS EFFECTIVE AND
WILL CERTAINLY TEND TO DO SO
AGAIN AND A LOT OF IT AS YOU
KNOW THIS IS JUST START UP COSTS
IN GETTING ITS PROGRAMS GOING SO.
RIGHT.
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW THANK YOU --
IT IS THE CASE -- WE AS A
LEGISLATURE AND I THINK AS A
SOCIETY WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
EDUCATION BEING THE NUMBER --
ONE EQUALIZER RIGHT AND AND SOME
OF OUR STUDENTS BECAUSE I WAS A
TEACHER SOME OF THE STUDENTS ARE
NOT PREPARED -- TO TO LEARN
BECAUSE THEY'RE HUNGRY THEY
HAVEN'T HAD THE BASIC NEEDS MET
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION ON THIS ON THIS
ISSUE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE WE'RE WAITING --
FOR A FEW LEGISLATORS TO COME IN
AND SHARE THEIR BUDGET PROPOSALS
BUT IN THE INTERIM WE CAN.
START DOING PUBLIC COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT CAN HOLD UP A SEC.
SO SOMEONE OR CREATE WEEK WEEK
WE WE FINISHED UP THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM BUT PLEASE COME
UP AND SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
INVESTING IN OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS [inaudible]
THANK YOU. THIRTY THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT I PRESENT TO
YOUR COMMITTEE SO -- THANK YOU
ONE RULE DON'T MENTION A BILL
THIS IS AN IDEA ALL THEY'VE BEEN
ADVISED ON AN IDEA.
WHAT IS THE BILL WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT HOW MANY ASKING?
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM
HERE TO TO SPEAK ABOUT.
OUR ASUS PROGRAM OF FISCAL
EDUCATION -- AND SAFETY PROGRAMS
WHICH AS YOU KNOW OUR
CORNERSTONES TO OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND THE BUDGET REQUEST
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE A PLAY.
THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH ACADEMIC ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES THAT IMPROVE THEIR
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL CONNECTIONS WITH THEIR
PEERS.
IN CALIFORNIA THE EIGHTH PROGRAM
SERVES MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AT FORTY TWO HUNDRED SCHOOLS
ACROSS OUR STATE EVERY DAY.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE OFTEN
ESSENTIAL FOR WORKING PARENTS
WHO WORK TIRELESSLY TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN BUT OFTEN
CANNOT AFFORD AFTER SCHOOL CHILD
CARE HOWEVER OVER THE TIME COST
TO OPERATE THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED.
SINCE ASUS WAS IMPLEMENTED THE
CALIFORNIA MINIMUM WAGE HAS
INCREASED BY 50%.
AND THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX HAS
INCREASED BY 30% WHILE THE DAILY
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR ASUS HAS
ONLY INCREASED 9%.
AS A RESULT THESE PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE FREQUENTLY
STRUGGLE TO STAY OPEN.
ACCORDING TO THE SURVEY
REPRESENTING MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITHOUT FUNDING
INCREASES A ONE IN FOUR PROGRAMS
IT'S EXPECTED TO CLOSE.
THEIR DOORS TO ABOUT NINETY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THIS BUDGET ITEM
PROVIDE A HUNDRED AND TWELVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION AND CONTINUE
WITH FUNDING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF THE EDUCATION. FOR
THESE CRITICAL AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THUS BRINGING THE
FUNDING FORMULA FROM EIGHT
DOLLARS AND NINETEEN CENTS TO
NINE DOLLARS AND SEVENTY FIVE
CENTS.
PER STUDENT PER DAY WHICH QUITE
FRANKLY IN MY OPINION IS NOT
ENOUGH WHEN IT COMES TO THE
EDUCATION OF OUR CHILDREN ACROSS
THE STATE.
WITH THIS APPROPRIATION OUR
STATE WILL ALLOW ASUS FUNDING TO
GROW WITH FUTURE MINIMUM WAGE
AND COST OF LIVING INCREASES TO
CONTINUE SERVING CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES THIS FUNDING
WILL ENSURE THAT THE ASUS
PROGRAMS THEY OPEN.
PROVIDE NUTRITIOUS MEALS --
NUTRITIOUS MEALS AND CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TUTORING AN ESSENTIAL
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES TO
ALL STUDENTS WHICH INCLUDE MUSIC
ARTS STEM PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
ALSO LESS YOU KNOW -- BENEFIT
THE FUTURE OF THE STATE SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU WE HAD A A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS AND MISTER
GALLAGHER TALK ABOUT HOW THIS IS
A VALUE UP IN -- RURAL NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS SACRAMENTO
AND URBAN LA AND WE KNOW WHAT
THE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
REALLY SQUEEZE TO THESE PROGRAMS
AND SO -- WE WE DID AND
INVESTMENT LAST YEAR FIRST TIME
EVER. FOR THE ASUS PROGRAM BUT
THERE IS A DOLLARS AND GOING AS
FAR NUMEROUS WILL ATTEND TO DO
SO AGAIN THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU WHEN IT COMES TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WHICH
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE A CHAMPION
OF K. THROUGH TWELVE AFTER
SCHOOL.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU COME
FROM A INNER CITY URBAN AREA OR
RULE DISTRICT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
RESOURCES IN THE FUTURE OF OUR
STATE WHICH I THINK.
YOU KNOW REGARDLESS OF WHERE YOU
COME FROM ACROSS THE STATE THIS
IS THE PRIORITY FOR WHO WE ARE.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
WOULD LIKE -- TO JOIN US TALK
ABOUT A A TEACHER GRANT PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE
THE RIGHT RIVAS.
WHAT'S THAT IS THIS WHAT DO YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT RIVAS I HELP YOU
DO.
WE GO I HAVE A GRANT PROGRAM
THAT'S ON THE ONCE AGAIN I MEAN
I WE'RE GONNA SEE WAS A CHAIR
AND I AM HERE AT THIS WANTED TO
REQUEST FINDING FINDING.
NEEDED TO HELP ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF QUALIFIED TEACHERS
IN OUR STATE.
EARLIER THIS YEAR I SUBMITTED A
LETTER REQUESTING A HUNDRED
MILLION OR MORE FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM.
A BILL I'VE BEEN WORKING ON WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL A BILL
THAT A YOU KNOW AN EFFORT THAT
HE IS CHAMPION OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
AND SO SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE TO
ANY MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
AND AND IN THIS LEGISLATURE THAT
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE HAVING
A VERY VERY TOUGH TIME.
RECRUITING AND RETAINING
QUALIFIED CREDENTIALED TEACHERS --
THE PROBLEM SEEMS TO BE GETTING
WORSE AS THE COST OF BECOMING A
TEACHER THEY THEY CONTINUE TO
RISE AND SAY RECENT COPIES OF
SURVEY OF TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA.
REVEALED THAT NEARLY THREE
QUARTERS COULD NOT FIND ENOUGH
QUALIFIED TEACHERS TO FILL THE
CLASSROOMS.
I IN FACT THE SUPPLY OF NEW
TEACHERS IS CURRENTLY HOVERING A
TWELVE YEAR LOW.
AND ACCORDING TO SOME DATA FROM
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
ROUGHLY TWO THIRDS OF NEW
CALIFORNIA.
PREPARED SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS ON SUB STANDARD
CREDENTIALS.
IN MATH THE NUMBER OF FULLY
PREPARED CANDIDATES WITH
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIALS HAS
DECREASED BY 50% IN SIX YEARS.
AND SO FOR THESE REASONS I
REQUEST AT THIS BUDGET
ALLOCATION THUS CREATING AND
FUNDING THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
GRANT PROGRAM.
AND THIS PROGRAM ITSELF -- IT
PROPOSES -- TO PROVIDE ONE TIMES --
THE SERVICE SCHOLARSHIP GRANTS
OF TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
CANDIDATES TO COMMIT TO TEACHING
FOR FOUR YEARS IN A HIGH NEED
SUBJECT AREA THIS INCLUDES
BILINGUAL EDUCATION SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND STAB SUBJECT
MATTERS.
AND SO CERTAINLY THIS THIS
ALLOCATION IS THIS THIS THIS
BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE ONE
ENTIRELY SOLVE OUR TEACHER
SHORTAGE PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WILL CERTAINLY GO A LONG WAY
TO HELP CREATE THE INCENTIVES
NEEDED TO INCREASE THE PIPELINE
OF QUALIFIED TEACHERS IN
SUBJECTS SHORTAGE AREAS.
WITH THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER WE WE HAD A
DISCUSSION A LITTLE WHILE AGO
WITH THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TALK ABOUT THE
TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAM.
AND THAT WE USED TO HAVE A CAL
GRANT T. PROGRAM UP FRONT TO
GIVE YOU MONEY TO GET YOUR
CREDENTIAL WE DO HAVE THE LOAN
FORGIVENESS THE APPLE PROGRAMS
WHICH IS.
AS MAYES DOUBT SO I KNOW MISTER
RODRIGUEZ'S IS PURSUING THAT BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT -- WE NEED TO
HELP GET MORE PEOPLE IN THE
CLASSROOM THERE ARE. SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE TEACHING TODAY
WITH AN EMERGENCY CREDENTIAL AND
NOT GOOD FOR KIDS SO RIGHT.
I WAS ON THE LIST FOR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. FOR
ALLOWING ME SPEAK THIS MORNING
ON BUDGET REQUEST IT RELATES TO
EDUCATION FINANCE FIRST ARE TO
ACTUALLY I'M SORRY FIRST I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON BETTER REQUEST
FOR THE CLEAN ENERGY JOBS
CREATION PROGRAM.
SPECIFICALLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATION TO THE
PROGRAM IN ORDER SUPPORT LOCAL
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT EFFORTS TO INSTALL COST
EFFECTIVE ENERGY PROJECTS.
IN TWENTY TWELVE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS APPROVED PROP THIRTY NINE
A MEASURE THAT INCREASED STATE
REVENUES BY APPROXIMATELY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
OVER FIVE YEARS HALF OF THOSE
REVENUES WERE ALLOCATED TO
PROGRAM FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AS OF JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN PROP THIRTY
NINE PROJECTS WERE APPROVED A K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS WITH ANYA
ALLOCATIONS AVERAGING THREE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE FIVE YEARS OF THE
PROGRAM.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION THESE PROJECTS
ARE PROJECTED TO PRODUCE AN
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION IN ANNUAL ENERGY COST
SAVINGS.
IN ADDITION TO THE COST SAVINGS
THAT WILL BE PRODUCED BY THESE
PROJECTS ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO THE
LOCAL ECONOMY ARE WELL
DOCUMENTED.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
APPROXIMATELY NINETEEN THOUSAND
JOBS HAVE BEEN CREATED SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE K. TWELVE PROP
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE PROGRAM.
DESPITE THE SUCCESS OF THIS
PROGRAM FUNDING ALLOCATIONS TO
THE PROGRAM EXPIRED IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS IS LEFT
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A STATE WIDE
PROGRAM TO MAKE SCHOOLS MORE
RESOURCE AND ENERGY EFFICIENT.
A LACK OF STATEWIDE PROGRAM IS
ESPECIALLY CONCERNING GIVEN THE
INCREASING ENERGY DEMANDS THAT
SCHOOLS FACE TO SUPPORT THE
GROWING USE OF ELECTRONIC
DEVICES IN OUR SCHOOLS TODAY.
PROVIDING A ONE TIME THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION TO CLEAN ENERGY JOB
CREATION PROGRAM IS A SMALL WAY
TO CONTINUE A PROGRAM THAT HAS
PROVEN TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
BY PROVIDING APPROPRIATION TO
THIS PROGRAM CALIFORNIA'S TAKE
ACE STEP CLOSER TO MEETING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS REDUCE ENERGY
COSTS FOR SCHOOLS AND CREATE
GOOD JOBS WHILE PROVIDING A
PIPELINE FOR SKILLED WORKFORCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THAT
ALLOCATION SECOND IN MY CAPACITY
AS CHAIR OF CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
ONGOING ALLOCATION FOR THE
LATINO POLICY AND POLITICS IN A
SHE TìM.
AT THE UCLA LUSKIN SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS.
LP PI FOCUSES ON CRITICAL ISSUES
THAT AFFECT THE LATINO COMMUNITY
SUCH AS HEALTH EDUCATION VOTING
RIGHTS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT AND
IMMIGRATION TO NAME JUST A FEW.
DURING ITS FIRST YEAR OF
OPERATION LPP I RELEASED OVER
DOESN'T POLICY REPORTS AND
BRIEFS WHICH GARNERED MEDIA
ATTENTION RECEIVED.
A POLICY TRACTION FROM STATE
LEGISLATORS AND CONGRESSIONAL
MEMBERS LPP AYE IS GEARING UP
FOR MULTI YEAR PROJECT ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS WHICH IS A
POLICY PRIORITY FOR OUR CAUCUS.
TO OPERATE AT FULL CAPACITY
THEY'LL PP I WILL NEED TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY IN CORE
OPERATING SUPPORT FROM THE STATE
TO MANAGE FACULTY RESEARCH
SUPPORT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS.
STRENGTH IN THE LEADERSHIP
PIPELINE AND DISSEMINATE DATA IN
POLICY IDEAS TO STAKEHOLDERS.
AT A TIME WHEN THE LATINO
POPULATION CONTINUES TO GROW IN
I. PROVIDES IS CRUCIAL TO
ENSURING THAT LAWMAKERS
UNDERSTAND THE BEST PRACTICES.
THAT AMPLIFY POLICY INNOVATION
TO ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FACED
WITHIN THE LATINO COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE STATE BUDGET ALLOCATE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION FOR LP PI
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU.
FOR GETTING IS AT TWO POINT FIVE
ON GOING -- ONCE I BELIEVE ITS
ONGOING ON GUN.
THANKS IS BETTER THAN ONE TIME.
AND ALSO HERE IN THE ATTENDED
SAYS THAT YOU AND CENTER REQUIRE
LOOKING FOR RESOURCES FOR THAT
CALIFORNIA GROWN HEALTHY KIDS
[inaudible]
FOOD PROGRAM [inaudible]
ARAMBULA I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
THIS BUT I'M SURE IT'S SOMETHING
I SUPPORT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT I LIKE IT TO GROW
HEALTHIER HEY HOW ALL THOSE
FOODS ARE GROWING UP IN YOUR TO
HELP ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE YOUR
DISPOSAL AND HOW IS IT THE
CALIFORNIA GRANT TO IT OF COURSE.
A PART OF HER HEART OF ARGUMENT
WHEN WE PASS FARMER OVER TIME IS
TO ENSURE THAT OUR CALIFORNIANS
PETITIONS ACTUALLY BY.
CALIFORNIA MADE PRODUCE YOU KNOW
WE DON'T WANNA PUT CALIFORNIA AT
A DISPROPORTIONATE DISADVANTAGES
OF COURSE WOULD RATHER LOCALLY
SOURCED OUR OUR PRODUCE VERY
GOOD EDDIE GET.
RIGHT LOCALLY GROWN PRODUCTS
LOCALLY AND AND AT PRICES THAT.
ARE YOU KNOW.
SUSTAINABLE FOR OUR FOR OUR
FARMERS YOU KNOW TO GET THOSE
AND I MEAN I'VE ALWAYS IS
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN.
WONDERING ABOUT A LOT LIKE HOW
CAN WE MAKE THAT WORK BECAUSE
CERTAINLY THERE IS A WIN WIN
THERE.
IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT A PUTS
ABSOLUTELY AND THEN FARMERSCAN
YOU KNOW FEEL GOOD ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE INVESTING IN
THEIR WORKFORCE AT THE SAME TIME
AS A BEING USED AS A RESOURCE
FOR LOCAL SCHOOL WE ALWAYS FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THAT.
IT'S TAKEN AWHILE YEAH I FEEL
ALRIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIMPLY ON THE OKAY BACK TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
SO PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE OR LESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SHARE
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO THIS
BUDGET REQUEST FOR BREAKFAST
AFTER THE BELL FUNDING.
AND WE THANK HER FOR HER
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND STUDENT
OF FOOD SECURITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF POP OUR I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF LA'S BEST AND
AFTER SCARE -- AFTER SCHOOL --
PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES THAT'S%
FACING -- ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT AN ABSENT --
THE BUDGET REQUEST BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO -- WILL
SHOULD CLOSE ITS DOORS IN SO --
THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR US --
WE THINK THE PROGRAM IS
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISE THAT
WE MADE TO CALIFORNIANS TO
PROTECT THESE KIDS AFTER SCHOOL
GIVE THEM -- HEALTHY -- SAFE
OPTIONS TO LEARNING GROW -- WE
THINK THE INVESTMENT HERE WILL
BRING ARE ARE A WHY TO THE STATE
SYSTEM AND OTHER.
OUT LONG TERM COSTS TO THE STATE
SO WE THINK IT'S A SMART PLACE --
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT
FUNDING WE APPRECIATE ANY AND
ALL SUPPORT YOU CAN GIVE THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU [inaudible]
NO.
HELLO I'M DR BETH CHAPMAN WITH
HUMBLE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION I REPRESENT TWENTY ONE
ACES PROGRAMS AND ELEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AND TO TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
COMMUNITY LEARNING CENTER GRANTS
AND ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT IS THE
MOST RECENT TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
GRANT WE'VE GOTTEN IN TWENTY
YEARS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT STAGNANT FUNDING HAS AT A
HORRIBLE IMPACT ON OUR RURAL
SCHOOLS WE CAN'T FIND STAFF.
WHO CAN AFFORD TO WORK IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN THE COMMUNITIES
THEY WANT?
THE JOBS IN.
WITH GAS COSTING OVER FOUR
DOLLARS A GALLON THESE DAYS
PEOPLE ARE FINDING THAT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO WORK ON OUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM SO WE ARE
HOPING THAT WE CAN GET THIS
INCREASE IN FUNDING -- WE HAD
ONE PERSON WHO APPLIED FOR A JOB
TOOK IT AND THEN REALIZED HER
PAYCHECK WAS NOT MADE MEETING
HER AT HER NEAT SO -- WE REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO GIVE US THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I AM STEVE KERR
VALLEY CHAIRMAN OF THE UCSF
DYSLEXIA CENTER.
I MADE A REQUEST FUNDING FOR TWO
SMALL PILOT PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
DEPLOY OUR UNIVERSAL COGNITIVE
ASSESSMENT APP WHICH IS A GAME
THAT YOU PLAN A TABLET AND IS
FREELY AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE.
WE'RE PROPOSING A PILOT THIS TO
SPEAK. TO A SMALL NUMBER OF LOW
INCOME FAMILY CLASSROOMS AND PRE
K. PROGRAMS TO IDENTIFY AND
REMEDIATE CHILDREN THAT ARE AT
RISK FOR LEARNING STRUGGLES --
WE'RE EMBARKING TODAY ON THE
GOLDEN AGE OF NEUROSCIENCE IN
OUR CALIFORNIA'S VERY OWN UCSF
IS LEADING THAT WAY WE HAVE
PIONEERED THE UNDERSTANDING OF
COGNITIVE AGING DISEASES LIKE.
ALZHEIMER'S AND DYSLEXIA AND NOW
WITH THE SAME WORLD CLASS
RESEARCHERS APPLYING THE SAME
METHODOLOGIES TO YOUNG CHILDREN
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THEIR
COGNITIVE LEARNING DIFFERENCES
AND HOW THE BRAIN DEVELOPS -- IN
YOUNG CHILD.
THIS PROMISES TO CHANGE HOW WE
THINK ABOUT EDUCATION AND THE
CRADLE TO CAREER TRAJECTORY WE
BELIEVE THAT -- YOUR ZIP CODE
SHOULD NOT TO BE A DETERMINANT
OF YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN.
SO WE RAISE MORE THAN THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THROUGH PRIVATE
DONORS IN A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP AND WE'RE PROPOSING
TO ADDRESS THE SOLVABLE PROBLEM
WHICH OTHERWISE IS FILLING THE
KINDERGARTEN. TO TO A PRISON
PIPELINE THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE NO
KID HUNGRY CAMPAIGN AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SPONSOR AND TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AND BOUGHT
THIS PRACTICE AFTER THE BELL.
PROPOSAL -- JUST A FEW POINTS
OVER HALF OF THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS -- QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
FREE AND REDUCED SCHOOL MEALS
PROGRAM YET ONLY 30% ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATE AND WE FOUND THAT
THE BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL
PROGRAM HAS ACTUALLY INCREASED
PARTICIPATION TREMENDOUSLY WITH
VARIOUS PROGRAMS OF CORPORATE ID
CORPORATE ELEMENTS OF MULTIPLE
MODELS WHICH ARE.
THAT PORK DIFFERENT THAT LOOK
DIFFERENTLY NEED SCHOOL -- WE
SAW BROUGHT EXPANSION OF THE
PRACTICE AFTER THE BILL PROGRAM
WHEN THE CD HAD FUNDING FOR
EXPANSION GRANTS IN THE PREVIOUS
FISCAL YEAR.
AND WE KNOW OF CALIFORNIA
REINSTATES THIS FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM THE RETURN OF THAT SOME
BE SIGNIFICANT TRIPS AT SCHOOL
NURSES WILL CEASE CRY CARNAGE
DROPPED ARTS STRIPS A SCHOOL
NURSES WILL.
ALSO WE STOP CHRONIC TARDINESS
DROPS AND STUDENTS MORE FOCUSED
ROUTE THE MORNING WHICH RESULT
IN IMPROVED LEARNING FOR THESE
REASONS NO GET HUNGRY IS PROUD
TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
HI THANK YOU TRACI PATTERSON
WITH CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES I'M ON HERE OBVIOUSLY
TO SPEAK ON CHILD HUNGER BUT
ALSO LIKE MS RUBIO WITH A DECADE
OF EXPERIENCE WORKING IN VERY
HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS.
AS A PARENT OF A PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENT MYSELF AND A MEMBER OF
THAT SCHOOL SITE COUNCIL SO I
WANT TO SPOT SPEAK SPECIFICALLY
TO OUR SUPPORT FOR HIS RUBIO AND
A BONTA PROPOSAL FOR BREAKFAST
AFTER THE BELL WHICH WE WORKED
ON A IN PREVIOUS YEARS THE CHAIR
MCCARTY.
A VERY EXCITED TO SEE THAT MOVE
FORWARD AGAIN THIS YEAR BECAUSE
IT IS A ONE TIME GRANTS THAT
LEAD TO SUSTAINABLE PROGRAMS
THAT BOTH DO WHAT KIDS NEED BUT
ALSO INCREASES REVENUE TO
SCHOOLS.
SO THE ONE TIME GRANT THAT
ACTUALLY LEADS TO SUSTAINABLE
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT THE STATE
DOES NOT NEED TO KEEP GIVING
THAT EXTRA BOOST -- TO AND SO I
WANTED TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME TO TALK ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL PUT FORTH BY SENATOR
REQUIRE AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ THE CALIFORNIA GROWN
FOR HEALTHY KIDS -- BECAUSE THIS
IS SPECIFICALLY STRUCTURED IN A
POLICY FORMA TO RUN EXACTLY LIKE
LCF ROUGH AND TO SUPPORT EL CAP
GOALS WITH CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE SO IT'S A NON
COMPETITIVE GRANT STRUCTURE
WHICH IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR
RURAL SCHOOLS -- I SPEND
SOMETIME THIS SUMMER AND RED
BLUFF WITH FOLKS AT THE CSU
CHICO HEALTHY COMMUNITY CENTER
AND WHAT RURAL SCHOOLS NEED ARE
NON COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO
ACTUALLY APPLY FOR A GRANT WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE THE STAFFING TO
OFTEN COVER THE BASICS CAN BE
REALLY DIFFICULT.
AND SO THIS SAYS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT RE HIGH POVERTY
THAT OFFER UNIVERSALLY FREE
BREAKFAST YOU WILL GET TEN CENTS
EXTRA PER BREAKFAST FOR
CALIFORNIA GROWN FRESH FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES WHICH IS WHAT
KIDS WANT THAT'S WHAT FAMILIES
WANT.
IS WHAT GETS EATEN -- AND SO
THROUGH THAT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE RESEARCH SUPPORTS THAT
UNIVERSALLY FOR BREAKFAST AND
BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL.
THERE'S A HUNDRED REVIEWED
ARTICLES HERE ABOUT IT REDUCING
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM REDUCING
TARDINESS SUPPORTING ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WANT SCHOOLS TO BE DOING
TO ME THEY'RE ALL CAPITALS.
THIS SUPPORTS SO WE REALLY URGE
YOU TO LOOK AT THIS CHILD
NUTRITION PROPOSAL NOT JUST AS A
WAY TO FEED KIDS THE BEST FRESH
FOOD WE GROW HERE IN THE STATE.
BUT ALSO A TO SUPPORT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PAYMENT AND REDUCE
ACADEMIC DISPARITIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU.
I'M KITTY DIXON -- STAFF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BETTER TOGETHER
TEACHER INITIATIVE.
AND PREVIOUS TEACHER AND
ADMINISTRATOR.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FOR IT TEN MILLION.
BUDGET APPROPRIATION TO FIND THE
BETTER TOGETHER TEACHERS NET
INITIATIVE OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS.
BETTER TOGETHER IT'S A UNIQUE
YOUR LONG PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT NETWORK WHOSE GOAL
IS TO CONNECT ALL TEACHERS PRE
K. TO TWELVE REGULAR ED IN
SPECIAL ED.
AS WELL AS EXPIRY TEACHERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE BEGAN FOUR YEARS AGO.
AND CURRENTLY HAVE OVER THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND TEACHERS IN OUR
NETWORK.
THE NETWORK IS IN PERSON OR
ONLINE FEELS THE NEED TEACHERS
MUST ASK FOR TO LEARN FROM AND
WITH THEIR PEERS WHAT WORKS IN
CLASSROOM SIMILAR IS MINE WITH
KIDS SIMILAR TO MINE.
AND THEY'RE LEARNING THIS AND
CONNECTED WITH TEACHERS ACROSS
THE STATE TO KNOW THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY TEACHERS ALSO KNOW
THAT MOST PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES COMING GO.
WITH OUR INITIAL SEED FINANCE
SET TO RUN OUT THIS SUMMER A
BUDGET APPROPRIATION WOULD
ENSURE THAT THE BETTER TOGETHER
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS INITIATIVE
WOULD BE SUSTAIN AN EXPANDED.
AND HOW'S THAT AS THE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AS
THE ELLIE A WE KNOW TEACHERS ARE
LEAVING FASTER YOU TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THAT TODAY ABOUT
RECRUITING NEW TEACHERS IN THE
SHORTAGE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT ONE OF THOSE
SHORTAGES IS CAUSED BY THE
NUMBERS.
THAT 50% OF TEACHERS LEAVE AFTER
THE FIRST FIVE YEARS OF TEACHING.
THE BETTER TOGETHER TEACHER
INITIATIVE HELPS TO ELEVATE
THEIR VOICE GAUGES THEM AND
LEARN AND LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES ONGOING
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND
ACTUALLY INSPIRES THEM AND NEW
TEACHERS TO COME ON BOARD.
AS ONE TEACHER SAID [inaudible]
THE BETTER TOGETHER TEACHER
INITIATIVE WAS NOT ONLY
INVALUABLE TO ME AS A NEW
TEACHER INSPIRING TEACHER.
BUT A COUPLE YEARS INTO IT BEGAN
TO HELP ME IMPROVE WHAT MY
TEACHING LOOK LIKE YOU'RE THREE
AND FOUR AND GAVE ME CONTINUE TO
GIVE ME A FRESH PERSPECTIVE ON
TEACHING. FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR
TO JOIN US IN SUPPORTING SUSTAIN
FUNDING.
FOR BETTER TOGETHER.
ON A SIDE NOTE THINKING OF THE
FIRES OF THE RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND ARE READY LOCATION LAST YEAR
AT OUR AT OUR SITE WIDE EVENT
WHERE THIRTY DIFFERENT --
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
HOUSING HOSE THAT CONNECTED
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY.
IT WAS IN REDDING WITH THE FIRE
IS COMING IN THAT THEY'RE ON THE
PHONE WITH US ALL NIGHT SAY THE
FIRES ARE GETTING CLOSE TO THE
FIRES ARE GETTING CLOSER.
BUT TEACHERS HAVE ALREADY COME
IN AND DRIVEN FROM THE RURAL
AREAS TO PARTICIPATE.
SO I ENDED UP TURNING IT.
INTO A SHELTER THINK ABOUT THAT
RAPID.
THANK YOU THANKS OKAY AGAIN
REMINDER THAT'S ONE MINUTE.
I KNOW THAT MR GALLAGHER THAT
YOU HAD TO GET GOING AND YOU
WANTED. TO TO DO YOUR YOUR
BUDGET REQUEST NOW QUICK YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- SO
BOTH ASSEMBLYMAN -- SOME MEMBER
DOLLY AND MYSELF -- DO YOU HAVE
A REQUEST TO PROVIDEA THREE
YEAR EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS IN
AN ADDITIONAL THREE YEAR EIGHTY
A RAMP DOWN. FOR THE DISTRICTS
IMPACTED BY THE CAMPFIRE --
CERTAINLY AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
DISRUPTION -- THAT THESE SCHOOLS
HAVE GONE THROUGH -- SEVERAL OF
THEM HAVE LOST THEIR THEIR
BUILDINGS COMPLETELY --
THANKFULLY SOME OF THE SCHOOLS
ACTUALLY THERE THE HIGH SCHOOL
DID NOT BURN DOWN -- BUT YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF GETTING THE THE
SCHOOLS BACK ON TRACK THEY'RE
GONNA NEED THAT STABLE FUNDING.
A SOURCE AND SO WE'RE JUST
REQUESTING THAT.
TO THAT HOLD HARMLESS AND THE
AND THE EIGHTY RAMP DOWN --
DOLLARS TO HELP SUPPORT THOSE
DISTRICT OKAY TO THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO THIS IS NOT A MONEY
REQUEST BUT AT LANGUAGE ISSUE
AND AND A STATUTORY CHANGE.
OKAY.
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED -- KATHY
SURE -- WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TODAY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE WORKING ON GETTING ADEQUATE --
RESOURCES ALLOCATED TO SUPPORT
THE MENTAL WELLNESS OF
CALIFORNIA'S K. THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENTS -- AND SCHOOL CLIMATE --
WE HAVE SUBMITTED IN WRITING --
BUDGET REQUEST FOR A C. D. E.
ADMINISTERED GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS COUNSELLORS.
PSYCHOLOGISTS SOCIAL WORKERS AND
NURSES TO SERVE CALIFORNIA'S
MOST UNDERSERVED SCHOOLS THOSE
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE.
THE WORST STAFFING RATIOS FOR
THOSE POSITIONS CURRENTLY -- AND
TO TRAIN THOSE A NEW STAFF
MEMBERS IN RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PRACTICES.
THIS SPRING THE ACLU ISSUED ITS
REPORT ENTITLED COPS AND NO
COUNSELORS HOW THE LACK OF
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH STAFF IS
DEPARTMENT STUDENTS.
THAT REPORT ANALYZED STUDENTS
ANALYZE DATA NATIONWIDE
CALIFORNIA RANKED FIFTIETH.
IN THE NATION IN ACCESS TO
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND NOT IS NOT
DOING MUCH BETTER YEAH I'M IN
THE OTHER CATEGORIES.
STATEWIDE THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND STUDENTS
WHO ATTEND SCHOOLS THAT HAVE A
FULL TIME LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER BUT NO COUNSELOR.
FIXING THIS WILL TAKE A LONG
TERM COMMITMENT OF RESOURCES BUT
AS A FIRST STEP WE HAVE ASKED
FOR ONE TIM FUNDING THROUGH A
GRANT PROGRAM TO BE ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
TO ALLOW THOSE SCHOOLS WHO
CURRENTLY HAVE THE WORST MENTAL
HEALTH STAFFING RATIOS TO HIRE
MUCH NEEDED.
STAFF -- CLOSELY TIED TO THIS
REQUEST IS A REQUEST FOR MONEY
TO TRAIN THOSE NEW STAFF AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES.
COUNSELORS AND OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH STAFF ARE IDEALLY
SITUATED TO HELP IMPLEMENT
SCHOOL RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROGRAMS.
OUR HOPE IS THAT BY PROVIDING
SCHOOLS PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
SCHOOLS MOST IN NEED THE PROGRAM
WILL DEMONSTRATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS AND USING
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES IN
IMPROVING SCHOOL CLIMATE.
CREATING A BETTER LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS
THIS CAN THEN SERVE AS AN
EXAMPLE TO SCHOOL CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS DISTRICTS AS THEY CAN'T
MAKE THE CITY.
DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE AS TO
HOW TO USE THEIR RESOURCES WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
PROPOSAL QUE THANK YOU.
I'M HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE SAME FIX SCHOOL DISCIPLINE
COALITION -- BUDGET PROPOSAL I'M
STILL THE LEVY I AM THE WITH THE
RESTORATIVE SCHOOLS VISION
PROJECT.
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TO AND SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE BASED ON
PUNISHMENT AND INSTEAD -- SHIFT
THE PARADIGM.
OF SCHOOL DISCIPLINE TO
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
DISCIPLINE WITHOUT PUNISHMENT SO
A LOT WHAT I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
SPECIFICALLY IS THERE RECALL THE
PART OF THE BUDGET REQUESTS THAT
GOES TO THE TRAINING OF THE
SCHOOL STAFF SUPPORT -- MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT WHICH IS A CRISIS
RIGHT NOW AMONG STARS SCHOOL
CHILDREN -- OF FOR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE TRAINING AND SINCE I
KNOW THE CHAIR PERSON REALLY
LOVE STORIES I'M GOING -- TO
DISPENSE WITH MY LITTLE NOTES
HERE AND JUST TELL A QUICK STORY
OF THE SITUATION WHEN WE WERE IN.
WE WERE -- WORKING WITH THE
SCHOOL AND THIS WAS A SITUATION
IN WHICH A CHILD WAS BEING WHO
WAS OFTEN IN TROUBLE BY THE WAY
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN BOY OFTEN IN
TROUBLE -- WAS ACTING UP IN
CLASS VERY DISRESPECTFUL TO HIS
TEACHER AND FINALLY THREE
SOMETHING AND HIS TEACHER
BECAUSE THERE WAS RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PRESENCE THERE HE WAS
SENT TO TALK TO ME.
AND THIS I HOPE WILL ILLUSTRATE
THE REASON I'M TELLING IT IS
BECAUSE I THINK IT ILLUSTRATES.
THE DEEP CONNECTION BETWEEN
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT WHICH IS THAT --
WIN WHEN DOING A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE INTERVENTION ASKED THE
QUESTION WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
YOU AND HERE'S WHAT THE CHILD
HAD TO SAY.
AND IT REALLY CHANGE THE VIEW
POINT OF OF HIS WAY HIS
MISBEHAVIOR FOR TOWARDS THIS
TEACHER WHICH WAS THAT HIS
FATHER WAS IN PRISON AS MANY
STUDENTS.
OUR HAD GOTTEN OUT OF PRISON HAD
COME OVER THE NIGHT BEFORE.
AND BEAT UP HIS MOTHER HE SAID
HE TRIED VERY HARD TO GET HIS
FATHER TO STOP BEATING HIS
MOTHER.
AND THAT WHEN HE CAME TO SCHOOL
BEFORE HE CAME TO SCHOOL THAT
DAY HE SAW BLOOD ON THE WALL AND
HE SAID I DON'T LIKE TO SEE THAT
SO I GOT ME A SPONGE AND I
CLEANED OFF THE WALL.
IN THE TOURNEY BUT AFTER HE TOLD
THAT STORY HIS BEHAVIOR DIDN'T
SEEM LIKE.
QUITE WHAT IT HAD SEEN BEFORE WE
FOUND OUT WHAT THE CAUSE WAS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD -- ACCOUNT GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE FOOT HELD THE
ANSWER KERN AND YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSAL FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
PARTNERSHIP PILOT PROGRAM THIS
ACTUALLY COMES OUT OF A HEARING
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HELD JOINTLY
WITH ASSEMBLYMAN MEDINA AS
HIGHER RIGHT COMMITTEE AND THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE -- THAT
WOULD HELP IMPROVE THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PIPELINE -- IN
EDUCATIONAL DESERT'S BUT IN
PARTICULAR -- WHERE THERE ARE AN
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF
SUBSTANTIAL CREDENTIALS WE WOULD
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RYAN MICHAEL HANEY AND WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LIKE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME REQUEST TO HELP FUND
THIS -- PILOT PROGRAM SO --
PLEASE FUNDED THANK YOU AGAIN.
OKAY GREAT TESTIMONY RIGHT
[inaudible]
SO.
HARD TO FOLLOW THAT -- MY NAME
IS ANU COMMUNITIES WITH EARLY
EDGE CALIFORNIA -- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISES
BUDGET ASK OF A HUNDRED FOURTEEN
MILLION TO SUPPORT BINDING WHEN
BY LITERACY PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
I DO ALL LANGUAGE LEARNERS
COMPRISE NEARLY 60% OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF FIVE AND NEARLY 60% OF
THOSE CHILDREN COME FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES -- WE WOULD LIKE
TO THINK THE LEGISLATURE FOR ITS
BOLD INVESTMENT OF FIVE MILLION
LAST YEAR TO FIND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS THAT
SERVED TO ALL LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
THIS INVESTMENT IS BEING NOTED
IN EARLY EDUCATION SPACES ACROSS
THE NATION LAST YEAR'S FUNDING
IS FULLY EXHAUSTED BUT THE NEED
TO SUPPORT THESE CHILDREN
CONTINUES TO EXIST.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
OUR DUAL LANGUAGE AND ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AT ALL AGES
AND SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAISES REQUEST.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA ASK YOU OUT
TIME OUT REAL QUICK SO MEMBER
MEDINA -- WOULD LIKE TO MAKE HIS
BUDGET REQUEST AND DO WELL FIRST
OF ALL AS THROUGH THE ADD ON TO
THE TO THE BUDGET ITEMS.
ISSUE TWO AT THE CITY SEE
OVERALL BUDGET MEDINA.
ISSUE THREE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STATE OPERATIONS
MEDINA.
OKAY THANK YOU.
I I WILL TRY TO BE VERY BRIEF I
HAVE A BILL ASSEMBLY BILL --
THREE THIRTY ONE TO MAKE --
ETHNIC STUDIES A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MANY DISTRICTS ARE
DOING THIS ALREADY -- I I THINK
THE TESTIMONY AND STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THE VALUE OF IT --
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
HAS PUT A COST ESTIMATE ON DOING
IT STATEWIDE.
AT A HEFTY.
FOUR HUNDRED IN DOLLARS THEY'VE
GIVEN ME A BREAK DOWN
[inaudible]
OF THAT -- OF YEAH IT'S A BIG
PRICE TAG AND AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK -- TO SEE WHAT
YOU KNOW.
PERHAPS -- WHAT ELSE WE CAN DO?
PERHAPS -- A LITTLE BIT LESS BUT
I THINK IT'S A VERY.
WORTHWHILE INVESTMENT AND AND I
WOULD ASK THE THIS COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THAT.
YES THANK YOU I I AM FULL
SUPPORTER THAT.
TEN CAN HELP TO THINK THIS
WEEKEND WHEN THEY DROPPED THE
**** FLYERS.
OVER WITH A DRONE OVER AT THE
GUY WAS BRIDGET SACKS STATE.
THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED MORE --
UNDERSTANDING AND AND AND
COMMUNICATION AS FAR AS
DIFFERENT CULTURES IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM FROM.
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
TO MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL
TO COLLEGE SO THANK YOU.
THE OKAY [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING OR AFTERNOON
WHATEVER IT IS RIGHT NOW.
MY NAME IS CHERYL ORTEGA AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF BILINGUAL
EDUCATION FOR UNITED TEACHERS
LOS ANGELES.
ARE WE ARE URGING FUNDING FOR
MULTI EDUCATE MULTI LINGUAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND THEIR
TEACHERS.
ASIDE FROM THE GENERAL TEACHER
SHORTAGE STATEWIDE THERE'S A
CRITICAL BILINGUAL TEACHER
SHORTAGE.
IN LAUSD THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
TEACHERS WHOSE IRST LANGUAGES
OTHER THAN ENGLISH WOULD DO NOT
HOLD BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATIONS TO
TEACH ANY OF THE LANGUAGES THAT
ARE OFFERED TO OUR CHILDREN.
WHO SPEAK SPANISH KOREAN
MANDARIN ARMENIAN AND ARABIC?
WE DESPERATELY NEED FUNDING THAT
WOULD HELP THESE CAPABLE WILLING
TEACHERS. TO GET THOSE
AUTHORIZATIONS AND BE
COMPENSATED IN THEIR WORK SO
THAT THEY CAN BE PART OF THE
MOVEMENT TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
THAT THEY DESERVE IN LANGUAGES
THAT ARE COMPREHENSIBLE TO THEM.
SECONDLY THE NEED FOR FUNDING
FOR DUAL LANGUAGE PROGRAMS IN
EARLY EDUCATION IS CRITICAL.
AT A CHILD'S FIRST ENTRY INTO
SCHOOL THE NEED FOR
COMPREHENSIBLE ACCESS TO
INSTRUCTION IS CRITICAL.
NOT TO MENTION THE AFFIRMATION
OF HOME LANGUAGES AND CULTURES.
IN LA U. S. T. ONLY TEN
PRESCHOOLS WITH A PLAN FOR TEN
MORE OFFER DUAL LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS THAT'S OUT OF THE
ELEVEN HUNDRED SCHOOLS THAT
EXIST IN THE DISTRICT.
WE NEED THE FUNDING TO MOVE
FORWARD AT A SIGNIFICANTLY
FASTER PACE THAN IS CURRENTLY
THE CASE.
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GOOD [inaudible]
GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARC THIS YEAR
AGO SIDIOUS AND I'M REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER.
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SOMEONE
WOMAN RACES A REQUEST FOR A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR FUNDING OF ADDITIONAL DOOR
LANGUAGE IMMERSION PROGRAMS FOR
BILINGUAL PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS FOR
BILINGUAL.
TEACHER PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS OF THE TWO PROGRAMS --
THE DEMAND FOR TWO OF THESE
PROGRAMS FAR EXCEEDED THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
I SAW FUNDING WOULD ALLOW ONLY
ACE TO CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE
VISION OF PROPOSITION FIFTY
EIGHT APPROVED IN NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WHICH WOULD.
OF PROPOSED THAT ALL STUDENTS
BECOME BY LITERATE AND MULTI
LINGUAL IN ORDER TO COMPETE AND
OUR ECONOMY OF THE GLOBAL
SOCIETY.
MY NEXT COMMENT IS IT IS NOT A
BUDGET REQUEST.
IT IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION AND IT READ IT IS IN
REGARDS TO THE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM AND THAT IS THAT PLEASE
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
TYPES OF DATA SHOULD BE INCLUDED
AND WHO SHOULD BE PART OF THE
WORK GROUPS ARE MENTIONED.
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT
INFORMATION REGARDING THE ARTS I
ESPECIALLY MUSIC ALL IS
REPRESENTED IN -- WHATEVER
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED BY THE
DATA SYSTEM CURRENT RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT DISPARITY AS TO
WHICH STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
ARTS AND MUSIC PROGRAMS.
AND THEY ARE USUALLY STUDENTS IN
SCHOOLS THAT ARE IN OUR LOW
ECONOMIC -- COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU.
BECAUSE OF AN ENEMY DOES NOT TO
KNOW WHAT CHILDREN NOW I'M HERE
TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
AND ALLOCATION OF TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDS. TO BE USED TO
DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND AT THE REGIONAL
LEVEL TO HELP BUILD THE CAPACITY
OF ENGLISH -- OF EDUCATORS TO
SUPPORT OUR ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS -- THIS APPROACH MAYOR
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN DONE IN
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS WITH THE
COMMUTER THE PET PRACTICES THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION --
SUPPORTING EDUCATORS AND I THINK
NOW IS THE TIME FOR THE STATE TO
INVEST IN THIS ONE TIME FUNDING
AND THERE'S A GREAT DEMAND.
ON THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
RECEIVED -- A LETTER WITH OVER
TWO HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
MEMBERS OF THE CHILDREN'S
MOVEMENT SUPPORTING -- THIS
BUDGET REQUEST IN HERE WITH ME
IS THAT.
AVOIDS COPYING CALIFORNIA'S
TOGETHER ARE CO SPONSORS OF THE
BILL AND THIS WOULD REALLY ALLOW
THE INITIATIVE WOULD REALLY
ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL ELLIE ETS
TO RECEIVE.
UNDERSTANDING AND TRAINING
AROUND THE ENGLISH LEARN A ROAD
MAP THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JAMIE
MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
SUPPORTING THE PROPOSAL BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. FOR THE
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THE
PRACTICE AFTER THE BELL PROGRAM
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ IS HAND
MAGUIRE'S PROPOSAL.
AROUND THE CALIFORNIA GROWN
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
MORNING CATHY MOSSBERG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOOD
BANKS WANT TO BE ON RECORD IN
SUPPORTING BOTH THE THREE
MILLION FOR THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL AS
WELL AS THE FIFTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
GROUND.
BOTH OF THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT
HELP LOW INCOME STUDENTS -- HELP
THEIR PARENTS STRETCH THEIR
NUTRITION THEIR FOOD DOLLARS --
AND SO WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF BOTH
OF THOSE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES TO JUMP IN
HERE REAL QUICK.
TO SHARE **** SHARE HER BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
OR SHALL I SAY PROPOSALS.
JUST ONE DAY HER NAME A FEW
TIMES TODAY LET'S AND AND FOR
YOUR NAME A FEW TIMES THIS MORE
THAN ONE PROPOSAL.
THE GOOD THING WELL LET ME JUST
GIVE MY PROPOSAL ON BILINGUALISM
FOR ALL.
WELL WE KNOW THAT PROP FIFTY IT
WAS PASSED BY THE VOTERS IN
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION FOR
GLOBAL ECONOMY INITIATIVE.
AND THE VOTERS SAID WE WANT OUR
STUDENTS TO LEARN MORE THAN ONE
LANGUAGE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT
YOUR YOUR HONOR OF MISTER CHAIR.
WE WANT TO PROMOTE PROVIDE AND
SUPPORT OPPORTUNITIES WE WANT --
TO TO PROMOTE -- AND PROVIDES
SUPPORT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS SO THEY CAN LEARN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES.
I THINK THAT BY THIS THE EIGHTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
EXPANSION.
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IT WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE FOR FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A STRONG
BILINGUAL EDUCATION PIPELINE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS FROM THE MOMENT
THEY ENTER EDUCATION SYSTEM SO
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS -- WILL
PROVIDE THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROVIDER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
THE TOTAL REQUEST MEANS THE
STATE WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
EDUCATORS AND CAMPUSES WHO WISH
TO ENHANCE THE BILINGUAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
LEADING TO A WIDESPREAD PROGRAM
EXPANSION AND ULTIMATELY AN
IMPLEMENTATION OF WHAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ANNOUNCED THE
STATE TO DO UNDER PROPOSITION.
FIFTY EIGHT SIR RESPECTFULLY ASK
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BUDGET
REQUEST TO SO THAT WE CAN DO
WITH THE VOTERS ASKED US TO DO.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK WE ALSO
HEARD ABOUT THE EASY E. SLOTS
THE CHILD CARE SLOTS THAT YOU'RE
ASKING ABOUT FROM ONE OF THE
OTHER WITNESSES SELL WHAT'S ON
OUR LIST.
TOO THEN IF I MAY UM.
THE BILLIONS FOR BABIES.
THAT'S AB ONE NINETY FOUR SO
THAT WE CAN EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
SLOTS AVAILABLE -- FOR CHILD
CARE WE KNOW THE CHILD CARE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTAN SPECIALLY
FOR WE BUT FOR OUR FAMILIES.
EIGHT OUT OF TEN CHILDREN WHO
QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
ARE NOT ABLE TO GET THEM BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE SLOTS.
OF THE SPEAKERS BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION OF REPORT TALKS ABOUT
THIS GREAT NEED IN TALKS ABOUT
THE THE FACT THAT WE NEED.
TO INVEST IN THIS AND WE'RE
HOPING THAT YOU AS A JOINT
AUTHORED THAT VERY BILL.
WILL HELP US TO GET THE FUNDING.
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT.
THE CHILD CARE FOR ALL OF OUR
ALL OF OUR CHILDREN OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE'RE GOING -- TO
LIFT THE CALL ON A FEW OF THESE --
BUDGET.
ACTION ITEMS MR O'DONNELL ISSUE
THREE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SEPARATIONS O'DONNELL I OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
JOINING US WANTS TO SHARE HER
PERSPECTIVE ON A BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WOULD SAY MEMBERS BUT THEY'RE
ALL GONE SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT HAPPENED
YOU'VE HAD A LONG MEETING TODAY.
I JUST WANTED TO COME AND REMIND --
A YOU AND OTHERS THAT YOU KNOW A
YEAR AGO AS YOU FULLY WHERE --
WE WERE GIVEN THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF UNDERPERFORMING
STUDENTS IN OUR IN OUR DISTRICTS
AS A PART OF THE LC A PFAFF THE
FACT THAT -- ILL CFF IS
PARTICULARLY THESE THE SPECIAL
GRANTS WERE DESIGNED TO SUPPOSED
TO CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND WE DISCOVERED IN OUR OWN
RESEARCH THAT WE'VE DOING WELL
WITH CERTAIN CATEGORIES BUT
THERE'S STILL AS PERSISTENTLY
LOW GROUP AT THE BOTTOM.
SO I SIMPLY WANTED TO REMIND YOU
OF THAT FACT WE WERE TRYING TO
DO SOME THINGS THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN THIS YEAR -- AND SO IT
WILL ALSO WAITING FOR AN AUDIT
ON THE FUNDING ITSELF AND
FINDING OUT WHERE THE MONEY IS
GOING AND HOW IT'S BEING USED
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON WE JUST
WANT TO REMIND YOU OF THAT WE'VE
TALKED WITH THE USE OF THOSE IN
THE BUDGET OFFICE.
AND HAVE SAID OKAY THAT TOOK IS
DIFFICULT IT WAS DIFFICULT TO
GET STARTED THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF
HAVING TO SET THE STANDARDS.
GIVING IT ORGANIZED GETTING
PEOPLE TO APPLY SO FORTH AND SO
ON SO WE DIDN'T HAVE A FULL YEAR
FOR THAT WHAT I HAVE REQUESTED
IS THAT WE CAP IT OFF AGAIN A
THREE HUNDRED MILLION AS WE HAD
BEFORE BECAUSE THIS IS LIKE
FINALLY A STARTING. FOR THE
PROCESS IT MAY NOT TAKE A WHOLE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION BECAUSE
IT'S ALREADY THERE WE MAY HAVE
USED I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH WE
VIEWS THIS YEAR I'VE ASKED.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH WAS USED
OUT OF THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
AND RELEASED SO THAT WE CAN.
BASICALLY GIVE IT A RESTART AT
THE AT THE FALL SO I TALK WITH
THEM.
SOME OF THE CONSULTANTS OF THE
BUDGET ABOUT THIS AND I THINK
IT'S A REASONABLE REQUEST TO
BASICALLY SAID IT BACK AT THREE
HUNDRED SAYS NOW THAT WE HAVE
THE STANDARDS IN A PROCESS IN
PLACE.
AND PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO APPLY
FOR THE GRANTS AND THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS AND SO WOULD GIVES US
A THREE YEAR.
KIND OF PERIOD AGAIN TO
BASICALLY LOOK AT THOSE SCHOOLS
AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A A
FULL TIME FRAME FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE I THINK AS WE
GET WHEN WE GET THE AUDIT BACK
WE'LL SEE HOW ELSE EFF IS
WORKING WHETHER THAT IT NEEDS
MAJOR CHANGE IN MODIFICATION AND
PROBABLY DOES.
BUT IN THE INTRODUCED ILL HAVE
THESE LOW PERFORMING KIDS WE
NEED TO ADDRESS.
OKAY SO IS IS THE REQUESTED A
THREE HUNDRED MILLION TO BE
SPENT OVER THREE YEARS.
RIGHT NOW IT IS THAT'S A REQUEST
I UNDERSTAND THAT WAS THE
UNDERSTANDING WE GOT CONFUSES
SOME THE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
GOVERNOR THOUGHT IT WAS THREE
HUNDRED MILLION PER YEAR.
WE WERE TOLD US THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THREE YEARS YEAH --
AND SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO SO I
JUST MAKE SURE AND AND THEY'VE
SPENT SOME OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE
SOME GROUP STATE SOME.
OF MID YEAR ALLOCATION
REQUESTING IS THAT THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION BE BASICALLY
CAPPED AGAIN AT THAT NUMBER WAS
PUT BACK IN WHAT WAS TAKEN OUT.
SO IF SO IF -- IF WE SPENT FIFTY
MILLION AND IT'S REALLY JUST
OKAY PUTTING IT BACK AT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE NEXT
YEAR YEAH SO THAT WAY WE CAN
BEGIN TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS PROCESS OF THE LOW
PERFORMING KIDS.
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE NEED TO
MAYBE EVEN INCORPORATE THAT INTO
THE OVERALL ILL CFF ONCE WE SEE
WHAT ELSE EFF IS ACTUALLY DOING.
OKAY YEAH THAT MAKES SENSE AND
NO GUARANTEES BUT THAT WHAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING IS MUCH MORE
VIABLE IN THIS BUDGET RIGHT
THAT'S WHAT I FIGURED WOULD BE
AND THAT'S WHAT I ASKED FOR
RATHER THAN.
SOMETHING ELSE I TALK WITH OF
THE OVERALL BUDGET FOLKS IN A
COUPLE OF THE PEOPLE THEY SAID
THAT WAS PROBABLY MORE
REASONABLE GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE HAD A SLOW START THIS COMING
YEAR WE HAVING TO SET THE
STANDARDS FIND A TO THE KIDS
WORK.
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE WERE USING AS
CRITERIA TO DETERMINE THE LOW
PERFORMING KIDS AND THAT TOOK
ABOUT A SEMESTER AND SO
THEREFORE AND SO THIS WILL GIVE
US THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
THAT WE HAD ALREADY WITH
WHATEVER WAS SPENT.
AT BACK IN OKAY OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
OKAY.
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARCHER MCCARTY
AND STAFF MY NAME IS RACHEL
MASSARO FROM PUBLIC ADVOCATES MY
COMMENTS TODAY ARE ON BEHALF OF
THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST AT
VOICE TEACH PLUS.
CHILDREN NOW IN PUBLIC ADVOCATES
WORK WERE ASKING THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER TO FULL TIME STAFF
OF THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. TO AUTHORS AND
PUBLISHERS NEWLY AVAILABLE DATA
PURSUANT TO AN AMMO YOU IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET TO IDENTIFY BRIGHT
SPOTS AND AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT
IN TEACHER PREPARATION
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION.
THE CDC IS A PERFORMED A SAMPLE
ANALYSIS OF THIS DATA BUT
CURRENTLY LACKS THE CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE THIS DATA AT THE AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL FOR
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT.
JUST LAST YEAR CDC'S EMPLOYMENT
DATA AND UP UNTIL LAST YEAR AND
SEE AND CD IS IMPLEMENTED AND
SEE TC'S CREDENTIALING DATA WERE
SILENT.
LEAVING THE STATE AND LOCALS
UNABLE TO ANSWER BASIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT TEACHER EMPLOYMENT AND
RETENTION AND UNDERSTAND HOW
THESE RATES VERY BY TWO BY
PREPARATION PROGRAM TEACHER
DEMOGRAPHICS TYPE OF
AUTHORIZATION AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY I NEED STUDENTS
ACCESS TO A PREPARED AND STABLE
WORK FORCE.
THESE QUESTIONS ARE ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL IN TIMES OF TEACHER
SHORTAGE WHEN SUB STANDARD
CREDENTIALS ARE ON THE RISE.
THE EMPLOYMENT CREDENTIAL DATA
WAS LINKED AT LINKED IN THE AMMO
YOU WAS I'M DONE PURSUANT TO
MEET S. IS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BUT SHOULDN'T BE
LIMITED TO THIS PURPOSE.
STATE AND ONLY A SEE THIS NEWLY
AVAILABLE DATA -- TO CLOSE
CRITICAL EQUITY GAPS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
JIM MCCARTY THANK YOU ALL FOR
HAVING US THIS AFTERNOON IN THE
AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS A RE READ AND I
SERVICE THE STATE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE BUDGET REQUEST IN
THE ASSEMBLY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL OF ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CAST IS A STUDENT RUN NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN TO PROMOTE STUDENT
VOICE AND INVOLVEMENT ACROSS THE
STATE IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
SO I CONFERENCES THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR STUDENTS PRESENTED
PROPOSALS TO THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND STATE SENATE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES AND
EDUCATION ON ISSUES LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
CAREER TECHNICAL TRAINING
WHATEVER THEY FIND IMPORTANT IN
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AND AS ONE OF THE ONLY STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT -- OFFERS A
DIRECT PLATFORM TO LEGISLATORS
AN OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT
CAPACITIES IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT THESE VISIONS FOR
AN IDEAL EDUCATION SYSTEM
ACCURATELY REPRESENT.
THE SIX POINT THREE MILLION
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WITHOUT STATE FUNDING THE
PRICE OF THESE CONFERENCES
DETERS TOO MANY STUDENTS FROM
ATTENDING AND I DON'T THINK THAT
FINANCE SHOULD BE DETERMINING
THE FACT FACTORED IN A MATTER OF
A STUDENT'S VOICE.
WELL WE ONLY ASK FOR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THESE
FUNDS WILL ENSURE THAT EVERY
CONFERENCE DELEGATION CONSISTS
OF AT LEAST 17% OF STUDENTS WHO
QUALIFY FOR FREE OR REDUCED
LUNCH.
APPROVAL OF THIS BUDGET REQUEST
WOULD INJURE EQUAL ACCESS TO
STUDENTS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE DID THAT THE BUDGET TWO YEARS
AGO SO WE TRIED.
BUT THEIR BOOKS DOWNSTAIRS
WORKING SO YOU CAN.
THE KNOCK ON THEIR DOOR.
MY NAME IS AYE ALLEGE MEN I AM
ALSO FOR CASK -- I'M THE
SECRETARY THIS YEAR AS WELL AS A
JUNIOR AT CREEK HIGH SCHOOL IN
CINEMA COUNTY.
OVER THE PAST YEAR I HAVE HOSTED
A REGIONAL CONFERENCE LEAD
LEADERSHIP WORKSHOPS ACROSS THE
STATE AND PROPOSED WHAT IS NOW
AB FIVE FOUR THREE IT TO THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY MADDIE'S
COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION.
NONE OF THIS WOULD'VE BEEN
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE FINANCIAL
AID THAT CAST GAVE ME.
IT WASN'T UNTIL LATER THAT I
FOUND OUT HOW LIMITED CASK
SCHOLARSHIPS FUNDS ARE.
YOUR APPROVAL OF THIS BUDGET
REQUEST FOR ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD.
BRING CAST CLOSER TO ACCURATE
ACCURATELY REPRESENTING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY BRANTLEY --
I WAS A STUDENT WHO ATTENDED
CAST PROGRAMS -- BACK IN
NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND AND MY
MOM NOW -- AND I VOLUNTEER WITH
CASCADE -- HELPING TO ADVISE THE
STUDENTS ON THE PROGRAM THAT
THEY RUN.
AND IF IT WASN'T FOR SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ONES THAT I
WAS ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM IN THE
STATE FUNDING THAT WE HAD BACK
THEN.
IT'S A VERY INTERESTING
MICROPHONE -- MY I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ATTEND THE
PROGRAMS -- AFTER MY FIRST
PROGRAM I HOPE TO ADD AS A
STUDENT ONE MEMBER TWICE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD.
AND I WENT ON TO BE A TRAINER.
FOR INNOVATION AND THEM I JUST
WANTED TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR
FOR THE STUDENTS IN THE GREAT
WORK THAT THEY DO.
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE IN THE GARAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
BOARD JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS%
SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE A SAYS FUNDING -- AND
ALSO FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
IS PROPOSAL ON THE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. TO
ESTABLISH THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS TO SUPPORT
HOMELESS STUDENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR PTERON RAP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS TO ITEMS.
RELATED TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
FIRST OF ALL TEACHER MRS SIGN
MEANT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
REFLECTIVE OF AB TWELVE NINETEEN
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
TEACHER PRIVACY.
AS WELL AS PROTECTIONS FOR A
PROBATIONARY TEACHERS AND
SECONDLY WE WOULD SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING -- PROGRAM
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THAT PROGRAM AS
WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS BY MY COLLEAGUE WHICH
YOU HAVE TO YOU REGARDING AB.
TWELVE NINETEEN WE HAVE A
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION FOR
UPCOMING STATE COUNCIL MEETING
ON THAT ITEM I ALSO WANTED TO
SUPPORT WAY TO AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER IS MOVING
FORWARD IN REGARD TO PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL THREE YEAR HOLD
HARMLESS LANGUAGE.
AND SUPPORT FOR THOSE THAT WERE
IMPACTED BY IT THAT CAMPFIRE WE
REPRESENT PARADISE EDUCATORS AND
OUR EDUCATORS HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED AND
HAVING THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
NOT ONLY IS GOING TO BE.
A FISCAL INCENTIVE TO HELP OUR
TEACHERS AND STAFF TO REMAIN IT
ALSO SIGNIFIES MORAL SUPPORT
WHICH RIGHT NOW IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ITEMS THAT ARE
MEMBERS IN THOSE IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES NEEDS TO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THAT.
IN ADDITIONALLY -- WE SUPPORT AT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
UPDATE FOR THE MODEL SCHOOL
LIBRARY STANDARDS WHICH SETS A
VISION FOR STRONG.
SCHOOL LIBRARY STANDARDS THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DANIEL PAN
WITH MOUNT PLEASANT ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE IMPASSE
PROGRAM FIRST OFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMMING -- I'M HERE
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE ASUS
FUNDING.
WE DO -- CONSISTENT EVENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
WEBER SUPPORT -- WAY WOULD
SUPPORT THE SCHOOL DAY WITH
THEIR EDUCATIONAL ACTIVITIES BUT
OUR STAFF FOR HEROES AND OUR
STUDENTS ARE INCREDIBLE.
BUT WE'RE NOT ABLE TO KEEP THEM
AROUND AND BE CONSISTENT SO IN
ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE NEED
CONSISTENT STAFF MEMBERS AND WE
NEED THIS INCREASED TO HAPPEN.
SO PLEASE -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE IT.
MY NAME IS REMUS RUN ON I'M WITH
THE HAYWARD UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I'M HERE -- TO URGE
YOU TO PLEASE LOOK AT INCREASING
THAT ASUS TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS WE HAVE A VERY HIGH
POPULATION OF SO OF LOW SOCIAL
ECONOMIC STATUS AND OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM SERVES OVER
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
AND OUR DISTRICT.
AND WE COLLABORATIVELY WORK WITH
PARTNERS AS WELL AS TEACHERS TO
SUPPORT OUR TO TO OUR STUDENTS
FOR ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
AND DUE TO US BEING ABLE TO
COLLABORATE TOGETHER WE'RE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN OUR
GRADUATION RATES OF OUR STUDENTS
AND WE JUST WANT YOU TO HELP US
CONTINUE THE EFFORT THAT WE HAVE
IN OUR WHO WERE COMMUNITY WITH
OUR STUDENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M BRIAN RIVAS
ON BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WEST URGING YOUR SUPPORT FOR TWO
ITEMS THE FIRST IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR A
LONGITUDINAL STUDENT DATA SYSTEM.
WE THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS YOU CAN DO THIS
YEAR'S ENACT THIS SYSTEM -- FOR
EQUITY AND FUNDAMENTAL IT'S
ABOUT SEEING THE TRUTH AND SEEN
WHAT HAPPENS TO STUDENTS WHEN
THEY MOVED THROUGH THE SYSTEM
AND ALLOW US TO BE SMARTER WHEN
WE HAD JUST POLICY AND PRACTICE
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE'RE DOING ALL THAT WE CAN --
TO PROMOTE STUDENT SUCCESS THE
OTHER ITEM IS AB.
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE I AM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS IS REQUEST --
YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE A TEACHER
SHORTAGE LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR SUFFERING SOME
OF THE WORST EFFECTS.
OF THIS BILL IS BASED ON
RESEARCH FROM PROFESSOR LINDA
DARLING HAMMOND THAT SHOWS AN
INCENTIVE GRANT CAN BE
ESPECIALLY ATTRACTIVE TO
STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS.
WHO ARE DETERRED FROM GOING INTO
TEACHING BECAUSE OF CONCERNS
ABOUT STUDENT DEBT SO PROVIDING
AN INCENTIVE GRANT WILL HELP US
ATTRACT ALL STUDENTS BUT
ESPECIALLY HELP US TO CHECK
STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS?
AND DIVERSIFY THE THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE THANKS.
I'M ANY SILVA FROM SAITEK WERE
IN NETWORK OF DROPOUT RECOVERY
SCHOOLS I JUST WANTED TO MENTION
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM AND TO IDENTIFY THAT
THERE IS A A A YOUTH GROUP DOES
NOT BE INCLUDED AND ASKED THAT
THEY BE INCLUDED THAT'S
OPPORTUNITY YOUTH THOSE SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR.
OLDS WHO ARE OUT OF SCHOOL AND
OUT OF WORK SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
THE LEGISLATURE'S REPEATEDLY
CALLED FOR MORE WORK ON RE
ENGAGEMENT -- MOST RECENTLY IN A
C. R. ONE OF TWO ACCORDING TO
ESTIMATES COMPILED BY THE
ALLIANCE FOR EXCELLENT EDUCATION.
IF WE RE ENGAGE JUST TEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS THIS LESS THAN
3% OF THE THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND THERE THAT ARE
OUT THERE -- WILL NOT ONLY HELP
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE SKATE TO
SCHOOLS PRISON PIPELINE BUT THE
ALSO CONTRIBUTE A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN
WAGES. HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN GROSS STATE
PRODUCT.
AND FINALLY SEVENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND STATE AND
LOCAL.
REVENUE AND WE WANNA AND COURAGE
JUST TO USE THE LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE STATUS AND NEEDS OF OUT OF
SCHOOL USE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MCCARTY.
I'M HERE MY NAME IS CAME TO MEET
HIM HERE IN BEHALF OF TECHNET
AND WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE
HUNDRED TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN ASUS
FUNDING.
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES THINK IT'S
STEM AND COMPUTER SCIENCE FOR
VITAL.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT.
IT'S CRITICAL TO INVEST IN THIS
FOR THE FUTURE THE STAY IN OUR
COURSE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A COLLECTOR HERE
HERE WITH AT THE TARGET
EXCELLENCE WORKING OUT OF THE
SACRAMENTO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF OUR
PROGRAMMING.
I'M I'M HERE TO ECHO THE WORK IN
THAT AND THE TOP OF MY
COLLEAGUES BUT ALSO TO OFFER A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE NOT BEING
MENTIONED I'M QUITE AS OFTEN AS
THE FACT THAT.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR
OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMMING ARE
ACTUALLY IN THE COMMUNITY AND IT
PROVIDES A KIND OF CIRCULAR LINK
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY FOR MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS WHEN THE PERSON
TEACHING YOUR WORKING WITH YOU
AFTER SCHOOL IS OUR NEIGHBOR.
SOMETIMES EVEN YOUR MOTHER OR
YOUR FATHER I COUSIN OR ANOTHER
TRUSTED ADULT IT REALLY DOES
HELP US WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY FOR
MANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE WORK
WITH.
AND MANY OF OUR STAFF THIS IS
THE VERY FIRST JOB THAT THEY'VE
EVER HAD SO AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS ARE ALSO
SUPPORTING THE COMMUNITY VERY
MAJOR WAY BY CONTINUING YOUR
SUPPORT AND EXTENDING THE
SUPPORT -- AND I URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE THAT SUPPORTER OF OUR
ASUS PROGRAMMING THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MONIQUE TAKE A I
WORK WITH THE CENTER CURRENTLY
WERE ONE OF THE LARGEST.
PROVIDERS AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
IN SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT -- I AM HERE
TODAY TO SHARE SHORT HEART STORY
WITH YOU BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CHILDREN WE ARE DOING THE
HARD WORK AS MY COLLEAGUE ANY
HOUSTON SAID -- WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF CHILDREN
WITH THE SAFETY OF THESE
PROGRAMS CAN PROVIDE AN
ASSISTANCE FOR THE CHILDREN I
WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT ONLY
SAFETY OF?
THEM OFF THE STREET FROM THREE
TO SIX PM AND ALSO THE SAFETY
THAT WE PROVIDE BY HAVING OUR
TEAM LEADERS AND ANY OF THE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE HIRED
TO WORK WITH THESE STUDENTS.
AS MANDATED REPORTERS ONE SHORT
STORY THAT I WILL SHARE WITH YOU --
WHEN I OVERSAW A PROGRAM A FEW
YEARS AGO ONE OF THE STUDENTS
WAS IN MY PROGRAM FOR THREE TO
FOUR YEARS AND WE WERE ABLE TO
GAIN HIS TRUST AND WE WERE?
NOTICING THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
PARENTS AND WE NOTICED THE
DIFFERENCE IN A CHILD'S FOR
BEHAVIOR CHILD IS WILLING TO
OPEN UP AND LET US KNOW ABOUT
ABUSE THAT WAS HAPPENING IN THE
HOME.
AFTER WE REPORTED IT I WAS ABLE
TO HAPPILY AND GRACIOUSLY
FACILITATE A HOUSEHOLD CHANGE ON
SITE ON CAMPUS WHILE I HAD A
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN CHILDREN IN
PROGRAM.
UNBEKNOWNST TO THEM I HELPED
FACILITATED WITH CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT FOR A
TRANSFER FOR THOSE CHILDREN TO
COME OUT OF THE HOME THAT WAS
FULL OF ABUSE AND INTO THEIR
MOTHER'S HOME WHERE THERE WAS
SAFETY AND SECURITY.
THE NEXT DAY WHEN I SAW THAT
CHILD HE LOOKED INTO MY EYES AND
SAID THANK YOU FOR SAVING MY
LIFE THERE IS NO PRICE TAG THAT
I CAN PUT UPON THAT.
BUT I AM HERE TO ASK FOR THE
INCREASE THE ASUS INCREASE THE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION.
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO HELP THESE
CHILDREN AND KEEP THEM SAFE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A PARISHIONER WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA LINES OF BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUBS FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER AND OTHERS WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THAT AUGMENTATION --
TO OTHERS -- NUMBER ELEVEN BY
SOME A MEMBER BERMAN ON BEHALF
OF SEVERAL COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION INCLUDING SAN DIEGO.
PLASTER SANTA BARBARA AND SANTA
CLARA REQUESTING A SHIFT BACK
FOR OF SOME COUNTY PROPERTY TAX
MONEY THAT WAS USED TO BACK FILL
COURT COSTS DURING THE RECESSION.
WE WANT TO SHIP THOSE DOLLARS
BACK TO COUNTY OFFICES AND GIVE
COUNTY OFFICES THE AUTHORITY TO
SPEND THOSE DOLLARS ON STUDENT
SERVICES.
AND FINALLY ON BEHALF OF BUTTE
COUNTY IN SNOW COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER'S -- REQUEST TO
PROVIDE -- THREE YEARS EIGHTY A
PROTECTION -- FOR DISTRICT
AFFECTED BY THE FIRE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
DIXON SLINGERLAND WITH THE USE
POLICY INSTITUTE LOS ANGELES
LEAD AGENCY FOR THE LA PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD NETWORK
REPRESENTING THE FIVE FEDERALLY
DESIGNATED PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOODS IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET REQUEST TO FIND TWENTY
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS THE
STATE.
THIS WOULD SUSTAIN THE FIVE
EXISTING PROMISED NEIGHBORHOODS
AND ADD AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE PROCESS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THIS IS A PRIORITY BUDGET
REQUEST OF THE END CHILD POVERTY
TASK FORCE -- THIS IS ALSO A
GENERAL FUND REQUEST AND NOT
PROP NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
HOW ARE YOU THIS AFTERNOON I'M
JACK ALONG WITH THE GRACE
INSTITUTE AND AND HELP ARE BEING
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN I BELIEVE
THAT YOU'RE AND RECEIPT OF OUR
BUDGET LETTER WITH OVER SIXTY
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS REQUEST.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON PATTY
CHAVEZ WITH SOUTH BAY COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND I REPRESENT TO
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND WE'RE HERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE.
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF THE
HUNDRED MILLION TO ESTABLISH
MORE PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS INITIATIVE WE'VE SEEN FIRST
HAND WHEN COMMUNITIES FAIL
SCHOOLS FAIL ECONOMIES FAIL AS A
FORMER COUNCILMEMBER.
I CAN SHARE THAT NO ONE ENTITY
CAN CHANGE THAT IT'S COMMUNITY
COMING TOGETHER AND PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOOD BRINGS PARTNERS.
ONTO SCHOOL CAMPUSES TO RAISE
CHILDREN TOGETHER. TO MITIGATE
THOSE BARRIERS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO RECENTLY SAID IN A
STORY THAT'S ALL TOO COMMON.
CHILDREN ARE EATING GRAHAM A
LIVING IN A CAR WITH KIDS SHE'S
RAISING LITTLE BOY DOESN'T GOING
TO SCHOOL BECAUSE MOMMY IS GOING
THROUGH CHEMO STORIES UPON
STORIES OF BARRIERS WITH THESE
KIDS.
CAN'T STUDY AND THEY DON'T DO
WELL IN SCHOOL WHEN YOU BRING
RESOURCES ONTO CAMPUS WE TAKE
THAT BURDEN OFF THE TEACHERS WE
HELP THEM WE WORK TOGETHER WE
RAISE THE WHOLE COMMUNITY.
AND WE'RE SEEING THIS IN SAN
DIEGO AND CHULA VISTA WITH
HUNDREDS OF FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH PARENTS
GETTING JOBS WITH -- PARENTS
GETTING COMPUTER -- SUPPORT WITH
COMMUNITIES COMING TOGETHER TO
VOLUNTEER ON THEIR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES WE ASK YOU. TO HELP US
CREATE MORE OF THESE IN
CALIFORNIA THINK DOUBLE THE CITY
THAT YOU WERE WERE YOU WERE A
COUNCIL MEMBER WHAT'S THAT CITY
CHULA VISTA CHULA VISTA.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANTHONY JACKSON I AM A STUDENT
SUCCESS CODE FROM A WERE
CALIFORNIA.
AT TENNIS IN HIGH SCHOOL TO THE
HEAD WERE PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD.
I WANT TO SHARE PERSPECTIVE --
THAT KIND OF PUTS A RESPECT A
LITTLE BIT THE PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOOD NETWORK -- NOT ONLY
A MINE THE STUDENT SUCCESS COACH
ALSO -- DEVELOPED FOR C. BASS
WILL COACH AND A VARSITY
FOOTBALL COACH ON MY CAMPUS.
AND I WAS ABLE TO TAKES ABOUT AS
WELL PLAYERS TO BASS WATERMAN
ABOUT TWENTY MILES DOWN THE ROAD
THE RECORD OR IN A VALLEY.
AND WHEN MY KIDS GOT OFF THE BUS.
THERE WERE IN AWE OF JUST THE
CONDITION OF THE SCHOOL THE WAY
IT LOOKED IT WAS CLEAN IT WAS
NEW.
THE GYM WAS NEW AND EVERYTHING
WAS TAKEN CARE OF AND ONE OF MY
KIDS AX ME HE SAID COACH WHAT IS
THEIR SCHOOL LOOK LIKE THIS.
AND BEFORE I GOT A CHANCE TO
ANSWER.
HE LOOKED UP AND SAID IT'S
ALMOST LIKE.
THE PEOPLE WHO BUILD SCHOOLS
THINK THESE KIDS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT ENOUGH.
AND RIGHT WRONG OR INDIFFERENT.
WHEN MY KIDS OF OUR KIDS SAY?
THE PEOPLE WHO BUILD SCHOOLS
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU
[inaudible]
AND WHAT BETTER WAY TO DISPEL
THAT MYTH THAT YOU GUYS FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE NOT IMPORTANT.
BUT TO MAKE INVESTMENTS.
IN THEIR DAY TO DAY LIVES AND DO
THINGS THAT.
HELP FOR THE EDUCATIONAL
TRAJECTORY AND MAKE THEM NOT
FEEL LIKE SECOND CLASS CITIZENS.
WHEN THEY GET OUT OF THE
EDUCATION OF MAYBE THANK YOU
THANK?
GOOD AFTERNOON MELINDA HALL AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
TO HAYWARD PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF THE SEVEN
YEARS THAT WE HAVE HAD OUR
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT.
OF FROM OUR THREE PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD HIGH SCHOOLS BY 64%
INTO CAL STATE EAST BAY AND WE
TOOK COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE ASK
OF A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CREATE.
THE TOTAL OF TWENTY PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RICHARD REID I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
MISSION PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD IN
SAN FRANCISCO -- AND I THINK
PATTY FROM CHULA VISTA SAID A
VERY WELL -- THAT PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
MAYBE YOU COULD HELP US OUT HERE
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE LETTER
AND SO TRYING TO CONFUSE WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING.
FOR MONEY FROM.
WHAT BUDGET WHAT PART OF THE
BUDGET AND WHERE WOULD IT GO?
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TWENTY
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS NON PROP --
NINETY EIGHT AND IT WOULD FIND
THE EXISTING FIVE PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
WHEN I GO THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION YES FRANCE.
YES SIR.
YEAH -- AND SO VERY QUICKLY --
THEY ARE COLLECTIVE IMPACT
INITIATIVE THAT BRING THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY TOGETHER TO TRY TO
STOP TRYING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM
THAT NO.
SINGLE ORGANIZATION CAN SOLVE ON
ITS OWN WHICH IS HOW DO YOU MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY KID IN THE
COMMUNITY REGARDLESS OF THEIR
INCOME LEVEL.
IS PREPARED TO GO TO COLLEGE --
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN IN THE MISSION
DISTRICT IS -- A DOUBLING OF CAN
TO READING THIS RATES AND OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE GRADUATION
RATE INCREASING FROM 63% 88%.
FOR LATINO STUDENTS -- WE WORK
WITH ABOUT TWENTY PARTNERS ALONG
THE CRADLE TO COLLEGE CONTINUE
ON TO PROVIDE WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
SERVICES.
AND I HAVE SOME HANDOUTS HERE
THAT SHOW STUDIES -- THAT SHOW
THAT THIS TYPE OF INVESTMENT CAN
RESULT IN A SIX DOLLAR RETURN ON
EVERY ONE DOLLAR INVESTED WITH
THROUGH CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
WORK FOR INCREASED --
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE WORK FORCE
INTO THE ECONOMY AS WELL AS
SYSTEM A SAVINGS -- TO THE
SAFETY NET SERVICES ALSO IF IF
IT PLEASES YOU ALL LEAVE THESE --
WITH THE SERGEANT AT ARMS AND
AGAIN JUST WANT TO REITERATE MY
SUPPORT FOR ADDING PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS TO THE BUDGET
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALONG
WITH THE I'M THE DIRECTOR
SEVENTY PIECE YOUTH PROGRAM. FOR
AN ACADEMIC BASED PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES COMPREHENSIVE ACADEMIC
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL SUPPORT TO
YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN THE
MISSION DISTRICT OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
WE'RE ONE OF THE MANY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAKE UP THE
MISSION PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD
NETWORK.
WE HAVE SEEN THE IMPACT THAT THE
PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD MODEL CAN
HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS MODEL WORKS BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES GREATER ACCESS. TO
RESOURCES THAT HELP SUPPORT THE
IMPORTANT WORK WE'RE DOING IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE PARTNERSHIPS CREATED BETWEEN
COMMUNITY SPACE PROGRAMS GIVE
OUR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES A
LARGER POOL OF RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT.
ALL OF OUR YOUTH COME FROM UNDER
PRIVILEGE UNDER RESOURCE
BACKGROUND.
MAKING OUR SERVICES AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF THEIR EDUCATION
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE TOOLS TO
SUCCEED.
ENSURING THE FUTURE OF OUR
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE.
WILL MEAN THAT OUR YOUTH WILL
CONTINUE TO SUCCEED DESPITE THE
CHALLENGES AND DIFFICULTIES THEY
MY FACE IN THEIR LIFE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NORMA
GARCIA I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY NOW BECAUSE HE FOR THE
MISSION ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY IN SAN FRANCISCO.
ALSO KNOWN AS META META IS THE
BACKBONE ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS THE EFFORTS OF MISSION
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND I'M HERE TO SAY THAT PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS WORK.
THERE ARE MANY PROPOSALS THAT
COME BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE TO
BE CONSIDERED FOR FUNDING.
AND EVERYONE HAS URGENT NEEDS
BUT WHAT I CAN SAY HERE IS THAT
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO SEIZE UPON THE
WORK THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE
THROUGH PROMISED NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND TO EXPAND THAT AND TO REAP
THE REWARDS AND TO SECURE THE
FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES SO WITH THIS SIDE.
I HARDLY RISK I REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET ASK OF
ONE HUNDRED MILLION TO SUPPORT
PROBLEMS NEIGHBORHOODS INTO THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT PATTON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
EXTREME SUPPORT OF THE TWO
POSITIONS IN THE BUDGET FOR
THEIR CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANT OVERSIGHT.
AS IMPORTANT AS FUNDING FOR CT
IS ENSURING THAT THAT MONEY IS
GOING TO BE USED RESPONSIBLY AND
GOING TO HIGHLY HIGHLY QUALIFIED
CT PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY THE LANGUAGE THAT
SUPPORTS THE AGRICULTURAL
EDUCATION -- PERSONNEL IS
EXTREMELY APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
A PERSONAL QUEUE DOES HERE ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI -- AS YOU KNOW IS --
FOR IN SUPPORT OF THE ISSUE FOR
OF THE INCREASE IN FUNDING OF
ACES AS YOU KNOW A SUS PROGRAM
SUPPORT CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
THE HIGHEST POVERTY COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND IN THE
CITY OF LA WHICH IS WHY WERE HI
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ERIN ROSS
FROM CITY YEAR AND I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PREVIOUS
SUPPORT OF OUR WORK WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AMERICORPS
MEMBERS SERVING IN CALIFORNIA IN
LA SAN JOSE AND SACRAMENTO.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME WE'RE
ASKING FOR THE STATE TO PLAY A
ROLE IN HELPING TO FUND OUR WORK
SO WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW'S REQUEST AFTER THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
ARE AMERICA MEMBERS DON'T
SUPPLANT TEACHERS THEY SUPPORT
TEACHERS A 96% OF SACRAMENTO
TEACHERS LAST YEAR SAID THAT OUR
AMERICORPS MEMBERS IMPROVE THE
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS.
AND WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CONSIDERATION 30% OF OUR
TEACHERS PURSUE OUR 30% OF OUR
AMERICAN MEMBERS PURSUE TEACHING
AND THAT'S IT BUT WELL TRAINED
TO DIVERSE.
PIPELINE OF TEACHERS FOR THE
STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M KALIN JOHN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE OF LINES OR
YMCAS IN SUPPORT OF INCREASED
FUNDING FOR ASUS PROGRAMS THIS
FUNDING IS VITAL TO ENSURE THAT
THE YMCA'S CAN CONTINUE. TO
SERVE THE PARKS ME THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS THEY SERVE AT
THAT THE ENGINE FIFTY ACES SITES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY ON BEHALF OF FAIR
SABAH THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT OF THE QUEST BY BETTER
TOGETHER FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARSTO HELP THEM
CAN.
CAN YOU THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WORK OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ROSS
BUCKLEY ON HAVE TO SEE IF
SACRAMENTO ALSO IN SUPPORT THE
PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD FUNDING
I'D LIKE TO ECHO HE COMMENTS
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AT THIS
FUNDING WILL HELP US STUDENTS OF
FAMILIES THANKS.
THIS IS A MISTER CHAIRS THERE
ARE SEEM TO HAVE A CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY -- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH A LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM A BECAUSE IT'S KEY TO THE
STATE'S UNDERSTANDING OF STUDENT
PROGRESSION OUTCOMES CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS.
AND ULTIMATELY MEETING FUTURE
WORK FORCE DEMANDS -- WE MAY
HAVE STRONG SEGMENTAL DATA BUT
IF IT'S NOT CONNECTED IN A WAY
THAT REALLY ALLOWS US TO
UNDERSTAND A STUDENTS FULL
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE THAT IT
REALLY LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
MAKE POLICY AND BUDGET DECISIONS.
THAT ENABLE AND SUPPORT THEIR
SUCCESS -- I THINK TODAY IS
CONVERSATION -- HIGHLIGHTS THE
CRITICAL NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE CLEAR FROM THE BEGINNING
ABOUT OUR GOALS FOR THIS SYSTEM --
INTO THAT AND WE THINK THAT THE
LA -- OUTLINED SOME STRONG
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE WORTH
EXPLORING INCLUDING -- DEFINING
THE INITIAL SCOPE AND LONG TERM
VISION OF THE PROJECT
ESTABLISHING A GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE THAT IS COMPRISED OF A
MAJORITY OF NON SEGMENTAL
MEMBERS.
AND THAT A DATA SYSTEM IS
CENTRALIZED THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MY NAME IS KATHY HALL I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE.
I PARENT TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT THE
INCREASED FUNDING FOR AFTER
SCHOOL AND SAFETY PROGRAMS.
ALSO IN STE WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF TWO ITEMS LISTED IN
ISSUE NUMBER SIX NUMBER TEN IN
EIGHTEEN WHICH I'M FUND MENTAL
HEALTH.
PROGRAMS AND PUTTING MORE MENTAL
EMPLOYEES INTO OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
STEVE PENCE SO I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR OUR EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS FOR THE YMCA
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY -- WE SERVE
NINETY THREE PROGRAMS ACROSS
FOURTEEN DISTRICTS -- AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD MANY OF THE
BENEFITS FROM OUR OUR PANEL
TODAY -- I WANT TO ECHO JUST
WHAT ONE OF THE OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTS WISE THIS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT A MUCH NEEDED COLA FOR OUR
EXISTING STAFF -- THERE
LITERALLY IS A CRISIS TO FIND
NEW STAFF TO SERVE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND SO -- I'D ASSET YOU
PRIORITIZE THE HUNDRED TWELVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR THE
PROGRAM AS YOU WERE LOOKING TO
SERVE THE STUDENTS OUTSIDE AND
FAMILIES -- THAT WERE FUNDED TO
PROVIDE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS FOR MIRACLE
HEAD START CALIFORNIA -- SERVING --
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED FIFTY
AGENCIES THAT SERVE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE MOST AT
RISK CHILDREN EASIER -- TO FIVE
HEAD START PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
IN THE MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM AS
NOTED I THINK IN THE THIRTY HEAD
START SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION'S
FINAL REPORT.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S JUST AN
APPROPRIATE TO INCLUDE HEAD
START EQUITABLY IN FUNDING FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD SYSTEM AND SO
TODAY WE'RE SHARING OUR
COALITION LETTER OF SUPPORT FOR
BUDGET REQUEST OF TWENTY MILLION.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PATRICK MORE TEAR
WITH FIGHT CRIME INVEST IN KIDS
REPRESENTING -- LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEADERS AND VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE
FROM ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- I WANNA MAKE THE
POINT THROUGH THE PUBLIC SAFETY
LANDS.
THAT AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
HELPED CUT CRIME CONSIDERABLY
BUT KEEPING KIDS OFF THE STREETS
AWAY FROM GANGS.
DURING AS HE SAID -- GERMAN --
FROM THE HOURS OF THREE TO SIX
PM WHICH ARE THE PRIME TIME FOR
JUVENILE CRIME.
IT'S NOT JUST CATCHY IT'S TRUE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA'S MADE A
GROUNDBREAKING COMMITMENT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS BUT MORE FUNDING
IS NEEDED AS THESE PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
ONGOING INCREASES TO THE MINIMUM
WAGE.
WHICH IS ALREADY UP 50%.
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT A
HUNDRED TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET AND TO HELP RAISE PER
STUDENT FUNDING TO NINE SEVENTY
FIVE PER DAY.
IN ORDER TO KEEP THE DOORS OPEN
AT QUALITY PROGRAMS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE -- AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR GETTING THE BALL
ROLLING ON PROP.
SIXTY FOUR REVENUE FOR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AS AN
ALTERNATIVE A REVENUE SOURCE.
AND I ALSO MAKE THE POINT THIS
MONEY THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
WON'T SOLVE THE CRISIS -- BUT IT
WILL HELP EASE THE PRESSURE THAT
THESE FAMILIES PROVIDERS ARE
FEELING SO FOR THAT ASK YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OTHER WILLIAMS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
NETWORK I WANT TO REITERATE THE
NUMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID MANY
TIMES THAT.
WE ARE EXPECTING ALMOST ONE IN
FOUR OF OUR PROGRAMS TO CLOSE
STORES AND TWENTY TWENTY WHICH
IS NEXT YEAR SO NINETY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS COULD BE.
WITHOUT PROGRAMS AND THAT
IMPACTS NOT ONLY THOSE STUDENTS
BUT THEIR PARENTS THEIR FAMILY
THEIR COMMUNITIES THOSE STAFF
AND SO THAT IS A HUGE IMPACT ON
OUR STATE NOT ONLY THAT BUT I
WANTED TO ADDRESS SOME COMMENTS
EARLIER ABOUT FUNDS LEFT ON THE
FLOOR.
THIS PROGRAM IS EXTREMELY
OVERSUBSCRIBED AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER OVER FOUR TIMES THE
REQUEST FOR FUNDING AVAILABLE.
AND IT IS A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE ABOUT 122% EACH YEAR
THAT IS RETURNED TO THE STATE.
AND IN ADDITION THERE IS A STATE
COMMITTEE THAT LOOKS AT HOW THAT
NUMBER CAN BE EVEN SMALLER EACH
YEAR SO THAT THESE FUNDS.
DO YOU GET OUT A 100% TO OUR
PROGRAMS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ IS PROPOSAL OUR REQUEST
FOR THREE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
PROP THIRTY NINE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS.
I WAS ALSO ASKED TO PASS ALONG
THE SUPPORT OF NEXT GEN AFTER
THIS PROPOSAL AS WELL THESE
INVEST IT IS INVESTMENTS.
MAKE YOU KNOW FUNDING TOWARDS
ENERGY EFFICIENCY CLEAN ENERGY
MODERATE AIR CONDITIONING AND
HEATING UP FOR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS WHICH NOT ONLY SAVE
SCHOOLS MONEY ON THERE AND
ENERGY BILLS BUT IT ALSO CREATES
MORE COMFORTABLE AND HEALTHY
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. FOR OUR
KIDS -- AT SCHOOLS AND DINO
DESPITE POOR AIR QUALITY OUTSIDE
OR EXTREME TEMPERATURES WHICH
ARE BECOMING MORE AND MORE
FREQUENT WITH OUR CHANGING
CLIMATE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DIANA DOMINGUEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER THE CHILD CARE
LINES OF LOS ANGELES.
SEIU AND UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS --
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
FOR FUNDING FOR AFTER SCHOOL AND
AFTER SCHOOL.
EDUCATION AND SAFETY THANK YOU.
DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AROUND DATE AT THIS WE
THINK MAKES A SMART SET UP A
PROCESS FOR MAKING.
SMART AND THOUGHTFUL INVESTMENTS
TO REALLY HAVING A A CRADLE TO
CAREER DATA SYSTEM ALSO ELECTED
NOTRE SUPPORT FOR THE FUNDING
FOR AFTER SCHOOL I THINK IT'S
IT'S ALREADY BEEN SPOKEN TO WHY
IT'S SO CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE
THOSE PROGRAMS FOR OUR YOUTH.
AND THEN ALSO NOTE OUR SUPPORT --
FOR MISTER MEDINA IS PROPOSAL
AROUND ETHNIC STUDIES WE THINK
INCREASING ACCESS ACCESS TO
ETHNIC STUDIES IMPORT IT COURSES.
IS CRITICAL AND THEN ALSO DOCTOR
WEBBER'S PROPOSAL FOR LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS I'M LOOKING
FOR IS TO BLOCK GRANT THANK YOU.
HELLO DAVE ALL ROUTES WITH THE
SCHOOL ENERGY COALITION AND
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING AND SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
AND SALAS HAS REQUESTED CONTINUE
PROPOSITION.
THIRTY NINE CREATES.
GOOD PAYING JOBS.
MEETS HELPS ME CALIFORNIA'S
CHRONICLES IN PROVIDES MONEY FOR
CLASSROOMS.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAO HIGHLAND ON
BEHALF OF THE PARADISE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE TO US
SUPPORT.
THE NUMBER GALLAGHER DECEMBER
DOLLIES PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE A
THREE YEAR EIGHTY A HOLD
HARMLESS.
AND A THREE YEAR EIGHTY RAMP
DOWN PERIOD FOR THE DISTRICTS
AFFECTED BY THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN A CAMPFIRE -- THE START
AND JUST PASSED OUT OR SUPPORT
LETTER -- AND JUST KEEP MY
COMMENTS SHORT AD THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT HAS THE SUPPORT OF
BOTH MANAGEMENT AND LABOR AND WE
THINK THAT UNIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORK WITH YOU GET THIS IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS US THE WHITE SEA IN HERE
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER IS
PROPOSAL -- TO FUND THE LOW
PERFORMING STUDENT BLOCK GRANT --
I WANT TO MENTION THAT -- WE ARE
JOINED BY A COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT BLACK PARALLEL SCHOOL
BOARD GREATER SACRAMENTO URBAN
LEAGUE -- THE URBAN LAKES OF LOS
ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO NATIONAL
COALITION OF A HUNDRED BLACK
WOMEN.
AT NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK TO
NAME A FEW -- THESE AT THIS
BLOCK GRANT PROVIDES -- CRITICAL --
SUPPORT FOR STRUGGLING STUDENTS
WERE NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVING
TARGETED FUNDS -- WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BLOCK GRANT
THAT GIVEN THAT IT IS AN
EXISTING.
PROGRAM BUT WE ALSO -- A DOCTOR
WEBER MADE MENTION OF SOME --
ISSUES AROUND IMPLEMENTATION --
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE THAT INSURERS FUNDING
GOES TO THE LOWEST PERFORMING
STUDENTS SUBGROUP THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS MIL
ASIK I'VE CALIFORNIA POLICY
SOLUTIONS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
OUR PAN AFRICAN GLOBAL TRADE
INVESTMENT CONFERENCE.
AND HEART INSTITUTE.
ROCKETS TO IT IS A GROUP OF NON
PROFIT IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS AN ALL
VOLUNTEER STAFF WE WORK WITH
KIDS IN.
IN EXTENT A CONTINUATION HIGH
SCHOOLS OUR KIDS STRUGGLING IN
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND NONE OF US
NONE OF THE MEMBERS GET PAID BUT
THEY SUPPORT.
HI DOCTOR WEBBER'S APPROPRIATION
BECAUSE WE THINK THIS BEGINS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THESE KIDS
WE HAVE BEFORE THEY COME TO US
SO WE STRONG SUPPORTER -- THE
THE MEMBERS ARE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A LIST KIßM
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
OF THREE OF REQUEST THAT YOU
HEARD ABOUT TODAY -- THE FIRST
IS THE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO ESTABLISH THE LONGITUDINAL
DATA.
SYSTEM -- WE'VE MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE WORKING GROUP
REALLY FOCUS ON STUDENT IN
FAMILY MEMBERSHIP AS WELL AS
THEIR EXPERIENCES -- AND WE
AGREE WITH US ABOUT THE LA --
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE FIRST
LEARNED ABOUT TODAY ESPECIALLY --
THE MAJORITY OF MEMBERS AND GPA
BEING NON SEGMENTAL OF
REPRESENTATIVES -- WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PLACE A REQUEST BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR A LONG TIME THAT THERE BE --
INCENTIVES -- SUCH AS FINANCIAL
AID WHICH WE KNOW -- WORK TO GET
MORE TEACHERS IN THE SYSTEM WE
ALSO WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT
FOR TWO OF THE ON INCREASES FOR
THE DEPARTMENTS DEPARTMENT OF ED
STATE OPERATIONS AND THAT IS UP
TO PROGRAM STAFF FOR THE CAREER
TECH EDUCATION AND SENATE GRANT.
OF WORK AND THEN TO FOR THE
STATE AND FEDERAL ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEMS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
THERESA PALACE AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CHARTER ACCOUNTABILITY RESOURCE
AND SUPPORT NETWORK OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS CARS NET.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT
CARS AND IT'S BEEN A SUCCESSFUL
MODEL FOR BUILDING STRONG
CHARTER SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA THESE PAST FEW YEARS.
AND THAT INCLUDES X. CREATING
SOME EXCELLENT TOOLS AND
RESOURCES FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- WE'RE VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE WORK THAT
WE DO AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT WE
RISK.
LOSING ALL THAT.
THE CARD THAT HAS BUILT A LOT TO
HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
IMPROVE.
THE OVERSIGHT OF CHARTER SCHOOL
OF THAT ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE WORKED REALLY HARD TO
MAINTAIN A NEUTRAL POSITION AND
WE BELIEVE THE ROLE OF BALANCING
QUALITY.
OVERSIGHT PRACTICES WHILE
ALLOWING CHARTER SCHOOLS TO READ
TEEN TO REMAIN A THOMAS IS A
REAL DIFFICULT BALANCING ACT BUT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT WITH
INTEGRITY.
AND SO THERE'S NO OTHER
ORGANIZATION LIKE CARS NET IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S BECAUSE
CARS AND IT WAS BUILT BY
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL EXPERTS.
OVERSEE CHARTER SCHOOLS AND WE
KNOW WHAT IS BEST BECAUSE WE
HAVE LIVED AND BREATHED IT
EVERYDAY WHEN WE DO OUR JOBS.
WE KNOW HOW TO DO IT RIGHT AND
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICT OVERSIGHT.
I KNOW IT'S NOT SEXY AND
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT EVEN EASY TO
DO OUR JOBS BUT WHEN WE WALKED
DOWN THE HALLS OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
WE THAT WE OVERSEE AS PART OF
OUR JOB WE SEE THE REASON WHY WE
DO IT IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
CHILDREN.
AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CLOSE THE ONES THAT ARE
BAD ACTORS AND KEEP THE ONES
THAT ARE OPEN.
SO THIS IS ALL DONE THROUGH
KNOWLEDGE AND THREE TRAINING OF
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING AND I
SINCERELY HOPE YOU WILL CONSIDER
MAKING AN INVESTMENT IN THE
CAR'S NOT BUDGET.
FOR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TWENTY
PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE HAVE BEEN -- ONE OF
THAT REGIONAL LEAD SOME PART OF
THE CARS NET NETWORK FOR THE
PAST. THREE YEARS WE HAD A
FEDERAL GRANTS TO START THE
PROGRAM BUT THAT FEDERAL GRANT
IS COMING TO AN END THERE'S SO
MUCH CONVERSATION AS THERE
SHOULD BE WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW ABOUT OVERHAULING THE
WAY THAT THE STATE HAS A
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND DOING A GOOD JOB.
OF CHARTER OVERSIGHT WILL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE ON THE GROUND AND
THEY ARE GROUND ZERO POINT ONE
FOR DOING THAT OVERSIGHT AND
DOING A GOOD JOB OF IT.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO RESOURCE
THEM THIS IS A RELATIVELY
MINIMAL ASKING COMPARISON TO
MANY OTHERS AND WE HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL INCLUDE A ONE
TIME APPROPRIATION FOR CARS NINE
YOUR BUDGET.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
I I JUST WANTED TO ECHO A COUPLE
OF THE PUBLIC -- COMMENTS -- IN
MY SUPPORT FOR CARS NET -- I I
VERY STRONGLY FEEL THAT
OVERSIGHT.
OF CHARTERS IS NEEDED AND AS WAS
STATED -- WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
WE'VE SEEN A BILLS AND
LEGISLATION TO DO THAT BUT CARS
THAT IS DONE A GREAT JOB -- IN
THE PAST THERE FEDERAL GRANT --
IS ENDING SO I WOULD HOPE.
AND ASKED THAT THE STATE OF FIND
CARS IN IT AND I HAVE IN FRONT
OF ME -- LETTER COALITION OF
EDUCATIONAL GROUPS INCLUDING IN --
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION ACTS -- BECAUSE BILL
ALL IN SUPPORT OF FUNDING --
CARS NOW.
TRY I SUPPORT THEIR YES
THEREAFTER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AMANDA DICKEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND ALSO APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT THAT WE'VE GOTTEN FROM
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- WE ARE
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE CARS
THAT BUDGET ASK IT'S EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS EVERY THREE
YEARS -- AND I ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS SOME SUPPORT -- FOR THE
BUDGET ASK FOR LOCAL PLANNING
COUNCILS AS WELL WHICH IS SIX
POINT SEVEN MILLION A FEDERAL
DOLLARS THANKS.
LIZ BUT THAT'S ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS TO SUPPORT FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR CARS THAT
THANK YOU YOU CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE FIRST OF ALL LIKE
TO REQUEST SUPPORT FOR FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT A COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL
NUTRITION AND WELLNESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT WILL PROVIDE QUALIFY
NUTRITION EXPERTS WHO WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TRAININGS PARENT EDUCATION AND
EVIDENCE BASED RESOURCES TO
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
IN THEIR REGION.
CURRENTLY OF FUNDING HAS BEEN
UNSTABLE AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE WOULD REQUEST FUNDING FROM
THE STATE.
IN VARIOUS -- APPORTIONMENT THAT
WOULD AND CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM
FOR THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION WE SUPPORT THE CAR'S
NOT REQUEST SO I WON'T REPEAT
THAT ON THE EIGHTEENTH A MILLION
DOLLARS LAKE TAHOE IS A REGIONAL
LEAD AND SO WE KNOW THE VALUE OF
THAT PROGRAM.
ALSO OF WACO CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST FOR THE
LOWEST PERFORMING PUPILS -- THAT
IS THE REQUESTED DOCTOR WEBER --
THAT WAS LISTED IN ITEM SIX AND
WE WERE ALSO ORIGINAL SUPPORTERS
OF THE ORIGINAL REQUEST TO
SUPPORT THE LOWEST PERFORMING
PEOPLE SUB GROUPS AND SO WE
CONTINUE TO URGE.
A SUPPORT IN CONSIDERATION FOR
THAT ITEM.
LASTLY WE'RE ALREADY ON RECORD
AS SUPPORTING ITEM ONE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM AND
ALSO FOR ITEM.
FOR THE AFTER SCHOOL IN SAFETY
PROGRAM SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE COMING
WEEKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
A MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
DEAN GESTURE ON BEHALF OF ADVICE
I ALSO A FORMER TEACHER WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CREATE.
A STUDENT LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM TO LINK DATA ACROSS
SEGMENTS AND TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO MAKE
DEEPER INSIGHTS INTO HOW
STUDENTS ARE DOING -- THEIR
OTHER LARGE STATES THAT DO THIS --
WHICH HELPS THEIR LEGISLATORS
MAKE GREAT DECISIONS ON
PRIORITIZING LIMITED RESOURCES --
AND LAST I JUST LIKE TO ECHO.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM PUBLIC
ADVOCATES AND THE REQUEST FOR
INCREASED CAPACITY AT THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING -- TO CONDUCT
REPORT AND ANALYZE MEANINGFUL
DATA -- ABOUT TEACHER
PREPARATION AND THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE AT LARGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANDREA
BALL ON THREE ISSUES FIRST ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
MARIN COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET REQUEST
LISTED AS ITEM -- ELEVEN TO UNDO
THE SHIFT OF THAT.
PROPERTY TAX TO RESTORE THEM TO
COUNTY SCHOOLS.
SECOND WE SUPPORT THE CARS THAT
REQUEST ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESPECIALLY IN THE GROWING
SENSITIVITY AROUND CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
I THINK THE SUPPORT AND TRAINING
OF CARS THAT IS -- EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT AND FINALLY ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
REQUEST LAKE -- MENTION FOR
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL NUTRITION
EDUCATION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR HOUSE ABOUT WITH UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIA UP PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THE PROPOSAL TO
RESTORE MODERNIZE THE HEALTHY
START INITIATIVE -- WITHIN CD IN
COLLABORATION WITH -- THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES -- I WILL KEEP MY
REMARKS PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON THE
FISCAL COMPONENTS OF OF THIS
PROPOSAL AS WE'VE HAD A CHANCE
OR TO DISCUSS SOME OF THE POLICY
MERITS -- IN ASSEMBLY EDUCATION --
THE PROPOSAL AS IT STANDS -- IS
FOR SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER
FOUR YEARS TO RESTART -- THE
HEALTHY START PROGRAM WITHIN CD --
TO PROVIDE SOME STATE OPERATIONS
FUNDING -- AND AND THEN TO
IMPLEMENT A A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
PLANNING AN OPERATIONAL GRANTS
TO GO TO LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES -- IN COLLABORATION
WITH LOCAL PARTNERS ACROSS
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES A
SAFETY NET SERVICES -- AND
EDUCATION ACADEMIC SERVICES --
AND WE YOU KNOW WE KNOW FROM THE
ORIGINAL HEALTHY START OF THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS REALLY
QUITE STRIKING -- THERE'S A
REQUIREMENTS IN THE PROPOSAL TO
HAVE FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR
INVESTED BY THE STATE FOR
DOLLARS -- INDIRECT SERVICES --
WE SAW ALSO IN THE ORIGINAL
HEALTHY START THAT COULD GO UP
TO SIXTEEN DOLLARS FOR EVERY.
DOLLAR INVESTED -- IN
CONSIDERING THE CURRENT FUNDING
LANDSCAPE WITH SO MANY DOLLARS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND THROUGH
LOCAL PLANNING PROCESSES WE SEE
THIS IS AN URGENT MATTER TO
COORDINATE THOSE SERVICES --
THAT CHILDREN FAMILY SO
DESPERATELY NEED -- CHILDREN ARE
PRESENT NOT JUST OUR FUTURE SO
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS
GREAT -- BUT WE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING TODAY -- AND SO WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JANICE GALLON
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND A
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE MARCH OF DIMES -- IN SUPPORT
OF THE BUDGET REQUEST TO FUND
THE RESTORATION OF MODERNIZATION
OF THE HEALTHY START ADDITION.
SIX I'M WE SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
TO CONNECT COMMUNITY SERVICES TO
FAMILIES THROUGH SCHOOLS.
AND COMMUNITY AGENCIES FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES -- THIS DATA DRIVEN
PROGRAM WORKS BECAUSE IT'S BUILT
AROUND TRUSTED COMMUNITY LEADERS
SUPPORTING ACCESS AND IMPROVING
FOLLOW UP -- WE KNOW FROM THE
PREVIOUS ITERATION THAT HEALTHY
START IMPROVES MATH AND READING
SCORES AND GRADUATION RATES.
AND ALSO REDUCES DRUG USE -- SO
WE DON'T NEED TO WRING OUR HANDS
ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN WE KNOW THIS
PROGRAM WORKS.
AND THIS APPROACH COULD NOT BE
UPDATED NOW TO ESPECIALLY
FOCUSED ON WHAT WE NOW KNOW
ABOUT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF OVERCOMING
TOXIC STRESS AND THE BURDEN OF
THE LACK OF MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
FOR CHILDREN IN THE STATE -- AND
IT CAN ALSO SUPPORT TEACHERS BY
LINKING FAMILIES WITH ALL THE
SERVICES THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO TRANSLATE NOW --
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT TOXIC STRESS
ON THE DEVELOPING CHILD?
INTO A POLICY THAT WE KNOW WORKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME S
ANDREA PERRY I'M HERE
REPRESENTING TODAY CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE.
AND THOUSANDS OF CRIME SURVIVORS
IN OUR STATE TODAY -- WE ARE CO
SPONSOR OF AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE
IN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS TO RESTART
HEALTHY START TO PLANO.
CSJ IS A NOT EXCUSE ME SEE SSJ
IS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
IS DEDICATED TO REMOVING
BARRIERS AND PROVIDING SUPPORT
FOR CRIME SURVIVORS BOTH ADULTS
AND CHILDREN.
HEALTHY START TO POINT A WILL
TARGET SCHOOLS AS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SERVING A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN MARGINALIZED DUE TO POVERTY
ISOLATION IMMIGRATION STATUS AND
OTHER -- SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
THAT IMPACT THEIR HEALTH THE
TRAJECTORY OF SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN -- WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY CRIME CHANGES
DRASTICALLY TOWARDS THE JUVENILE
AND ADULT PRISON SYSTEM?
CALIFORNIA TODAY SPENDS BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO HOUSE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IF DOLLARS ARE
SHIFTED TO PROVIDING RESOURCES
AND SERVICES AND SCHOOLS FOR
CHILDREN WHO ARE IMPACTED BY
CRIME THERE WOULD BE LESS OF A
NEED FOR THE ROBUST PRISON
DOLLARS AND SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL STREAMLINE AND
INTEGRATE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE --
THAT SERVE THESE CHILDREN AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH MORE EFFECTIVE
PREVENTION AND EARLY.
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DE I
GUY GOES ON BEHALF OF THE UC
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION -- WE
SUPPORT YOU SEE STUDENTS FROM
ALL ACROSS THE STATE AND ARE
REALLY EXCITED AND REALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED LUNCH USUAL DATA SYSTEM --
AS SOME OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED
BEFORE ME -- THEY IT'S YOU KNOW
REALLY WOULD HELP TO CAPTURE
SOON EXPERIENCES THAT HELPED --
TO HIM MAKE FOR THEIR CHOICES --
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
UNIVERSITIES -- WE ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THERE OUGHT THERE IS
STATE REPRESENTATION AND
OVERSIGHT ON THE COMMITTEE THAT
WOULD BE CREATED TO OVERSEE
ON THIS LOGICAL DATA SYSTEM.
IN WITH THAT THANK.
HELLO DEANNA NEIGHBOR FROM THE
OPPORTUNITY INSTITUTE WE ALSO
STAFF THAT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS NETWORK.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR ASK TO REFUND TO
THE HEALTHY START PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ONE ECHO THE
COLLEAGUES ARE COMING TO MY
COLLEAGUE PAMELA GIVES FROM LAKE --
IN SUPPORT OF SCHOOL NUTRITION
EDUCATION AND TRAINING FUNDING
FOR COUNTY OFFICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE CHALLENGE
OF IT WITH A MASSIVE PROJECT
CALIFORNIA HERE TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- GOMEZ REYES
IS UNDER FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
QUEST FOR BILINGUAL IN BY THEIR
ST YOU CATION PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THEY'RE GETTING FASTER A GOOD
AFTERNOON SERRA LOIS WITH TEACH
PLUS -- FIRST OUR TEACHERS
WANTED TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
LUNCH IT'LL DATA SYSTEM AS
EDUCATORS WHO USE DATA TO INFORM
THEIR PRACTICE ON A DAILY BASIS
THEY SEE THE VALUE OF THIS
IMPORTANT SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OF THE LA --
BUT FORD INCLUDING THE QUESTION
ABOUT -- EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES OF
GRADUATES OF OUR CSU AND YOU SEE
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS
WHICH IS WHY THEY THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT THE CDC DATA IS
INCLUDED IN THE LAUNCH OF THE
THE SYSTEM -- WE ALSO WANT TO
SUPPORT -- THE ADDITIONAL THE
QUEST FOR ADDITIONAL CAPACITY AT
THE CDC -- THAT OUR OUR
COLLEAGUES AT PUBLIC ADVOCATES
TALKED ABOUT -- WE ALSO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER RES
RIVAS IS REQUEST FOR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM.
AND WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAHAM AS RAISES A PROPOSAL TO
INVEST AND BY LITERACY AND BUY
IT I THINK WE'LL ISM PARTICULAR
INTERESTED IN THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
WE'VE GOT ALL THOSE DOWN HERE.
HERE'S HERE'S PROOF HERE.
MULTIPLE PAGES THIS BUDGET IDEAS.
SO THEY'RE ALL UNDER
CONSIDERATION.
AND WITH THAT RICHARD THANK YOU